foreign
thank you
welcome to the house uh Judiciary
Committee and uh I'm going to begin by
recognizing representative Manos to lead
us in the Pledge of Allegiance
thank you
good morning
um
we have a number of bills and proposed
Constitutional Amendments on for hearing
uh today
um
I see a number
of cards uh for the first for the first
bill cacr-2
um
as you know we've scheduled this hearing
for an hour and a half and I'm going I'm
going to sort of start out with the
presumption that everybody will be
relative that well everybody will sort
of say what they have to say and be
relatively brief so I'd rather not try
to impose time limits but if it starts
to look like we're going to run way over
because people are you know just
going on longer than being brief I may
have to impose a time limit so that we
retain some kind of uh some kind of
adherence to uh the schedule we have
today I'm not you know I'm not looking
to be right on the money but if it looks
like we would go way over I then they
um impose some time limits the other
thing I would like to say is uh we are
all very aware that these um
that the issues that we're hearing today
raise uh can be very you know very
strongly held views on both sides of
these issues and that's fine that's
that's exactly what what you'd expect in
a democracy
we on this committee despite the the
strong disagreements we may have had on
many many bills have always conducted a
respectful debate among each other and
I'm very gratified and I know my
colleagues feel the same way uh about
our ability to do that and so what I
would ask please is this is the House of
Representatives and I would please ask
you to also uh conduct your what are
your testimony provide your testimony in
that same respectful man thank you with
that um I'm going to uh call first uh on
cacr2 on the sponsor of the bill
representative Amanda toll Miss tall
no you know you need the red thing there
you go good morning can you hear me
better now
honorable member
member Sherry committee my name is
Amanda Elizabeth toll and I represent
Cheshire 16 which encompasses Keen
Walpole Hinsdale Chesterfield Surrey in
Westmoreland New Hampshire I'm here
today as the prime sponsor of cacr2 New
Hampshire's reproductive Liberty
Amendment and soon it's going to
actually be Amanda Elizabeth Soto
because I just got engaged on Saturday
night so
um to my partner Alberto so very excited
about that
um I had an abortion when I was a
teenager and approximately 11 weeks ago
I gave birth to my second child Jordan
who's here too
um and it hasn't been easy I got a
terrible case of pups while pregnant
needed iron transfusions and the sleep
deprivation has been especially hard
my son is such a blessing and I'm
grateful to care for him with the most
wonderful loving partner by my side
but parenting is likely one of the
hardest things one can do and it
shouldn't be forced upon people
because I was able to have children when
I was ready and not before that I've
been able to become a state
representative who's advocating for
Public Policy based in compassion and
justice
I'm tremendously grateful for being able
to obtain the abortion care I needed
when I was younger
sharing my own abortion story for years
and hearing the stories of others I know
one thing for sure
abortion care is an intersectional issue
people of all economic classes races and
religions access abortion care legal
barriers to abortion will not stop
abortions they will only keep
disenfranchised folks from accessing the
care they need sometimes with deadly
results
with all the attacks on Reproductive
Rights it's critical to lay the
foundation for proactive legislation to
protect them
constitutional protections for
Reproductive Rights are imperative for
the following reasons
Federal so I'm so sorry I'm just going
to I
um grab my phone because I help out all
my paper workloads here but um I'm not
seeing it
um
yes thank you so much
please thank you for your patience
thank you
okay
so constitutional protections are the
gold standard as they give the highest
level of legal protection in addition to
the purposely bold and Progressive
content of the New Hampshire
reproductive Liberty Amendment the fact
that it is a constitutional amendment
means it's not subject to the governor's
veto and it's a lot harder to undo and
would mean that we do not need to fight
tooth and nail for Reproductive Freedom
each time it goes before the state
legislature we don't want legislators to
be able to play political ping pong with
people's Reproductive Rights every new
session
this bill is also a reproductive Justice
bill it isn't just about abortion rights
but also about the right to have
children when you want to have them free
from state-sanctioned violence
sister song a collective of women of
color fighting for Reproductive Justice
defines this term as the human right to
maintain personal bodily autonomy have
children not have children and parent
the children we have in safe and
sustainable communities
cacdr2 models this more expansive vision
of what it means to have true
reproductive autonomy it is meant to
protect the right for folks to end
pregnancies or to choose when to become
pregnant this means that it will protect
the right of abortion and birth control
at the same time that it protects
Granite Staters from state-sanctioned
violence like force sterilizations
New Hampshire citizens should be able to
directly weigh in on the Reproductive
Rights and affirm their values relating
to reproductive autonomy by giving these
rights the highest legal protections New
Hampshire residents are overwhelmingly
pro-reproductive freedom indeed during
the last Judiciary Committee hearing on
the New Hampshire reproductive Liberty
Amendment last year
1413 constituents signed in in favor and
only 134 posed putting this issue on the
ballot as a constitutional amendment
will allow residents to directly show
support for Reproductive Rights as an
issue of personal Liberty that is very
important to Granite Staters
this past November three states opted to
take this path Michigan California and
Vermont affirmed abortion rights and
state ballot proposals voters in all
three states amended their constitutions
to support Reproductive Rights this bill
which utilizes the same language as our
neighbor Vermont just passed lays the
groundwork for doing the same thing here
in New Hampshire I hope that you will
vote in favor of cacr2 and allow New
Hampshire constituents to weigh in on
reproductive autonomy thank you so much
for hearing my testimony and I'm happy
to answer questions
questions some questions from members of
the committee
not seeing anything there's one I'm
sorry yes representative Greece
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative
what reproductive decisions do the
biological fathers of pre-born babies
have the right to make
can you please repeat the question
sure
what reproductive decisions do the
biological fathers of pre-born babies
have the right to make thank you so much
for the question this constitutional
amendment is to affirm everyone's
personal for themselves their
reproductive autonomy and so
um it is about your own reproductive
autonomy and New Hampshire constituents
having the right to weigh in on that
directly thank you
other questions and please advise given
the given our the way we're sort of
physically set up please raise your hand
so I may not see if you don't any other
question
seeing none thank you very much thank
you can I just say one
more okay so I wanted to say that
so the goal of the reproductive Liberty
amendment is to enshrine into our state
constitution what medical practices were
happening in New Hampshire prior to
recently past abortion ban and for
nearly 50 years the state of New
Hampshire trusted doctors and patients
to make these decisions around abortion
care including later in pregnancy
these are complicated and often
heartbreaking decisions and there was
bipartisan agreement for decade after
decade that said New Hampshire supports
privacy particularly when it comes to
these personal medical decisions and so
again I think allowing the voters to
weigh in on this because we know it's
popular across the board
um is really the right thing to do and I
urge you to pass cacrt cacr2 New
Hampshire's reproductive Liberty
Amendment thank you for hearing my
testimony today right thank you
um I'm next going to call on
representative Joe Shapiro and I'm uh
the the next witch I'm going to just
sort of announce the next witness after
him so people can get ready and what I
would say is the next witness after Mr
Shapiro will be Sean Philly I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly the only
thing I would say is if there are other
reps or members of the legislature
Senators who are here and you're here
you're you're here because you have
other business I recognize that there's
a lot of other hearings going on so I
will take those reps or Senators out of
order after representative Shapiro
because of their of the fact that they
have other business
um so I see representative daughter so
I'll ask representative not to testify
after representative Shapiro
representative Shapiro thank you for
being here thank you chairman Lynn and
thank you committee members
um I want to just take a moment to thank
you for your Mr chairman for your
introduction about how we want to
conduct business here and in the
legislature I appreciate it for the
record I am representative Joe Shapiro
representing Cheshire 16 which consists
of keen Ward 2 and 9 small surrounding
towns
in anticipation of today's hearing I
wrestled with what to say as a man I was
unsure that I had something to offer to
a discussion about reproductive autonomy
eventually I decided that speaking on
behalf of this bill which will enshrine
the new in the New Hampshire
Constitution a woman's right to make
decisions about her body her health care
and her well-being was an opportunity to
honor the two most important women in my
life
when I was a very young adult my
girlfriend became pregnant we were not
ready we were scared and I must admit I
was clueless about how to navigate a
situation like this
emotionally and practically
when my girlfriend chose to have an
abortion it was my mother who came to
her side taking her to the clinic coming
to our apartment to offer healing and
support and most importantly lending her
strength communicating by the force of
her very nature that there was no reason
to feel shame
fast forward more than 10 years another
unplanned pregnancy my wife and I knew
we wanted children but we were once
again less than prepared I was a student
we were poor we were betwixten between
several life transitions we wrestled
with what to do
we worried about what could go wrong
could we provide the stability a child
needed would we have the resources to
give our child the life that they
deserved
the discussions were long hard and
honestly pretty excruciating at times
but I can't think of anyone who I would
rather have had them with than my wife
Nikki she was a beacon of strength
competence and Hope
our daughter is 37 now
we are thankful every day for her and
her sister and for our two grandchildren
we know that our daughters will have to
wrestle with difficult life altering
situations in fact they already have
we have full confidence in them
my mom and my wife taught me and more
importantly taught our daughters that
women are fully capable of making the
right decisions for themselves about
their bodies their health care and their
well-being
they do not need the state to decide for
them I urge you to vote ought to pass on
cacr2 let the people of New Hampshire
decide
thank you thank you representative
questions for this Witness
yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative uh according to the the
text of the bill it says all persons
have the right to make their own
reproductive decisions does this mean
that someone who may have an affinity
for animals or a brother and sister who
would like to keep it in the family or
perhaps maybe a minor attracted person
has the right to make their reproductive
decisions as well
I did not catch that
I did not catch that question
okay
yeah the the I think the problem is that
the Acoustics are not great in here so
uh representative Gleason I wonder if
you could maybe closer to the microphone
I will speak a lot louder then how's
this thank you okay
the text of the bill says all persons
have the right to make their own
reproductive decisions
does that mean that someone who has an
affinity for animals or a brother and
sister would like to keep it in the
family or a minor attracted person may
have that they have the right to make
their own reproductive decisions
I find that question offensive and I'm
not going to answer it
right
any other questions for this Witness
see none thank you very much our next
call on representative Gene knotter
please
thank you for the record I'm Janine you
need not I'm sorry I'm Hillsborough 12.
I didn't know what I was going to say
today when I came here so I'm going to
tell you why I'm pro-life
when I was 10 years old I saw pictures
of little arms and legs in a pool of
blood
and I knew I was looking at pictures of
dead babies
and I've always kept that image in my my
mind
and uh in 1995 I lost a child
I didn't lose a blob of of tissue it was
a baby it was my baby
and then I had a dream a very very Vivid
dream that the child was standing right
next to my bed it was like I woke up and
there's this child there looked like my
other kids but half the face was
deformed
and I kind of put in my head on that's
why the baby didn't make it but it was
my child and I loved him and I said oh
no no I love you and I reached for him
and he backed away like in fear which in
my mind I thought well okay we can't
touch what's on the other side and he
was gone
and I first became a mother when I was
still a teenager
and that baby was a baby the day before
he was born
three months before he was born
and he was a miracle of life in the
moment of conception
even though I put the cart before the
horse
I remember the words of a former drill
sergeant who later became a priest and
he had this deep voice that I cannot
mimic but he said if you are in a
position
if you know that something is wrong and
you are in a position to do something
about it and you do not
then you are at fault
so because I have this great fear of God
and I remember his words and I'm
pro-life I have to be here today
to say that I think it is wrong to put
this into law
and if you're asking from trouble from
above
thank you
thank you representative questions
representative
seeing none thank you um uh Sean uh Phil
Celiac I hope I'm yes thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee my name is
representative Sean filio and I have a
privilege of representing Cheshire
district 7 which covers Keane's award
too
I'm here to talk to you today about some
of the legal aspects of cacr2
the proposed amendments would apply
strict scrutiny to reproductive
decisions
as you may know strict scrutiny would
require that in order for the government
to apply limitations upon reproductive
decisions
the government would need to have a
compelling interest
and that if the government had a
compelling interest in applying
limitations on reproductive decisions
that any such limitations would need to
be narrowly tailored this is a standard
that has been applied by the U.S Supreme
Court and New Hampshire Supreme Court
for decades
thus cscr 2 would not make it such that
there could be no limitations on
reproductive decisions but rather that
such limitations would need to be
narrowly tailored to a compelling
governmental interest
let's take an example
as one representative recently placed
could there be no limitation on
bestiality or pedophilia or incest the
answer is an unequivocal no of course
there could be limitations because the
government has a compelling governmental
interest in prohibiting incest in
bestiality so of course there could be
limitations because there's a compelling
governmental interest but any such
limitations would just need to be
narrowly tailored so that the law would
go no further than what we need to do
this is the standard that has always
been applied to fundamental rights this
proposed amendment just seeks to apply a
governmental standard that has always
been in place
to reproductive decisions the key word
here is reproductive decisions what does
reproductive apply or mean it means what
it means it means the dictionary meaning
if we need to figure out what that means
that's the work that courts have always
done we trust our judges and we trust
our courts to determine what that means
we simply ask that we now apply an
existing standard to a new right I
welcome your questions
questions for this Witness
representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative you've used the term
compelling State interest
uh multiple Supreme Court rulings have
declared that the state
this is U.S Supreme Court rulings that
the state being the government has a a
state interest in protecting the life of
the baby
so how do you
if if this U.S Supreme Court has already
ruled that the state has a compelling
interest in protecting the life of the
baby at one point as the same time of
protecting the rights of the woman then
how does this bill not then contradict
with the U.S Supreme Court has already
ruled is a compelling State interest in
protecting the life of the baby
I think you're representative for the
question indeed the U.S Supreme Court
has said that there is a compelling
governmental interest in protecting the
life of a an unborn child as well as the
right of the the health of the mother
that was said in Roe versus Wade so
we're seeking to reinstate the standard
of Roe versus Wade it's always the work
of governments to balance
government is tough work
but that's what our constituents asked
us to do is tough work it's always a
balance but I think we're up to the task
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Manos
thank you Mr chair
to the New Hampshire state constitution
is that correct
I'm sorry representative could you
please us pull your mic a little bit
closer thank you sorry
this is a proposed concept
constitutional to the New Hampshire
state
Constitution is that correct yes
representative this is a proposed
amendment to the New Hampshire state
constitution and as such it would be
submitted to the voters of New Hampshire
is that correct
yes representative this would be
submitted to the voters of New Hampshire
to decide whether they believe this is
an appropriate right for them to have
under their state constitution this is
asking whether we believe that as
citizens of our state whether we want
this right just as citizens of other
states have been asked a similar
question and citizens of other states
have made that determination for
themselves it should be a basic right of
citizens of this state to determine for
themselves whether they want this right
just as citizens of other states have
had that privilege to decide if they
want that right for themselves
and isn't that the most democratic of
processes to let the voters of New
Hampshire decide for themselves whether
this amendment should be made to the
state constitution
thank you for the question
representative that would be seem to be
the fundamental definition of democracy
to let the people decide for themselves
how they wish to rule themselves
other questions
representative Morgan
um thank you thank you very much uh Mr
chair thank you very much to the
representative from from uh from from
from Keen
um basically
men cannot get pregnant although we did
hear a anecdote in the hearing about
transgender rights about a
a you know a trans man who hadn't had
bottom surgery who got uh pregnant
anyway but um so men can't get pregnant
but do you think if we
did get pregnant do you think this uh
ongoing debate of which this amendment's
part would probably uh be different
uh well thank you representative uh as
noted
Transit trans men do get pregnant but I
think we also need to consider the fact
that this bit of this amendment is about
Reproductive Rights it deliberately does
not use the word pregnancy men make
reproductive decisions then decide
whether or not to use a condom during
sex men decide whether or not to get a
vasectomy this equally applies to those
reproductive decisions if the government
wants to decide whether or not a man can
get a vasectomy the government needs to
have a pretty good reason to get
involved in that decision if the
government wants to place restrictions
upon contraception such as condoms the
government needs now to meet the strict
scrutiny standard we need to recognize
that this is reproductive
so yes it also applies to men and some
of the reproductive decisions that men
make because men make reproductive
decisions
thank you representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I'm having trouble with the audio in
here because of hearing aids so if I
miss something I apologize I first
wanted to ask if you are an attorney and
have a legal background
thank you representative I I am an
attorney I I hold the bar here in New
Hampshire and have also passed the the
New York Bar I've had the privilege of
serving with the attorneys general of
New Hampshire Vermont and Massachusetts
and was a Federal Judicial law clerk
under judge William young in the U.S
District Court for the District of
Massachusetts and I'm now a practicing
attorney for a private law firm based
out of Manhattan clearly I work remotely
thank you follow up
if I caught this correctly before and
part of your testimony
you seem to imply there should be a
balance
um
between the mother and the child
in the womb
and a balance between
the the mother and the state compelling
interests
now the question is
in Planned Parenthood versus Casey
the viability standard
came into the Forefront
and I happen to think that that's a
decent standard but
the viability If the child has the
capability of surviving outside of the
womb
does this come into play
with your balancing and the state
compelling interest because in Casey
that was stated that with viability that
the state did have a compelling interest
in the life of the pre-born child
thank you representative
viability may have a role here if that's
how the legislature decides to Define
the balance between the rights of the
mother and the rights of The Unborn and
it may also be how these New Hampshire
Supreme Court decides to apply this
given the fact that
the presented uh described has now
fallen under Dobbs it would be for the
New Hampshire Supreme Court to decide
how they would apply the standard but
they would certainly look to the prior
standards that had existed as being
compelling and convincing but it's
unclear if they would be binding given
the fact that they've now fallen
other questions
yes
um I have not had a chance to read the
complete Dobbs decision but
um the question would be
how much of Roe Doe
and Casey
um was obliterated by the Dobb's
decision or are there pieces of those
things that still survive in the
decision of the of the doc's decision
thank you representative I think that is
the question that we're also working out
and will be the question that we figure
out over the next few decades if I knew
the answer for that I think I would be
sitting at a different chair than I am
now
thank you
other other questions for this week
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you my call on former
representative Kurt Wolpert
and the next person after that will be
representative sellers just so you'll
know for uh
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record
like this
okay so for the record my name is uh
Kurt Wilbur I reside in Stratford New
Hampshire and I'm vice president of New
Hampshire rights life I put down two
minutes I'm going to say within it
New Hampshire right to life is in total
opposition to this
because
there can be no concept you know what I
think we're really having trouble
hearing you uh representative Wilbur I'm
sorry but uh
oh yeah
there you go good idea yeah thank you
all right
so New Hampshire right tonight is uh
close to this
excuse me
thank you
I'll leave it there all right start over
New Hampshire right to life has posted
this because it can be no constitutional
right along these lines
that can be known for two reasons and
has to do with a
with the fact that
this is the right to abortion abortion
is an intentional killing of an innocent
human being
that cannot be constitutional
that is opposed by every part
of our body of law
the second is they want to put it in the
right to privacy
there are at least two individuals human
beings involved
when the decision about abortion is made
mother and the child
and
there could be many others
uh very closely related
would be seriously impacted as well
to allow one person to so severely
impact the other people is not a matter
of privacy
it's a matter of community
and so if you were to adopt this at all
it shouldn't go into the Privacy part
of the Constitution you'll have to find
another place
the idea that
the established in Roe versus Wade
the Supreme Court recognize that it did
not know
what was in the womb
today we know but they said if we did
know what it was
and it was human being
and that human being would already be
protected this is 1973.
would already be protected by the United
States Constitution Article 14.
which means essentially what I just said
that can be no right no constitutional
right
to to abortion
and the last thing I'd like to say is
that
when they talk about reproductive
anything
they're really talking about abortion
because nothing else is really a matter
of
dispute in our society and I think if we
want to put this in into anything
it should talk about what it's talking
about and not hide behind the euphemism
of reproduction and with that I will
conclude
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much
uh representative uh sellers next and
after the next one after that will be
representative Murray representative
sellers
good morning Representatives thank you
Mr chair for the time and committee
members
representative sellers Grafton 18. I am
going to list the towns just to give you
an idea if you haven't heard before
you're going to hear them at least once
I represent Alexandria Bristol
Bridgewater Heber and Groton Dorchester
orange Grafton itself Canaan and Enfield
those towns I like to say we would all
be on the same page and we'll 100
agreement in this bill but of course
we're not and as we all know we're
pretty divided what's going on here and
uh
but I did want to bring up a few items
here or at least one or two
it is I I honestly believe that
our state and any government does not
have any rights
or any say over any reproduction of a
male or a female
zero
however because of the predicament and
the times we're in
we're trying to solve problems by
putting in amendments and also other
bills
because of the times we're in and
which I disagree with but they're here
and since they're here we need to
address them
so one thing I have here is uh maybe two
things
it says I just want to make sure this
bill and that's unfortunate maybe even
when you guys deliberate and stuff at
that point it says uh an individual's
right to personal reproduction I take
that as male and female I'm not looking
at this as just a female issue it's a
male issue as well
that's one the second part it says I'm
going to read on line five
says infringed
unless justified by a compelling State
interest and so on
man if I was a lawyer and I'm not a
lawyer but I think I could come up with
about 50 different ways of saying
the state could be justified so I I look
at this and I say this bill is going to
be very vague and open to interpretation
and would be a real problem if it's put
forward thank you
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
representative Murray and after
representative Murray the next uh
witness will be uh
Gene Espanola
representative Murray thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee can you
hear me okay you have to get closer okay
you can pick that up if you need to
right that's great thank you
um so I'm representative Alessandra
Rodriguez Murray and I'm very proud to
be a co-sponsor of this legislation
last July the unthinkable happened and
the Supreme Court Court overturned Roe e
Wade
since then we've seen thousands of women
young girls and other pregnant people
struggle to get often the life-saving
care that they need
while New Hampshire laws have remained
stable during this time we have seen an
increase of patients from out of state
coming to access abortion care in New
Hampshire these patients are receiving
delayed care that is more stressful
expensive and feels out of their control
we must protect New Hampshire citizens
from the same fate
the fall row confirmed what Granite
theaters have always known we cannot
depend on the federal government to
protect our rights
cacr2 is exactly the kind of legislation
we needed at this moment a democratic
way for our constituents and fellow
citizens of New Hampshire to determine
the future of abortion in New Hampshire
and for themselves the people of New
Hampshire deserve to know that their
Reproductive Rights are protected in the
state that they live in and that the
laws will constantly change back and
forth every two years let New Hampshire
continue to be the safe haven of Liberty
and personal choice that we always have
been please vote ought to pass on cascr2
thank you thank you questions for this
Witness
she ain't none thank you
um
I I believe it's Gene I it's hard to
read the first name Espanola
Joan I'm sorry Espanola and the next
person after that will be uh Bob Dunn
from the Diocese of Manchester
thank you
well for you turn on the red there you
go thank you my name is John Espanola
and I am from Londonderry New Hampshire
and I'm asking you to please vote no on
cacr2
there's no freedom for the baby in the
womb when it comes to reproduction
reproductive freedom and reproductive
freedom is just a means
just means a woman can kill a living
human being with no repercussions from
the state
if you vote Yes on cacr2 your coursening
New Hampshire's Culture by adding this
resolution to our constitution
our world is coursing coarsening more
and more each day with violence drugs
suicides sex trafficking social media
attacks canceling people and the
bullying of children who are fortunate
enough to be born
then there's the lies told to women that
they can abort the baby in their womb
and feel good about it
I still don't believe after hearing the
um sponsor of this bill that a woman can
abort her baby and feel good about it
I'm sorry
also the hard hearts that tell the
mother it's okay to kill your baby
instead of giving them real loving help
with support to keep the baby or
suggesting adoption
all of you on this committee have the
power of life and death in your vote
please choose life and help our culture
soften its attitude toward life
and I just like to share one thing
that happened to me I was protesting in
front of a Planned Parenthood and a car
stopped in front of me and it was a
woman in the car and she started
screaming at me and hollering at me
because my sign said and abortion
and she had two children in the back of
that car
and her language wasn't good either
so
after she started stopped screaming at
me she turned around to the children who
I think one was probably about 10 and
the other was younger
she said to the kids what did we say to
her
and they dropped the F-bomb the two
children in the back knew what this
person was telling them to do so you
know with these children are adults now
because this was about 15 years ago so
the coarsening of our
um culture
was happening then
and now we have people like that woman
telling these children
you know to say that to me and
I I still can't get over it to tell you
the truth
um so thank you and I'm also asking you
to vote no on House Bill 271
224 and 88. these three bills along with
cacr do nothing to make our world a
better place but only forcing it even
more thank you thank you questions for
this waitress
seeing none thank you very much uh Bob
Dunn please
and then that next will be uh
representative uh Newell
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Bob Dunn the director of
public policy for the Roman Catholic
Diocese of Manchester and I'm here today
on behalf of Bishop Peter labashi to uh
oppose
cacr2 is that okay can you hear me all
right yes thank you I have written
testimony so I just want to make a
couple of quick comments if I might
um first of all
if there's one thing that I suspect
everybody in this room agrees on it's
that in certain ways human dignity and
solidarity are things that are beset by
many challenges in today's world
and so I asked the committee to think
about this question as you deliberate on
this cacr
will the work of building up human
dignity and solidarity be Advanced or
hindered by the adoption of a
constitutional amendment that
effectively declares a certain category
of human beings as expendable
proposals like this inevitably have
repercussions in other areas
if we want Society to recognize the
human dignity of the young human being
at the border or the young human being
who is homeless
or the young human being who is in need
of health care then we need to recognize
the human dignity of the young human
being in the womb as well
if we begin to ask Society to treat
certain ones of us as expendable
then we can't be surprised if Society
begins to treat certain ones of us as
expendable
and so I ask you to vote down this
proposal thank you thank you Mr John uh
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you
um representative Jody Newell please
next and uh the next witness after that
will be uh Senator Deborah uh
I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
the members of the committee my name is
Jody Newell I'm a representative
representing Cheshire four
um a very solidly uh pro-choice District
so I'm happy to be here today
representing my constituency
as I thought about what I was going to
say today I was once again filled with a
sense of discouragement
we are so set in our ways it seems we've
staked our flags firmly on either side
and by God we'll fight to the death to
defend our positions
now what in this context could I
possibly say that would change the mind
of someone who believes that abortion is
murder
and after a lot of time and thought I
decided to share a little bit about my
own Journey from regular March for Life
participants in attendee to abortion
Storyteller to Civil Disobedience
participant and willing or SD on behalf
of the right to choose
I intend to address two points the first
is that abortion should be legal and
second that it should be an unencumbered
right
and I won't I won't throw statistics at
you I know we're a wash with statistics
but that part actually plays a pretty
significant role in my journey
see I was raised in a Conservative
Christian household with a fiercely
loving mama who devoted much of her time
and energy to overturning Roe v Wade
every January we travel to DC on a bus
to the March for Life and I believe
myself that abortion was murder
so so much so that I was the one person
in my high school class who would stand
up Standalone arguing and defending this
point I remember a paper I wrote once
and the disdain I felt at Corrections
from my teacher on the statistics I used
to back up my claims
but being you know me
I was not satisfied with just knowing
that I was right I needed to prove my
point smug teacher be damned
that was when I signed up for a
newsletter from Nero it's not that I
trusted them in fact I thought they were
evil but I did this in order to pick
apart their alternative facts their
competing statistics
but in the end I had to take a good look
at my own
this effort led me to understand the
true nature of abortion because the way
it had been presented to me was false it
was inaccurate it was emotional
I still can't get this image out of my
mind
30 years later and I won't describe it
here I don't want to put you all through
that
let me just say that for a long time I
believe that partial birth abortion was
abortion
this is propaganda
this is indoctrination
what it is not is factual in reality
the overwhelming majority of abortion is
still legal in New Hampshire because it
happens well before 20 weeks well before
a fetus becomes the full-grown viable
precious baby portrayed in the image
that I remember in my mind
so why as a mother of two amazing human
beings created in my own womb and of
whom I am so extremely proud to have
brought into this world do I believe
this should be an unencumbered right
with no restrictions from the government
well let me tell you about these babies
entrants in the world
one was a year and the other yet to be
born just three weeks out when their
father my fiance at the time
overdose on heroin in our bathroom ten
feet away on the other side of a closed
door
even saying that now as a legislator as
someone who tries to do good things in
this world
there's a twinge of fear that you'll
judge me
demean me
I am perpetually afraid that my past
even even if the reality in context
isn't explained in detail even if you
know and love someone who has found
themselves in a similar situation even
if you are a compassionate person who
makes all efforts not to as does my mama
that your opinion of me will change and
you will value my words less
but I say it all the same because having
known that judgment having had my
Integrity questioned my motive
scrutinized and worked
in other people's minds and having found
the strength to fight back I cannot and
will not remain silent when good people
many going through the hardest time of
their lives
are called murderers
there are as many situations as there
are people and to assign malice to
install roadblocks to impose faceless
and unnecessary barriers based on a
default Assumption of their nefarious
intent
is simply abhorrent and frankly it's
inaccurate
we as a legislature and collectively the
government are not capable of nor should
we be in the business of assessing the
Merit of each individual situation these
are these very personal and impactful
decisions belong in the hands of the
individual with expert guidance for
medical experts
which is exactly why we're here today
to ensure that that's where they will
stay
thank you for your time and I'm happy to
take questions questions for this
Witness
see none thank you very much uh Senator
uh
and the next witness after that will be
uh Danielle Pimentel
good morning chairman Lynn honorable
committee members
my name is Deborah alt Schiller I
represent Senate District 24 which
includes the towns of Exeter Greenland
Hampton Hampton Falls Northampton rye
and stratum
I'm here in support of cacr2
relative to
reproductive medical decisions
in November of 2018 81 percent of New
Hampshire voters approved adding 22 more
words to our state's Constitution right
to privacy and individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion or
in private or personal information is
natural essential and inherent these
words added as article 2B
this amendment was about control and who
has it New Hampshire citizens want
control over their private and personal
information
our proposal of cacr-2 would be added as
Article 2 C with 31 Words which
complement article 2B
the right to make personal reproductive
medical decisions is in Violet and
fundamental to The Human Condition
neither the state nor any political
subdivision shall infringe upon or
unduly inconvenience this right this
amendment like 2B is also about control
and claiming it unequivocally this
amendment didn't come out of thin air
and it has inspiration from current
statutes and legislative intent let me
elaborate in doing legislative research
there's another place in New Hampshire
law I would like to share with you the
first part of chapter
137-j titled written directives for
adults without capacity to make medical
decisions
it states its purpose in policy as the
state of New Hampshire recognizes that
individual persons have the right
founded in the autonomy and sanctity of
a person to control the decisions
relating to the rendering of their own
Medical Care
the New Hampshire legislature has
amended this chapter three times and
consistently reiterated that purpose and
policy statement the state of New
Hampshire recognizes that its citizens
have the right founded in the autonomy
and sanctity of a person to control the
decisions relating to the rendering of
their own Medical Care and yet
when that New Hampshire citizen is
pregnant their rights to control
decisions related to their medical care
and the privacy of that personal
information is thrown away
pregnancy seems to be the line where
constitutional rights are Stripped Away
in Article 1 equality of men origin and
object of government all men are born
equally free and independent therefore
all government of right originates from
the people is founded in consent and
instituted for the general good
there is no caveat in Article 1 that
says all men are born equally free and
independent
except when pregnant
and yet that loss of freedom and
Independence is exactly what happens
Article 2 natural rights all men have
certain natural essential and inherent
rights among which are the enjoying and
defending life and Liberty acquiring
possessing and protecting property and
in a word of seeking and obtaining
happiness equality of rights under the
law shall not be denied or Abridged by
this state on account of race Creed
color sex or natural national origin
except when pregnant
a New Hampshire citizen who is pregnant
loses the benefit of their life and
Liberty particularly if their pregnancy
is life-threatening or their pregnancy
loses viability they're affirmative
rights to seek Happiness by making
reproductive medical decisions
independently as is their natural right
is Stripped Away they no longer have
control over their own body they are
enslaved to a law
marginalizing pregnant women by
stripping them of their natural
essential and inherent rights is not
the New Hampshire way
when a person does not have freedom over
their reproductive decisions with
affirmative rights because the state can
interfere
they are chattel
this is not the New Hampshire way
New Hampshire citizens value our natural
rights and it is an unjust and undue
burden to restrict the reproductive
medical decisions made by citizens it is
our time to enshrine our values of
freedom of reproductive decisions into
our state constitution because
constitutional protections for
Reproductive Rights are the gold
standard
respectfully ask you to recommend cacr-2
ought to pass thank you questions for
this Witness
yes representative statement
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um this has been very helpful your
presentation piece to be able to follow
I'm having difficulty with hearing and
hearing I believe other folks may also a
very nice presentation that you've done
here I have one question
um
relative to privacy in this argument in
this issue
are there any limits or better term
would be conditions
on how privacy governs
this individual right
of reproductive Freedom specifically
would be
how it may affect other persons
including the conception partner
as well as the
individual person
being grown in the womb
I'm sorry as well as the individual
person what that last bit Yeah the
individual person being
grown in the womb as well as the
conception partner to raise that
individual if it were to be born
I understand that I thank you thank you
for the question and allowing me
up to
um to clarify that
um this
this Constitutional Amendment
is designed to make sure that we are
focusing on the person here the person
now who is covered by the Constitution
women should have freedom to make their
own reproductive choices it is not the
state's responsibility it's not the
state's purview to get inside a woman's
body and make any decisions for what is
right for her medically at any point it
is her decision to make part
particularly reproductive choices
because they are reproduction
reproduction is dangerous it is it can
be life-threatening it is not an easy
thing to do it permanently changes
someone's body and entering into
making a choice to have a pregnancy and
follow through if possible with that
pregnancy is not our business the
privacy of making medical decisions
should be with that person
I hope that answers your question in
terms of how this is
I hear that um
but essentially does the conception
partner
also have that right uh to participate
and that's it is a soul right of the
woman or does the right expand or extend
to the conception partner the other
individual who may decide opposite for
instance
so I would say that cacr2 specifies that
anyone in New Hampshire's reproductive
choices whether they are the person
whether they are
whatever side of the equation and be
delicate here of
um of a reproductive Act
should have the medical autonomy to make
their own choices I would no sooner come
before you and put legislation in front
of this body that would limit your
reproductive choices and where you can
control your reproductive health
and I would I would that's we are
requesting that Equanimity for women too
thank you thank you other questions for
this witness thank you very much and um
ladies and gentlemen thank you I
appreciate the time thank you uh ladies
and gentlemen uh next is uh Danielle
Pimentel and given what I see as the
time and the number of additional
Witnesses I am going to ask please
follow the Miss Pimentel and the
witnesses that follow the please limit
your remarks to three minutes thank you
good morning can you all hear me
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is Danielle
pimento and I serve as policy council at
Americans United for life which is a
national law and policy nonprofit
organization with a specialization in
abortion end of life issues and
bioethics law
today I strongly urge the committee to
oppose this resolution because it
prohibits Common Sense protections for
women's health and safety from being
enacted in the future as well as
infringes upon Health Care Providers
conscience rights
currently New Hampshire has very few
protections for pregnant women and The
Unborn however if this resolution is
passed it will make it even more
difficult to enact future protections
for the health and safety of women which
includes informed consent
um laws as well or as well as parental
involvement laws and this is because the
resolution imposes a strict scrutiny
standard whereby the state must have a
compelling interest
um in order to regulate abortion which
can be achieved by the least restrictive
means currently New Hampshire does not
have any informed consent process for
women undergoing abortions such as
medical disclosures of the risks of
abortion the type of procedure or a
reflection period which would ensure the
woman has the time necessary to consider
these risks and information before
making a decision on whether to continue
her pregnancy these safeguards are
critical because women cannot agree to
medical treatment unless they are
competent and have the the adequate
information to make that decision
informed consent safeguards are also
important because many women or protect
men and women against coerced abortions
many women are subject to intimate
partner violence as well as reproductive
control as many as one quarter of women
seeking abortions have some kind of
experience with reproductive control and
informed consent safeguards women by
providing them with material information
to let them know that they are not alone
in their decision and that they have
other Alternatives that they have other
resources available to them however the
resolution today would prevent States
likely from from passing these kind of
safeguards to protect women
Additionally the resolution contains
broad protections for for abortion which
raises serious conscience rights
concerns New Hampshire does not protect
the conscious rights of Health Care
providers in the abortion context and
although the state's Constitution
includes a purported right of conscience
it is an adequate protection for health
care providers because the Constitution
does not include within the language any
mention of abortion or health care or
anything that would ensure that Health
Care Providers
conscience rights are protected if they
have moral or ethical obligations to
abortions
um thus this resolution would could
leave Healthcare Providers
um with either the choice of
um
losing their or not providing care or
I'm having to violate their own
conscience in performing an abortion
um so for these reasons I strongly
encourage the committee to oppose this
resolution in order to protect the
health and safety of women as well as
protect the conscience rights of Health
Care providers in New Hampshire
thank you and I any questions thank you
questions for this Witness
okay
representative report
um
you're speaking about a
coerced abortions does it go the other
around other way around sometimes were a
woman becomes pregnant but her partner
coerces her to stay pregnant even though
she doesn't feel that continuity
abortion is a good thing to do either
for health reasons because
not all like uh not all embryos are to
conceived developed smoothly into babies
or just because of uh her relationship
with a partner or where things fit into
her life so is it
um which is the so is isn't that also a
problem though of course uh you know
coerced to coerced pregnancy as well as
Courage the abortion yes they're good
last part
that's part of troll there definitely
could be individuals that
um have exercised some kind of control
over a woman to continue her pregnancy
that is true
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much I'm
going to next call on representative uh
uh Catherine O'Brien
and the next witness after that will be
Sebastian Fuentes
good morning thank you
thank you the very emotional epic and it
is an emotional topic for me as well
this bill uh this cacr really is about
allowing abortion for any reason at any
time in the pregnancy it's not the same
as a discussion about a woman who has a
a child that has a condition
inconvenience
incompatible with life
okay that's a different that's a
different argument it's a different
story
now when I ran for state representative
the first thing I told people when they
asked me about myself was that I was
pro-life okay and I got elected so I
feel a duty to be here and say some
things
my journey to being pro-life is probably
unusual and not what you would expect
so to talk about it means I have to talk
about my life and it's kind of hard but
here I go
um
I grew up in the 70s and the 80s when
there was a lot a large feminist
movement where we were told we could do
anything and be anything
and I took that to heart okay I I really
appreciated that kind of equality it
meant a lot to me it meant so much to me
and I was a huge fan of Susan B Anthony
and I read her life story
and I took it to heart because
she believed in the equality of women
and their their ability to uh do what
they needed to to support themselves the
reason that she was so in favor of women
supporting themselves and taking care of
themselves was because she saw that it
was a way that women
could take care of their families and
not have to endure the terrible
situation of abortion she did speak on
abortion
a lot of people don't know that
I think she would be proud
of what I I did with that and um with
her teachings I was the first female at
my Vocational High School to graduate
from the Machining program and I did
support myself
in that field for many years
I had an unplanned pregnancy at that
time and it was it made it all the
difference
my own childhood was difficult I've
talked about a little bit here in the
past
I was born into a kind of poverty that I
think a lot of people don't realize
happens in the United States I did not
have a bed until I was about seven years
old I was hungry a lot we were on uh we
were in subsidized housing we were on
government Aid
you would think that maybe that was my
family story for Generations but it
absolutely wasn't
my um
my grandfather who passed away soon
after I was born was a uh around a
renowned physician and medical
researcher and he was the chief
pathologist at usamrid when he passed
away you see hammered his United States
Army Medical Institute
researched something
okay I'm sorry
I
I asked my mother why she did not have
an abortion when she was pregnant with
me because
how much poverty happened after the
divorce and the and all of that
and she told me about something that
happened when she was
um a child representative you I I we are
I will be quick you're all over three
minutes now I will be very quick all
right she told me about something very
interesting that happened when she was a
child she was on the campus of the
University of Vermont where her father
was a medical professor and she waited
for him to at his office
and when she was in the office wandering
around she found
fetuses in Jaws in all stages of
development
and she told me that is why she did not
have an abortion when she was pregnant
with me despite the fact that it plunged
her into years and years of poverty okay
because of the divorce
she said she knew those were people when
she saw them and her father came out of
his office and told her those are
fetuses fetus means baby
and those are babies and she said yes I
know those are babies obviously they're
all babies they were all in very
different stages of development I feel
like I owe my life to those
those medical teaching AIDS
because my mother really struggled and
worked very hard to have children
and uh
I'm pro-life because of that I feel like
I was a person before I was born just as
much as I am a person today worthy of
protections and so that I want to share
that story with you thank you questions
for this Witness
seeing none uh Sebastian Fuentes and the
next witness after that will be Liz
Canada
's thank you Mr chairman Lee and members
of the committee for listening to my
testimony uh my name is Sebastian
Fuentes I'm the movement politics
director for rice and democracy of New
Hampshire uh I'm also a North Country
resident for the last 21 years uh I
don't want to address you to you as a
political director or anything like that
but I'm here to talk to you us uh the
son of a brave mom as the husband of an
amazing woman dedicated to her family
and the community in the fight of two
amazing beautiful daughters
I need to fight day and night for the
rights to make their own decisions I'm
also a father of four children
I was able to after my last baby was up
in this world to go to the hospital make
an appointment
literally in a matter of a week I was
able to just replace the vasectomy I was
in and out I made my own choice
I walked out of the hospital I realized
that my wife don't have that right
I realized that my daughters won't have
that right I realized my mom don't have
the right my neighbors my siblings my
sister don't have the right
you feel good to be able to do that but
I also felt really worried about their
rights uh they were not able to do that
as well
I came 21 years ago from my country
where women die and improvised abortion
centers
because abortion was banned
I came from a third world country where
indigenous women
well were forced to have the uterus
removed for money in order to keep
poverty low
many die in the process many were
forgotten
restricting access to reproductive care
abortion included is a threat to our
communities especially black and black
communities in this country
New Hampshire needs to move forward when
discussing Reproductive Rights and not
backwards
now for the last seven years I have come
to this this state house to testify
about many issues from affordable
housing
women's when my my son was three weeks
old I came to this same building
downstairs to the senate committee to
testify about Paid Family Leave
for the last seven years I have came to
testify about minimum wage
I came to testify against guns in
schools
and many other issues like utility bills
and right now right after this I have to
go to lob 101 to testify with my son my
wife and my daughter about child care
affordability because it's something
that is hurting us
so my question to you all is when are we
going to allow young families in New
Hampshire to thrive
enough is enough
our state legislators regardless of
party affiliation must support
affordable access to abortion
unbodily autonomy should be left
to the discretion of the individuals
we should let the residents of New
Hampshire make their voices heard about
this issue
my mother my wife my two daughters
amazing and thousands of amazing women
in New Hampshire
are waiting for action
let's be on the right side we owe that
to them so I'm here to support cacr2 and
I hope you do that too thank you so much
questions for this Witness
101 now thank you Liz Canada and uh next
after Miss Canada will be uh Josie Pinto
good morning are you able to hear me
with my mask on
sounds okay
sorry my kids are really sick so I'm
like really worried okay so my name is
Liz Canada I'm the advocacy manager at
Planned Parenthood of Northern New
England and Planned Parenthood New
Hampshire action fund and we're here to
support cacr2
after the U.S Supreme Court completely
overturned Roe v Wade last June abortion
was on the ballot very explicitly in
four states Vermont Kansas Kentucky and
Michigan
two of those measures were to further
restrict abortion and two of those
measures were to enshrine protections
into their State's Constitution
those states have very different
processes in order to amend their
constitutions than we do and they allow
ballot measures based on signatures but
the overarching question was still the
same
and in all four states which are
arguably very different from one another
voters overwhelmingly supported
Reproductive Rights soundly defeating
anti-abortion measures and approving
reproductive freedom
Reproductive Rights abortion birth
control are all bipartisan supported
issues they are not red or blue issues
here in New Hampshire
we've enjoyed for so long a bipartisan
support of Reproductive Rights here in
the State House
cacr2 would send the question to the
voters it would allow for the voters of
New Hampshire to decide on whether the
New Hampshire Constitution should be
amended to explicitly include
reproductive freedom
it is a very high bar to amend the state
constitution here in New Hampshire
but we know that the vast majority of
granite Staters support Reproductive
Rights and they do not want government
interference in their reproductive
health care or in anyone's reproductive
Health Care
polls indicate that New Hampshire is one
of the most supportive States regarding
reproductive freedoms and limiting
government interference on pregnancy
ncacr too would let Granite Staters
voters voices be heard just like we saw
in multiple States this past year so we
encourage you to vote ought to pass on
cacr-2 thank you thank you questions for
this Witness
see none thank you thank you
Josie pinto and next will be uh Megan
McNeil
good morning Representatives my name is
Josie Pinto I'm a constituent of Dover
and I'm here in my capacity as the
executive director of the reproductive
Freedom fund of New Hampshire
urging you all to support cacr2 my work
is about breaking down barriers for
patients who need abortions and I
believe this legislation would be the
strongest possible way we can ensure
patients are able to access the
reproductive Health Care they need
without worry fear or confusion
ever since the 24-week abortion ban went
into effect in New Hampshire and Roe v
Wade fell earlier this summer my
organization has dealt with a lot of
confusion from patients around where
their rights stand it's understandably
hard to keep up with the shifting
National landscape but I'm confident
this bill would help bring voters into
the decision process to affirm once and
for all that Granite seders support the
right to abortion
recent polling has already shown us this
is true with about 70 percent of
citizens affirming their support for
abortion rights regardless of your
personal opinion on abortion I urge you
all to consider that this issue deserves
to be decided by the voters of this
state the people who would truly be
impacted by this
when Roe was struck down the decision
was handed to the states so let's allow
the voters of the state to decide I want
to see New Hampshire declare our strong
support for abortion not just in this
current political moment but for the
generations to come who deserve to be
guaranteed the rights that most of us of
reproductive age have had our whole
lives
the right to abortion is a right that
goes alongside our values of living free
I believe that bodily autonomy is the
ultimate form of freedom and that we
should be guaranteed that right in the
state that so highly values personal
autonomy
New Hampshire has a long bipartisan
history of supporting privacy
particularly when it comes to personal
medical decisions
cacr2 will protect Granite seder's right
to reproductive autonomy and prevent
future attacks on our access to
contraception sterilization and abortion
care let's let the voters settle this
matter once and for all please support
cacr2 to bring our state one step closer
to making reproductive Liberty a reality
for us all thank you thank you questions
for this Witness
saying No thank you uh Megan McNeil and
uh after Ms McNeil will be uh
Courtney Reed
Ms McNeil hi my name is Megan McNeil and
I'm a resident of Dover New Hampshire
um and I'm here to ask you to support
this bill
um as a Libertarian woman I believe that
individuals should have the freedom to
make their own choices about their
bodies and their lives this includes the
right to access safe and legal abortion
the decision to have an abortion is
deeply personal and should be left up to
the individual
no one knows the circumstances of a
woman's life better than she does it's
not up to the government or anyone else
to dictate what a woman should do with
her body
in fact attempts to restrict access to
abortion are a violation of individual
liberty
these restrictions not only limit a
woman's ability to make decisions about
her own body but all they also
disproportionately affect low-income
women and women of color who may not
have the resources to access safe and
legal abortions
furthermore making abortion illegal does
not stop women from seeking out this
necessary medical procedure
it only pushes them towards dangerous
and potentially deadly alternatives
such as self-induced abortion or seeking
out unlicensed providers
as a Libertarian I also believe the
importance of limited government
intervention into people's lives
laws that restrict access to abortion
are a clear example of government
overreach
the government should not be in the
business of dictating medical decisions
or moral values
ultimately the decision to have an
abortion should be left up to the
individual
it is a private matter that should be
made in consultation with a health care
provider not politicians or activists
who seek to impose their beliefs on
others
in conclusion as a Libertarian woman I
firmly believe in the importance of
individual liberty and limited
government intervention
this includes the right to access safe
and legal abortion
attempts to restrict this right are a
violation of individual freedom and have
a negative consequence for Women's
Health and well-being it's time to trust
women to make their own decisions about
their bodies and their lives thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you uh Courtney Reed
and next after Miss Reed will be uh
Jocelyn
toffee oh toffee I believe I'm
pronouncing that ah thank you
Miss Reed
thank you can you hear me yes
thank you uh chairman and members of the
committee my name is Courtney Reed I'm
here with the ACLU of New Hampshire and
I just want to provide another brief
statement of support for this cacr uh as
we've heard this amendment would
enshrine Reproductive Rights in New
Hampshire state constitution and allow
voters the opportunity to ensure that
abortion stays legal in the state and
that patients continue to have access to
necessary reproductive care
uh with the current legal landscape that
we're we're faced with this is one of
the most effective tools we can use to
ensure that these reproductive Liberties
um remain in place for granite Staters
and I just want to speak to why that
this is effective in that uh the
compelling State interest uh element of
the Constitutional Amendment subjects
the state to strict scrutiny uh whereby
the legislature would need to establish
that there is an extremely important
reason to enact a law that would further
restrict Reproductive Rights and that
lawmakers would also need to prove that
there are not any other possible ways to
address the state interest without
infringing on this right to reproductive
freedom
we've already seen in response to Rose
overturn States take proactive measures
to protect reproductive Liberties
including California Michigan and our
neighboring state of Vermont passing
their own State constitutional
amendments to ensure that these
reproductive freedoms are protected
and I just want to wrap up by stating
that abortion bans pose a life-altering
consequences for pregnant individuals
whether it be the health risk that they
might be faced with needing to continue
a pregnancy a more more difficulty
escaping poverty perhaps not being able
to hold on to a job or continue their
education and ultimately reproductive
freedom is an essential freedom to
fulfill the promise of equality and
self-determination so I recommend that
the committee move forward with this
cacr and ensure that Granite Staters
have the opportunity to protect
reproductive Liberty as a central
freedom and a dignity as everyone
deserves the power to decide for
themselves if and when they want to have
a child thank you questions for this
Witness
see none thank you uh Miss toffee and
next will be uh Maggie O'Neal
good afternoon everyone my name is
Jocelyn tofik I live in Dover and I'm
here currently to support uh cacr2
um
none of what I'm about to tell you is
anyone's business and I do feel
resentful feeling like I have to come
down here today
to tell this to a room of strangers
um
but that's how important I think this
amendment is
in 2004 when I was 26
I had an abortion I had a two-year-old
daughter and lived with her father in a
home we owned in Dover
I was in my second year of college and I
had been on birth control and using it
fully as directed with no user errors
confirmed by my gynecologist
we knew we did not want another child we
could not afford another child nor could
I have finished my degree as the
inherent risk to my health would have
been too debilitating
my first pregnancy was fine until it
wasn't and around 34 weeks I went
pre-eclamptic and I hemorrhaged
immediately after giving birth
a hundred years ago I would have died in
2004 my odds were better but they were
certainly not zero
especially here in America with the
worst maternal mortality rate among all
wealthy countries
preeclampsia is still one of the leading
causes of pregnancy death in the United
States Bleeding Out accounts for 75
percent of all pregnancy deaths in the
United States not only that the rate of
preeclampsia in the U.S has increased by
25 percent in the last 20 in the last
two decades
maternal mortality rates overall for all
conditions are increasing year over year
in the U.S
there are so many good reasons to
constitutionally protect a woman's right
to decide what happens to her own body
but the one I really want to focus on is
that pregnancy entails is statistically
measurable and significant risk of death
who is this or any government to tell me
I am required by law to risk my life in
a forced pregnancy
it's insane
although the risk is very much real a
history of preeclampsia and hemorrhaging
after birth would not preclude me from
having another child it would be a risk
but by many state standards would not be
considered imminent threat enough to
allow for termination in more legally
restrictive environments
this is why constitutionally protecting
my right to decide if I live or die
pregnant
is important
an average of 24 pregnant people in
America will die for every 100 000 live
births that's one pregnant woman dead
for every
4167 who get to live
if you are black and Pregnant that
statistic explodes to one pregnant woman
dead out of only
1818 pregnancy survivors
if you are over 40 which I am that
number is now one dead woman for every
926 who get to survive that pregnancy
those are good odds for a Powerball
ticket
so my question is
who gets determined what is too risky
for me who gets to say what odds of
death I am forced to accept me or my
government
I very much prefer it be me
these numbers from the CDC do not even
include the leading cause of death for
pregnant people in America
because the leading cause of death is
not considered a medical result of
complications due to pregnancy Because
the actual leading cause of death for
pregnant women in America is homicide
the horror of that
pregnancy can be and often is lethal and
when it is lethal as in the case of
bleeding out there is usually no warning
I had no indicators prior
my pregnancy nearly killed me so who
gets to decide for me when I will risk
my life and how and for what it should
be me who decides
when I choose to risk my life
when the odds of surviving forced
pregnancy or any pregnancy are this bad
the government should not and should
never have the power to force me to be
pregnant against my will the
government's duty at its very Foundation
is to protect my very basic right to
live please approve this amendment for
public vote and let the people of New
Hampshire decide when and how and for
what they want to risk their life thank
you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you uh Maggie O'Neill
and next will be Nicole Lyman
good morning
my name is Maggie O'Neill and I'm a
proud resident of Newmarket New
Hampshire and I'm here today to voice my
support for cacr2
I attend church nearly every Sunday as I
have done most Sundays through my life
and as a Christian American I recognize
the rightful separation of church and
state as well as the pluralistic nature
of our society
our tradition of protecting religious
liberty predates our independence as a
nation actually
my faith calls me to hold compassion and
love for all people and to afford them
the dignity to make decisions for
themselves according to their own needs
and circumstances and it's not just my
personal belief either after the fall of
Roe the Episcopal Church stated that
they uphold the conscience rights of
pregnant persons to determine whether
they want to continue a pregnancy
they have called since 1988 on state and
federal governments to take this as a
quote take special care to see that
individual conscience is respected and
that the responsibility of individuals
to reach informed decisions in this
matter is acknowledged and honored
I trust people to make their own
decisions when it comes to the deeply
personal and complex experience of
pregnancy and reproduction
I am grateful every single day that I
was able to access abortion care when I
needed it
abortion care is life-saving health care
which all persons deserve access to
these decisions should be left to
individuals according to their needs I
urge you to support this constitutional
amendment to protect this right Thank
you questions for this Witness
saying none thank you
um Nicole Lyman and uh next after Ms
Lyman will be uh
uh Evan Ringo I believe
this one my name is Nicole Lyman a Dover
resident a New Hampshire native I am
here today to share with you my personal
story in hopes that it will inspire an
understanding of the importance of Bill
cacr2
my first child wasn't planned I was
terrified I was only a year into my
sobriety and although I was clean I was
going through a period of my life where
I was struggling with depression
joblessness and having a steady home
despite what you may think about
pregnancies being obvious I was totally
unaware I was pregnant until I was four
months along the pregnancy was not easy
the father of my child was extremely
mentally abusive I needed to do
everything I could to get away from him
if ever the factors were aligned in my
life to choose abortion for convenience
this would have been the time I can't
imagine not having that choice available
to me having that sacred right to choose
for my own body was immensely important
to the decision-making process
essentially changed me to be a better
person
I was able to confront my fears and
after everything was considered I made
the very difficult decision to have the
child and raise her essentially on my
own in the face of some pretty difficult
odds just a few months after my daughter
was born I was diagnosed with postpartum
depression and at the same day also
found out I was pregnant again amazingly
I was a small percentage of people who
had birth control fail
my life was nearly in shambles I was
getting out of abusive relationship the
stress of being a new mother struggling
with income and finding a place to live
nearly cost me my sobriety and nearly
cost me my life
I chose to terminate the second
unexpected pregnancy so I could save my
health and move on with my life to be a
good healthy mother
there's no question I made a lot of
choices but the most important part of
the process was that I had the freedom
to do so
one of the most heartbreaking moments
thus far being a mother was receiving
the news of the overturn of Roe v Wade
from my 13 year old daughter
one of the most she when she gave us the
news in the car she had tears in her
eyes she looked terrified
I was not even aware she knew how
serious this was until this moment
something happens to a mother when she
sees her child feels unsafe
I made a promise that I would fight this
so she could feel safe and have the same
freedoms her but to her body that I had
it's crazy watching my daughter grow
into this independent human with
independent feelings making her own
choices that she will grow through grow
from
she's going to make mistakes we all are
we are human we are flawed it's
important for us to have the choices
when it comes to body autonomy no matter
what the reason please support Bill
cacr2 we need not forget the history of
what life in our culture was like
pre-row I would really love to see my
home state stand on the right side of
history with this one thank you
questions for this Witness
see none thank you um Evan Ringo I hope
I've got that right and the next witness
after that will be uh
Nico
Anna Anniston I believe I hope I'm
pronouncing those correctly
hi can you hear me
cool uh hi I'm Evan Ringo I'm from
Pelham
um I would like to start talking about
uh some of the non-abortion uh aspects
that this could protect
um in 1952 uh Britain chemically
castrated one of the greatest computer
scientists of History Alan Turing
um the power to chemically castrate uh
by the state is currently uh uh in law
in a number of states here and that this
uh protection would help against that
and considering how often uh States have
wrong wrongfully convict people and put
them on death row
um only later for it to be overturned
I'm very worried about that uh the state
having the power to chemically castrate
uh or for sterilize for sterilize
um someone it I also uh am aware of how
easy it is for me as a man to go get a
uh
a vasectomy and the number of barriers
that are in place uh for a woman to try
and get her tubes tied
um and having this protection would make
it a lot easier for for laws to come in
place and for suits to be brought so
that women would have the easy the same
access uh that a man does to make these
choices proactively to you know prevent
abortions from happening similarly uh
there are a number of cases where uh
people have tried to restrict uh birth
control access which again makes it
proactive uh uh so that abortions don't
have to
uh come up um on the abortion issue uh I
I as a Libertarian I believe that it
your right to your body is the
fundamental right
um You don't really have any other
rights if you don't control your body
that's the kind of the basis of it all
of your property rights go away if you
can't control yourself you can't control
anything
um
so if the state is willing to take over
uh your choices in uh in that then
really they're pretty much able to take
over your choices with anything so I
just uh would urge you to uh to let
people make the choice on this to let
our citizens vote
um because you know that's kind of the
whole point of having freedom is letting
people speak their mind and by not
letting them vote you're basically
saying hey we don't trust you to speak
up and think for yourself so you know
maybe don't do that
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none
um nilo
Ennis
starcig I got it I'm sorry it's all good
and next after that will be Susan
Richmond
uh hello my name is Nico Anastasia I'm
from Portsmouth and I'm here today to
speak in support of crcr2
I rarely speak publicly and I'm here
simply in support of the women in my
life I strongly believe that women
should have the right to choose whether
or not to have an abortion
while I may not personally be able to
experience the physical and emotional
toll of pregnancy and childbirth I can
certainly empathize with difficult
decisions that women face when it comes
to the reproductive health
there are many reasons why a woman may
choose not to have an abortion that we
have heard today
whatever that reason it is ultimately
the women's decision to make not mine or
anyone else's
critics of abortion often argue that it
is immoral or goes against religious
beliefs however I believe mortality is
subjective and everyone has the right to
their own religious beliefs as protected
in our constitution
it is not fair or just of course someone
to adhere to a specific moral code
particularly when it comes to such a
personal decision
furthermore denying women access to safe
and legal abortion Services could have
devastating consequences it can lead to
dangerous back alley procedures
increased maternal morality rates and
perpetuate gender inequality
it is unfair to force women to carry
pregnancy to term against their will
in conclusion I believe that it is
important for men to support women's
right to choose when it comes to the
reproductive health
we should not seek to control or dictate
when a woman can or cannot do with our
own body but rather trust and respect
her ability to make the best decision
for herself and her future
access to safe and legal abortion
Services is essential for Women's Health
and autonomy and we must work to ensure
that these Services remain available and
accessible for all who may need them
please support bill cacr2 for women of
New Hampshire
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you sir
Susan Richmond and next after Ms
Richmond will be Erica
foreign
Revere I believe or Reverend okay thank
you chairman Lynn and members of the
committee I speak in support of cacr2 I
went to high school as did my husband
when uh prior to Roe v Wade and a female
colleague of my husband's in high school
jumped off the high school roof killing
herself because she did not have an
option of another way to end her
pregnancy so
um I here to stand up for the women who
have not had choice and who will not
have choice if their right to abortion
is taken from them and they will resort
to some method or other and it could be
back alley or self-inflicted abortion if
there's not legal medical safe means
thank you thank you questions for this
Witness
seeing none
um Erica and I'm again I hope
I think maybe it's Perez I'm sorry it is
foreign
good morning chair and members of the
committee my name is Erica Perez I'm
from Manchester New Hampshire and today
I'm seeking in support of cacr2 because
I think Reproductive Rights should be
codified into our state constitution
I want the security of knowing that
anyone from my state that chooses to
have an abortion can have one simply
because they need one without the red
tape of law following them around or
trying to intervene
the fact is that abortion is legal in
New Hampshire before 24 weeks for now we
have no guarantees we have nothing
protecting us from the people who
represent us one day deciding that we
should have a six-week abortion ban
which is an actual bill that's come up
for the past two years at least I want
the people of New Hampshire to decide I
think that's fair but a portion on the
ballot and see what the people of New
Hampshire really want the thing is we
aren't just talking about Reproductive
Rights we're talking about people's
futures we're talking about people
escaping abuse we're talking about
teenagers who aren't ready to be parents
we're talking about Freedom do we have
it or not do you believe in autonomy or
not
again please support cacr2 thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you uh Kathy Holmes
and next will be Sophie Mara
okay I have my stopwatch going I think I
can do this in one minute thanks to that
tall representative who had the cell
phone trouble
I hope he submits a written testimony
because I would sign my name to it
he so succinctly said all the things
that I would say I just have two things
to add one is I thought Senator Deborah
altshire had an excellent case for
issues like Ivermectin and vaccine and
I'm gonna look it up on the live stream
and get that information
but uh the last thing I want to put out
there is a phrase that my husband came
up with years ago why doesn't anybody
say this pro-choice that's pro-choice
before the ACT not the fact
women have a choice but with freedom
comes responsibility
that's it thank you questions for this
Witness
seeing none uh Sophie uh marrow and next
will be
um
Mary Rose McLaughlin
vera good morning can you hear me okay
great
my name is Sophie marrow I'm a
constituent from Portsmouth and I'm
really glad to be here today to show my
support for cacr2
um I volunteer with the lovering health
center and with the reproductive Freedom
fund of New Hampshire and my primary
role is supporting patients in Aftercare
uh providing emotional support and just
holding space for folks as they recover
um and you know every patient and their
experience is different but it is always
an honor to support people in this way
and I'm really proud to play a small
part in helping folks to access the care
that they need I'm proud of my friends
and my fellow volunteers who are here
today and who are here every day in
solidarity with each other
I'm proud of Tenors like the Love Ring
who and their commitment to Safe
compassionate and inclusive care and I
am the most proud of patients in New
Hampshire who advocate for themselves
and show tremendous bravery in the face
of fear uncertainty and unnecessary
obstacles
so I'm glad that we're here today to
talk about how we can remove those
obstacles I'm glad that my reps are
listening to the vast majority of
granite Staters who believe that
abortion should be legal in all or most
cases
we are one of the most supportive states
in the country when it comes to
reproductive Freedom so I'm glad for the
opportunity to correct the fact that New
Hampshire is the only state in New
England without protections for abortion
because the bottom line is that
reproductive freedom is a prerequisite
to being a full free and equal citizen
it is a foundational essential Liberty
without which none of the others can
exist
if the state can tell me if when and how
I become a parent I am not free
if the state can take that choice away
from me I cannot participate equally in
society and if my doctor needs to double
check with a lawyer or a politician
before providing care I am not safe
until we protect Reproductive Rights not
only are we not safe but we are out of
step with our tradition of respecting
folks privacy and personal decision
making and we will continue to waste
time and resources fighting regressive
legislation rather than working towards
a better healthier future
the right to Safe accessible
reproductive care is a fundamental human
right and must be decided by the voters
thank you for your time thank you
questions to this Witness
seeing none uh Mary Rose McLaughlin and
next will be uh Omer Ahern
okay good morning members of the G
ate you need to get up close to the mic
thank you thank you my name is Mary Rose
McLaughlin I am a student and a law
intern from Sullivan County
as you know
cacr2 proposes that an additional
section on reproductive Freedom be added
to the New Hampshire state constitution
cacr-2 states that an individual's right
to personal reproductive autonomy is
Central to the liberty and dignity to
determine one's own life course and
shall be not be denied or infringed on
unless justified by a compelling State
interest achieved by the least
restrictive means
saying that an individual should have a
right to personal reproductive autonomy
is completely good and true
however this amendment should not be
added to the New Hampshire state
constitution because it implies that the
current laws against infringing on
reproductive Freedom are not enough
the amendment being proposed implies
that abortion will perfectly ensure
reproductive freedom and the ability to
choose one's course of life
this is false
cacr2 will have the complete opposite
effect
reproductive Freedom defined as a
person's freedom to choose when they
wish to have a child and who they wish
to have it with is already protected in
New Hampshire RSA 632a
abortion takes away another individual
person's reproductive freedom and
autonomy and most importantly another
life
abortion infringes on Liberty dignity
autonomy and most especially the future
course of life of the fetal human being
therefore because this amendment implies
the legality of abortion it should not
be added to New Hampshire state
constitution thank you thank you
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much man
thank you um
Omer Ahern and next will be Julie LeDoux
thank you Mr chairman
my name is Omer Ahern Jr
and I am from Wentworth Grafton County
New Hampshire
I am one of seven children
I am the father of four children
and the grandfather of eight
grandchildren
I asked this committee to oppose cacr2
to me this is about saving precious
lives of human beings
I do believe that life
begins at conception
and ends at natural death
as humans
we can decide what we do
we are not
animals
so people already do have
reproductive
autonomy
decisions and choices are not always
easy
but they do have consequences
if a person does not want to have
a baby
just say no
before
doing the Act of Creation
even if the pregnancy is caused by a
criminal act
and the woman after thought does not
want to have the baby
a second crime is not justified in any
way
taking the life of another human being
there are many families who would
uh love to be able to help women in
these situations and there are medical
providers who will also help
the mother saved the life of the baby
and then this family or these families
would raise the child who can grow up to
be a great benefit to our Republic and
our society
I'm also an attorney
and in my law practice over the last 44
years
I would have married couples come into
my office
and ask me to help them find a baby if
they could adopt love and raise in a
loving family
but
they were not there
babies are needed
please save lives and oppose
cacr2 thank you very much thank you sir
questions for this Witness
saying none thank you uh Julie Ledoux
and
um after that uh will be Ash Draper
thank you I'm coming from Hollis New
Hampshire
um there's no way this is not going to
be emotional and subjective to one
degree or another
but I work with post-abortion survivors
who are horrified and traumatized by
what they've been through
my husband and when he was sitting to be
a physician
um
assisted in a procedure dilation
curettage
and watched as a living human being
struggled inside the womb and was hacked
to pieces
and he pulled out body parts
you can't have a foundation for anything
if you build it on
a false assumption
there's no foundation for freedom
or love or care anything we believe in
if we don't understand
what is essentially human and why we
must protect it and I want to ask those
of you women who've been hurt to please
forgive us
because you did deserve better care
personally support an organization that
will fly women any from anywhere in the
country
to be cared for completely through nine
months of pregnancy given everything
they need
this is the kind of thing we need I have
a lovely spiritual daughter
who went through an abortion because she
didn't believe she could survive
I found out afterwards and I told her if
I had known I would have done absolutely
everything I could to save her and her
child
and if it really really was an issue of
the choice of her life or the child's I
would have I would have chosen her
the reality is you had a senator stand
right there and talk about essential
constitutional liberties who was
ill-informed about something called
common law and um
essential natural rights
she said something about autonomy and
the sanctity of a person but she didn't
realize that the natural that the
natural rights she referred to in our
constitution
uh the the formation of those relied on
something called maxims of law that come
from the 17th century
and the maxims of law that informed uh
John Locke and the former the formers of
the Constitutions
our state constitutions and our
essential idea of what is human and what
is uh
Sanctified to protect comes from a maxim
law of law which is
um let me just find it here and read it
to you
maxims of law 58c who he who is in the
womb is considered as born when his
benefit is concerned that is the
foundation for uh natural law and common
law that were the foreign foundations of
our constitution
everything else is going to have to flow
from our reality and our acceptance at
every that humanity is messy
foreign
that we will die when we try to care for
one another it will hurt it will cost us
we will fail
but if we think a human baby is
three-fifths of a person like they
thought a slave was
and we don't move past that we will
never build anything that will create a
foundation
of Truth to build all our other values
on
constitutional amendment is not
something to just throw around if you
don't build from the right foundation
about what is human what deserves
protection you won't build true
Essential Health Care for Women we've
failed it's time for a new thing but we
can't build anything good and true and
Lasting and compassionate and truly free
if we don't understand but it's
essentially human
and must be protected at all costs or in
a painful time
we're in a painful time
we're going to have to rethink so many
things
we failed so many women and so many
babies
but you don't build what is good and
true and Lasting on a foundation of
lying
what is essentially human from the
moment it is conceived
thank you uh questions to this Witness
representative Morgan did you have a
question
um first of all well I hesitate to ask
you but um your heartening back to John
Locke's time and I'm not sure if I I'm
familiar with John Locke I'm not
um in his time was reproductive Health
something that was handled truthfully by
or primarily by men or is that something
that was with considered the time to be
kind of within the women's sphere of
influence um my point was simply that
when these matters were being considered
that even our forefathers and the people
who wrote the Constitution understood
there was an issue of life in the womb
and believe me abortion was very much an
issue
it always has been the issue of life and
death it's always been messy it's always
been difficult it's when we somehow just
assume
that somehow what creates essential
freedom is a woman's right to choose and
we we forget the foundation that freedom
is based on the value of humanity
we've got to go all the way back to the
beginning
and our Founders actually thought about
these things they really did so I
believe that Senator was pretty much
misrepresenting the idea of natural
constitutional law okay other questions
for this week um well then
the Constitution like it says all what
they wrote was all men are created equal
and I guess we the role of men and women
has changed a lot but actually all of
our men are born equal so why did they
do it board instead of conceived like
well I just was taking issue with the
fact that he had a senator who came here
and stood on constitutional law and you
could say well then maybe we shouldn't
listen to her because what she quoted
was written by men
I think it's just important that we
understand that our founders understood
How Deeply important it was to know who
is human
and why that matters in the womb
and why we can build from that something
better
that serves everyone
thank you cic R2 isn't it
thank you other questions for this
Witness
see none uh Ash Draper
my name is Ash Draper I'm a Chester
resident and New Hampshire native
I am a Yale trained Midwife I work in a
community health center in Manchester
and help bring babies into the world at
Elliott Hospital
I am here speaking for myself and I am
here in strong support of car
cacr2 a bill that supports the
reproductive decisions of all
at least 10 times a day I am witness to
the trauma and difficulty life brings to
so many
my patients are not here today due to
the many barriers some of which include
the inability to get time off from work
not having someone to watch their
children not having access to reliable
transportation or simply not speaking
English so I am here today to speak for
them and their families
I see how difficult reproductive
decisions are without the government
posing barriers I can confidently say as
an individual and as a health care
provider that it is your duty as
representatives to support individuals
in helping to make active decisions for
themselves and their families as we know
only an individual knows the best
situation for themselves the best
decision for themselves at that time in
their life
please vote to protect these families
and making decisions that are best for
them by codifying this constitutional
right
someone just a little while ago
suggested the idea of just saying no
I wish I could invite this person and
others who feel this way to Shadow me
for one day at work
or even just an hour
you would see this is not an option for
so many
while I would love to share the details
of stories of why saying no just doesn't
work for all I know it would keep you up
at night and I know I only have three
minutes to speak today
I only heard of this hearing last night
so I didn't have time to quite prepare
the statement I would like so I hope
this suffices
it's hard as a health care provider to
be present in vital hearings like this
one today when you are busy on the
ground doing the work caring for
individuals and their families their
fetuses and their babies
many of my colleagues are overwhelmed
and overworked ensuring that they
provide quality sensitive care to all
individuals so they don't have the
capacity to wait to speak here today
I have written testimony I have also
submit and I just want to offer the
space for questions now or at a later
time
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your time uh I I don't have any
other pink cars is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on cacr2
yes
um you need to submit a card do you need
to submit one of the pink cards and
you can speak first and fill it out you
can speak first and fill it out later
okay
I wasn't planning to speak but this uh
session move me my name is Catherine
haraki I live in Hampton New Hampshire
um statistically speaking one in five
pregnancies uh ended an abortion that
means that of these five Great Men
Behind you these framed leaders one of
their wives most likely had an abortion
why did that matter then because
what women did didn't matter then they
weren't considered so what they did
didn't matter either it wasn't worth
making legal or illegal
and I couldn't help but think what a
coincident it was that abortion didn't
become illegal until around 1829 the
same year or the year same year within a
year when the first
women's strike which happened in Dover
New Hampshire when 800 mil girls left
the factory
because of terrible conditions and what
a coincidence that the moment women
start asking for some rights other
rights start getting taken away
so this discussion isn't about right or
wrong we're all sinners
and if this was about right and wrong we
wouldn't have a governor we'd have an
Ayatollah this is about wants I want
Reproductive Rights she wants me
productive rights he wants Reproductive
Rights and some of you want Reproductive
Rights as well that's what we want and
that's what we're here discussing
although even so far as to say
that
by saying no to CRC or two it's not only
carpet bagging a philosophy that doesn't
belong in New Hampshire I would go so
far to say after hearing some comments
today
no to this to me might be saying that
you're trying to compensate for your own
sins and perversities
so my push today is for you to think
very carefully about New Hampshire's
History New Hampshire's wants and look
into your own soul and make the right
decision thank you questions to this
Witness
seeing none thank you anyone else who
wishes to speak on cacr2
seeing none I'm going to close
oh yeah please don't forget to fill out
the pink card okay so you know uh other
Witnesses desire to testify I'm going to
close the hearing on this and uh we've
been going now for uh
over two hours so I'm gonna take a brief
recess before we uh resume uh by taking
up uh HB 271 FN so we'll
all right all right so we'll take a
brief uh
uh how about when we say you know when
we say 10 minutes think of 10 minute
recess
yes
thank you
foreign
that's great
and then
oh my God
everything
that's fine
foreign
you know
like
um
thank you
foreign
well you know what I I took all of us I
took all the Reps and
but that's okay
right right here
10 minutes
thank you
absolutely
for the day
all right
foreign
all right um this is the house Judiciary
Committee I'm going to call it uh back
into session uh
to hear House Bill 271 FN
um and um I'm first going to recognize
the sponsor
um and because she is a sponsor I'm she
may speak for however long she needs to
speak to to tell us about the the bill
after she speaks I will uh because I
have uh because of time and because of
the number of people who have indicated
a desire to speak I will impose a a
three-minute limit on on other people
that uh wish to speak so without further
Ado I would recognize the prime sponsor
representative Marjorie Smith
you
you're you're not
please no not
to try Okay
um the sound system is terrible
uh let me set the stage Mr chair my name
is Marjorie Smith I'm honored to serve
on this committee
this is my 13th term during those 13
terms I have served on two major policy
committees only Judiciary and finance
and I have chaired each of those twice
so the connection between Judiciary and
finance is one that is very close to me
I care about
policy
procedures and politics in the Greek
sense of the word
trying to bring people together to solve
common problems not the same goals as
partisan politics which I have never
been good at
every two years how spill one is the
budget House Bill 2 is what we refer to
as the trailer Bill and House Bill 25 is
the capital budget bill that happens
every two years the trailer bill is the
bill that is created to provide any
language necessary
for the numbers that appear in house
bill one that is the only
material that is supposed to go into
House Bill 2 language which makes the
budget work
I am stuffy and I'm old-fashioned I
believe in doing what we are supposed to
do within the legal structure that we as
a nation
and a state and A legislature have
established
two years ago in complete violation of
policy
practice and procedures
a section was included in House Bill 2
that had absolutely nothing
nothing to do with the budget
there had been no assignment to a policy
committee
no hearing no relevant Committee Action
and no public dollars involved let me
repeat that no public dollars involved
the house and the Senate passed the
budget bills and the governor signed
them saying he objected to the language
that I object to here but he had no
choice because the budget had to pass
now let's think about that for a moment
that was an interesting statement on the
part of his Excellency
for two reasons the first is he claims
to respect the rights of women to
control their own bodies to make their
own choice
and he repeats that as he goes about the
country now
having an opportunity to present himself
to voters in other states
he talks about being pro-choice
and the other reason this is interesting
is not just two years before the
governor acted on his right to veto his
the budget and then a new budget was
formed he knew from his own experience
that he didn't have to sign a budget
bill that was anathema to him
if he had wanted to follow a policy
procedure and practice since then there
have been multiple efforts to try to
stop the Damage Done
and some but not all of the most
egregious components of this section
have been repealed
specifically the removal of the
intrusive and medically unjustifiable
requirement for ultrasound tests and
also by adding
language which acknowledged the
possibility of fatal fetal abnormalities
today you will hear in bills before us
some other efforts to try to erase more
of the language that never should have
become law
I'm not interested in a change here and
a change there in this case what I'm
looking forward to is tabula rasa a
blank slate that would then make it
possible for us to construct new
language following an appropriate
legislative process
to accomplish what an overwhelming
percentage of voter support
as indicated by their actions across the
country in states that are thought of as
red and states that are thought of as
blue
the right of people to decide for
themselves how to control their own
bodies I've had two children and I've
had my time in an obstetrician's office
never have I been in office big enough
to accommodate the patient the doctor
and 424 legislators we legislators have
no business
practicing medicine we are trained
in many fields
um but we are not trained as medical
professionals we are not subject to
centering if we violate medical
procedure we are not trained or equipped
to take the place of those with Germany
appropriate medical behavior and
enforcing those regulations
administratively and judicially medical
professionals are under
the supervision of people who know how
that should be conducted when I was
first elected in 1996 I was asked why
would I want to join a legislature that
not had not had a democratic majority in
the history of time or at least modern
time
my answer was that I believed not in the
Democratic platform or the Republican
platform but in the concepts of the
libertarian that had long been
the the force that governed the state of
New Hampshire a classic libertarian
philosophy that respected the right of
the individual to live
free
of Nest unnecessary government intrusion
and respected the principles of civil
rights and civil liberties
the corruption of House Bill 2 in 2021
violated that tradition
and we have a chance with this bill
to erase the blight
that exists because of the inappropriate
action of this legislature I hope you
will consider supporting this
bill which tries to undo something that
should never have been done in the first
place and I thank you very much
thank you representative Smith questions
for uh the sponsor
representative greeson thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative how
are you this morning I'm happy to see
you representative oh goody
given the level of misunderstanding
regarding the provisions of the fetal
Life protection act before we vote to
repeal it or not
I thought it would be beneficial if
everyone knew what the actual law says
so would you please explain what the law
actually says including any provisions
in the law that might prevent someone
from inadvertently running a foul of the
law that's a very good question and what
I should have done is to have the text
with me perhaps someone else does but I
can tell you that one of the most
egregious
remaining sections is that which
um basically permits anyone to bring
like a vigilante Squad to bring charges
against medical professionals for that
can result in felony convictions and
fines and obviously lost the license
uh that is something that is absolutely
appropriate to be done by medical
professionals who are violating the law
and violating the ethics of being a
medical professional I have no problem
with that my problem is that that should
happen in a due process logical way a
way that we have constructed over the
years and for for medical professionals
they cannot get a license unless they
pass certain tests training whatever
they have to periodically get new
training not training provided by the
legislature but by medical professionals
there if there is a complaint to be made
there is a body against
which that claim can be presented of
medical professionals who can say yes
this is a perfectly appropriate act
under the circumstances or no it isn't
and yes this medical professional should
be
uh punish and I'll use that Loosely in
some way it might be to have more
training it might be to go through a
period of supervision it might be to
lose the license all of that is
perfectly appropriate as long as that is
performed by the people who should do
that and that is the people whose job
is to make sure that doctors do what
they should do just as we have people
who make sure that lawyers do what they
should do or that contractors do what
they should do not 424 legislators who
wanted to make a political issue
out of something that is not a political
issue that has to do with personal
individual rights
Mr chair if I may follow up please
because I don't think I got a complete
answer on that is that the only thing
that this law the fee Life protection
act does is penalize doctors for
performing an abortion or are there
other Provisions well there have been
other Provisions
um uh uh is representative the former
version of a welfare still here
representative welper and I served
together on the Judiciary Committee
um and I was chair and I asked
representative Welter to be my clerk
there's never been a better clerk maybe
in the future there's going to be but in
the past there never was a better Clerk
representative welper and I could not
disagree more on this issue
but last term we came together and the
two of us helped to bring a bill through
the house and then the Senate that dealt
with the inappropriate use of um
uh
ultrasound tests
subsequent to that conversation
um the Senate on the basis of superb
testimony by people from across the
state agreed that there was the concept
of fatal fetal abnormality and that
there should not be
um uh
a a denial of the right for someone to
end a pregnancy so those are two changes
there is another change remaining and
I'm actually not sure how I feel about
it but I think and to be honest I must
acknowledge it to you and that is the
Restriction of 24 weeks I I'm not sure
that that that is
um
isn't I'm not sure that it's an
inappropriate specification and I say
that for a number of reasons there's
virtually no doctor in this state who
would perform an abortion even as late
as 24 weeks unless there was another
overriding reason such as a fatal fetal
and rally the life of the mother
um so on that sense I'm not so sure it's
disastrous but on the principle
of having this in-house Bill too
that's where I have problems it does did
not belong it shouldn't have come in
that way and if in its wisdom the
legislature constructed a new
that's fine but they ought to do it the
right way you have a bill you bring it
to a policy committee the policy
committee debates it
um there are procedures there are
processes and we go through it that way
I think representative that that covers
all the components but if you know of
something else that I haven't mentioned
I hope you'll remind me
I most certainly will thank you other
questions for this week yes
I'm sorry oh yes I'm sorry
representative Andrews
thank you thank you Mr chair uh just one
question
has any parts of this bill have been
challenged in court
any parts of this bill been challenged
in court
um
I'm drawing a blank right now
representative and I hope that you could
ask that question of people who have
much more knowledge than I do
other questions for this Witness
representative Dreesen
well I'm sorry
representative Paris had a question
representative Perez yes please
you use the term vigilante
um with doctors so
under this bill
you may then later you mentioned that
doctors could refuse to perform these
abortions
um
I'm confused by that what would these
Vigilantes be doing to to these doctors
would it be if they did not perform the
abortion or if there was
um some type of
something that happened at the abortion
or if they uh performed an abortion at
30 weeks I don't understand where the
doctors would be prosecuted thank you
thank you very much
um for asking the question you know we
always say that and we don't necessarily
mean it but we always say thank you for
asking the question
um sometimes we just assume you didn't
ask the question but it's a fine
question I don't believe I ever said
anything about a doctor refusing
to perform an abortion what I did
indicate that is under current Medical
Practice in this state
doctors who have special who specialize
in certain areas in including by the way
Obstetrics and Gynecology
um uh do not
necessarily have the equipment or the
experience to do the very very rare Act
of performing an abortion later in
pregnancy so it's not a question of
refusing it's a question of a doctor
understanding exactly what his or her
training has prepared him or her to do
and making sure that anyone who is going
to perform a medical procedure has the
necessary training and experience that
can happen for example in a state like
Massachusetts we're at the large
hospitals
pregnancies that are have gone on and
are running into terrible trouble that's
where people go in terms of my use of
the word vigilante it was right for you
to pick up on that word it's not a
polite word and it's not a word that I
would ordinarily use but I'm using it in
this sense because it is someone who is
not
directly involved in the situation in
other words not that the pregnant person
not anyone else the pregnant person
chooses to involve whether it's a
partner or a parent or a religious
um uh
consultant
and of course the doctor but someone who
was not involved who chooses to come in
and determine
that what had happened was not
appropriate and it is that person who in
the section the relevant section in
House Bill 2 is given this Authority and
um I think that although the word is not
a polite word the closest uh parallel
that I could come up with is vigilante
other questions for this Witness
thank you Mr chair
the the current law
says that there are no restrictions
whatsoever on abortions for the first 24
weeks and then a woman May obtain an
abortion after 24 weeks under certain
conditions rape incest fatal fetal
anomalies and health of the woman
there are no Provisions in the law to
even determine whether or not the baby's
at 24 weeks or as by your own statement
that the the ultrasound provision has
been stripped out so that is actually
not part of the law so there's no
Provisions at all regarding that so
given that
is it not true that abortions performed
after the first trimester are in fact of
significantly greater risk to the woman
herself so this fetal Life protection
act is actually also a pregnant woman's
Life protection act
um well first of all representative
um as I say I don't have uh the full
text in front of me but I beg to differ
with you I don't think that all of the
exceptions that you noted are in fact in
that legislation I could be wrong and
therefore I ask you to let someone who
follows me who has direct access to that
text to um to say what's accurate
um I have no problem at all claiming
um a vagueness in that second
um I my point in all of this with all
due respect is that I don't think that
you
or I
whether as a man or as a woman as
someone who is pro-choice or whatever
that means and I don't think any of us
have the right to decide for someone
else
how to control
their own lives I don't need
the government to decide that the way to
protect a woman
who is
um who has the possibility of getting
pregnant
um should be determined
by the government I think that the woman
should know
and I say woman and we understand that
as we come to better understand gender
and sex issues that might not be the
exactly right word but you know I've
been using that word for a long time so
it's hard to change
um
the government has no right
to be making this determination I think
at the moment
that a pregnancy has developed to the
stage where in fact
um
the embryo the fetus has left the
woman's body
um and is able to function
on its own outside of the woman's body
at that point the state I believe has an
interest and I would hope they would do
what happens in almost every other
industrialized State and some states
that aren't that the state has a program
to for example have people immediately
go to the home and say how are you doing
can we help you do you need some help
with uh without a nurse uh do you need
you know oh I see the toddlers wandering
around could I prepare peanut butter and
jelly sandwich for them all of those
kinds of supports are a way for the
state to send a message to a family
where there's a newborn that the state
cares the public cares about you and
your family and we're going to do
everything that we can to help that's at
the point
that the fetus is independent physically
of of the pregnant person and up until
then when the fetus cannot survive on
its own
it is to me
not yet in a state where the government
has an interest
other questions for this but
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your courtesy
um next I'm going to call on former
Senator Thompson
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Tom
Sherman I am from Rye New Hampshire I'm
representing myself
I'm a former State Rep state senator and
actually physician as well
as a practicing physician and a New
Hampshire state senator I spoke against
and voted against the first abortion ban
in this in our state's modern history
which circumvented the standard
legislative route for passage of policy
by being attached to the last budget
Bill signed into law by governor sununu
today I'm speaking in support of HP 271
which would repeal that ban
the abortion ban from its outset was a
solution in search of a problem
that actually put the health of both the
pregnant woman and the fetus at
increased risk
elective abortions
are not performed in New Hampshire
I'm sorry elected late term abortions
are not performed in the state of New
Hampshire
period
on the other hand there was ample
testimony raising concerns about the
ability of the medical community to
respond to situations in the third
trimester threatening the health of the
mother of the fetus
for which there were no appropriate
exceptions in that bill
which increased the risk for both the
mother and the fetus
we actually do have the capacity to
provide
state-of-the-art Maternal Fetal Medicine
sub-specialty care in the state of New
Hampshire
and our teams have been recognized as
being among the finest in the country
both at Dartmouth and at the Elliott
foreign
but these teams
under this bill that was signed into law
by the governor
actually
puts these providers
at risk of facing criminal and civil
penalties
providers of these services at Dartmouth
health
have expressed concerns that this this
would actually put their patients that's
the pregnant women
their lives at risk
under this ban
a woman facing a tragic complication of
her pregnancy
actually has to wait
with her medical team
for appropriate care until they and
possibly their attorney believes that
her life is threatened
the exception in the bill to answer one
of your questions
is for the life of the mother
there is no exception for the health of
the mother
as a doctor I recognize that this delay
of care actually increases
the mother's risk of death
they also reported that the threat of
these penalties have had a chilling
effect on the specialty practice of
appropriate high-risk care known as
Maternal Fetal Medicine
their practice has been recognized
nationally for their excellence
and regionally as an essential component
of all obstetric care that means every
level of OB GYN care
in the eastern half of Vermont
and in the northern and western half of
Maine in addition to New Hampshire
that's the referral base for Dartmouth
health
the band's Provisions for felony
prosecution in the state of New
Hampshire for the appropriate practice
of medicine is a real threat to the
ability to recruit and retain these
specialized providers
and as a result to the continued ability
of Dartmouth health and the Elliott
hospital to provide these services not
just in New Hampshire but across the
region
and remember there is no exception
in this ban
for rape and incest
I joined the vast majority of granite
Staters who recognize abortion as an
essential component of Health Care
as such deciding whether or not to
proceed with an abortion is an intensely
private
and personal process between the
pregnant patient and their doctor or
nurse practitioner
leaving this decision in those capable
hands by passing HB 271
you will restore not only the freedom of
all Grant Staters to make their own
health care choices but also the ability
of our own highly specialized providers
to actually protect the health and life
of both the mother
and the viable fetus
both in the individual clinical
situations and also
in order to assure ensure the viability
of our maternal fetal medicine programs
in New Hampshire
this bill
that was run through the budget
was a mistake
we keep spending your valuable time
trying to repair the damage correct the
mistakes
and oddly enough in a bill that was
brought forward
to protect the life of the fetus
to actually turn around and change that
bill over and over again
to protect the life of the mother and
the fetus
that bill that ban needs to be repealed
and as representative Smith said
you need to start over
if you believe there should be a ban
make it one that does not threaten
the lives of pregnant women
the lives of their fetuses
and the viability of some of the top
programs in Maternal Fetal Medicine in
the country thank you I'm happy to take
any questions questions for this Witness
yes uh excuse me sorry
um
the way the law is written in New
Hampshire would this be an accurate
assessment I'm not sure if it is or not
and maybe you can answer this maybe you
can't
um if say after 24 weeks I as a pregnant
woman
um went to another state
that would take care of the abortion say
it was in a case of an in vitro like
there was multiple births and you had to
downsize and there wasn't the ability to
do it here in this state I went to the
other state had the downsize of the one
child came back that was life
threatening to the other baby or myself
if I came back to this state would I be
um prosecuted as a mother as a woman for
having that
baby
taken so if if I have the question if
you were facing for example a threat to
your health yes not your life yet so
something like preeclampsia in the third
trimester
and you know that that could get worse
and that it's progressing but the
attorneys at your hospital along with
the team of doctors can't definitively
say that it is life-threatening which is
the exception in New Hampshire if you go
to another state to get the care that
you believe you need
um I think that's I I actually don't
know if you could be prosecuted if you
came back into the state but
since the physician who performed that
or the provider of Reform that is out of
state
then they could not be prosecuted and
that I know of uh in other words the
bill the law that's there now actually
the the felony conviction is of the
provider
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Andrews
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
chairman for taking my question do you
know if the current abortion law
has been or is currently challenged in
any Court
I don't know of any
challenge
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much sir oh
I'm sorry
representative Perez sorry
thank you
um what is your practice
I'm your favorite kind of doctor so I
hope you all are up to date on your
colonoscopies I'm a gastroenterologist
it's good for your health I I have
another question if I may
so if we repeal this law we would go
back to NOLA
correct and that would mean that anyone
in the state of New Hampshire could have
an abortion at any time with no for any
reason with no limitation
um up to birth
um and
do you not see
the concern about the life of the mother
at that point
I have I was worked in recovery room and
I actually took care of others
um
in late term abortions it was very
similar and I'm not saying it's the same
but very similar to post C-section care
and delivery and I just
did you feel that going back to no law
is the way to protect women here in New
Hampshire
well first of all that's not what I said
uh what Young so
we have lived with the protections of
Roe versus Wade since the early 1970s
prior to that if you talk to
um
some of the OB gyns who are still around
from prior to that they saw the
complications of illegal abortions
uh many of which the women died of
sepsis they died of hemorrhage
um
but what we've seen since the early 70s
is we don't see what you've described in
the state of New Hampshire
it's not something it's not a thing
there are not providers in the state of
New Hampshire licensed by the Board of
Medicine who perform elective late-term
abortions I said that early in my
testimony
so I'm not sure where you were
practicing but in New Hampshire
it is such a high risk procedure it
would be like me going and doing routine
colonoscopies on 90 plus year olds we
don't do that it's not a thing
so so that's
that is we have lived without an
abortion ban in the Live Free or Die
state
for decades and we have not seen what
you're describing
representative press follow-up
I was saying when the I should have said
when the life of the mother was
um in jeopardy
and it was here in New Hampshire and my
question to you is where did without any
law
where did late term where did mothers
who wanted late-term abortions go to
have their abortions if you said they
are not
they were not being done here in New
Hampshire or were they done illegally my
concern is if we eliminate this
completely are we going back to yeah
kitchen table abortions for people who
want them no we're actually going back
to the way we were two years ago
in New Hampshire before January 1st 2022
for the last 30 years that's where we're
maybe 40 years I can't do the higher
math
that's where we're going
doctors in New Hampshire don't perform
elective late-term abortions they do
very rarely
do the necessary and appropriate medical
procedure to save the life or to
preserve the health of the mother
that's where we were before January 1st
and if they wanted an elective abortion
my understanding is that there are only
a few places in the entire country and
there are none in New Hampshire where
you can go for an elected third
trimester abortion
which Stapleton
my question is that
do we have any statistics
that
indicate whether this bill has resulted
in
a
positions being deterred
or otherwise attracted to New Hampshire
because of this bill in either case
well I would ask
a question or response as a physician
so maybe it's a little rhetorical
if I had a choice of going to Vermont
to practice Gastroenterology
and I could do it freely
using standard of practice and the Board
of Medicine as my guide
or
come to New Hampshire
where doing everything appropriate in
the practice of my medicine I could end
up with a
jail term of seven years
and a hundred thousand dollar fine loss
of my career
and all the other things that go along
with not even just a felony conviction
but a felony charge
where do you think I would practice
they have three providers right now
approaching retirement in the seven
physician
maternal fetal medicine program at
Dartmouth Hitchcock
I would never
come to New Hampshire
under the threat that this ban presents
that's my own personal opinion as a
physician
I I thank you for relating that uh but
my question was do we have statistics
that show that this bill has resulted in
Physicians being deterred from coming to
New Hampshire to practice I guess the
answer I don't know of any felony
charges haven't been brought yet
but I can guarantee you that the threat
alone which is supposed to be a
deterrent right it's not just a
deterrent for doing
inappropriate Medical Care in the third
trimester it's a deterrent for doing
appropriate Medical Care
and it's a deterrent from any of us
thinking about New Hampshire as a good
place to set up an OB GYN practice
I believe you had a question
oh yeah thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Dr Sherman you bet
uh I guess my question is in the absence
of this
um and and across Medical Care in
general as a physician
um the conduct of providers is governed
by a range of other
um structures uh from the hypocratic
oath from the get from the beginning to
um
standards of care in the various
professions and and then also within
each organization and maybe beyond the
medical ethics boards that I presume
would potentially have an interest in in
a case like this if it were to be
presented could you say a little bit
more about how they uh these parameters
sort of work and have worked in the past
and
um and I guess uh well let me leave it
there actually so
um I've practiced in multiple States
and it's slightly different from state
to state but the governing principle in
healthcare is you know the oath the
Hippocratic Oath our training
and then following standards of practice
and standard of practice is pretty well
delineated for each of our Specialties
for how we practice
deviations from that
um especially where they end up causing
harm
are brought before the Board of Medicine
if they cause a death or if there is
that level it can even go as far as
being criminally investigated
so there's already a mechanism as
representative Smith was talking about
there's already a mechanism for what
happens when you practice inappropriate
care that can be inappropriate
prescribing it can be a procedure that
you're not doing appropriately
um and in every state there is that
mechanism I believe
that that mechanism has for the most
part it's not perfect but none of these
systems are perfect whether you're a
lawyer or a doctor or a businessman or
or any profession
but it really is geared toward the
protection of the patient and the life
of the patient and the well-being of the
patient
representative did you have a question
all right any other questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you good to see you all representative
Gene Janine knotter please
yeah
oh are you um yeah I'm gonna call on
representative uh former representative
Kurt wolper at next
afternoon Mr chairman and members of the
committee
um Hillsboro 12th I represent uh was on
Judiciary last term and we all got along
very well even though we don't agree on
this issue and we never will no matter
what we say to each other
so
two and a half years ago when I knocked
on doors and we talk about abortion
most of the people that I talked to
would say by the third trimester oh yeah
by then that's too late
so we Pat we only passed late term
abortion this time around this campaign
season I couldn't believe how many
people think that we banned abortion are
all nine months
either these people were lied to or
they're just completely misinformed I
don't know where they got the
information from
but it's only the third trimester when
the child
can survive outside the womb
if if it's so rare then why repeal it I
remember sitting on that committee on
this committee and asking an abortionist
well how often do you have late-term
abortions and she said oh it's very very
rare and like well how do you know I've
sponsored the statistics bills we don't
have any statistics in New Hampshire we
don't know who's give doing abortions
how many even aggregate we couldn't even
get past it as aggregated
um statistics you know by County so that
to protect you know if somebody has one
you don't want to find out in a small
town so I'm losing my train of thought
here but I also um wanted to mention
a woman named Gianna Jensen maybe you've
heard of her
she's one of the leading pro-life
activists in the country
in the 1970s her mother
um went underwent a saline abortion
and Giannis survived and it is only
because the nurse working at the clinic
called an ambulance that this this woman
went on went on to live she had cerebral
palsy and she has some other issues from
the saline that burned her
but I first met her while I talked to
her on the phone when she was a young
teenager and I interviewed her I had to
get through her mother first on the
phone it was like very difficult I had
to I had to convince her that I was a
friendly and not someone was going to be
mean to her and then I met her here in
New Hampshire
it was in Manchester and I interviewed
her again
um we talked about
um
rape and incest there's a woman in New
Hampshire who's written a book she's
also been very outspoken her name is
Darlene Pollock
her mother was raped she's the product
of that crime she herself was raped her
daughter is a product of that crime
but she knew that killing the baby
wasn't going to make what happened to
her go away
and uh the last thing I want to say is
we had a former representative
I don't know how many terms ago it was
but he stood at the well and said in the
case of rape if someone has to die why
not kill the rapist
thank you questions for the switch
representative Morgan
um thank you I just have a oh sorry did
you have a question yeah yes oh okay I
actually have a process question which
uh what oh he's not taking you well she
she doesn't want to take anything oh I
understand yeah the uh
all right representative Kurt wolper
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
again my name is Kurt welper I live in
Stratford and I'm here speaking for
myself
microphone
I'll confine myself to the process
of passing the feed away protection act
because what I've heard here just makes
my ears burn
House Bill 625 came to the Judiciary
Committee
it was had a public hearing
it was voted in expedient to legislate
to the house floor
that vote was overturned by a vote of
192 to 161.
it was vote it was moved ought to pass
that vote succeeded on a vote of 191 to
160. I'll get that backwards the
overturn was 162 to 190.
so we overturned the committee
recommendation a lot in expedient
and we voted the house voted it ought to
pass 191 to 160.
it went to the Senate
the senate had a hearing
and then Things become murky
because it never got under the heading
of Hillsville 625
it never got a hearing in uh a vote in
the Senate what it did get was amended
amended to move it into part of hb2
that Amendment
was thoroughly devoted on debated
on the senate floor so just to be clear
the house house bill 625 had full
procedures in the house
and in the Senate
and then hp2 went
to the house it went through Committee
of conference with the Senate
and it was voted ought to pass
by both bodies
so I think that's six votes
of the House and Senate
to approve Hospital 625 or the fetal
Life protection act
in this in these in these walls that's
the full blood full monty they called
right
and it went to the governor and he did
sign it and he did not approve of it
but he signed what hp2 anyway
and we'll leave that with that
and ever since he's been trying to get
it
modified
the other thing I've been a lot of
discussion about the uh actual
construction of the bill
and you're going to hear more about that
later the only thing I want to say is
that when House Bill 2 passed House Bill
625 passed
the Constitutional order
was that any
abortion ban
had to be
later in the in the pregnancy after an
at a viability standard
which 24 weeks met and it had to have
two exceptions
for the life of the mother and for the
health of the mother
both were included in House Bill 625
thank you questions for this Witness
representative Horton
thank you and this is uh
just give me a chance to ask what I
wanted to ask the previous uh previous
member and you gave a pretty good
explanation of the legislative history
of it um
and this the governor gave a budget
address yesterday just like he did two
years ago and two years ago this was not
um this was not in his initial budget
proposal but uh
then it goes to the house and said it's
a very lengthy process and lots of
things
creep into the uh creep into the Budget
Trailer build but
so is the governor totally powerless
well the House and Senate are working on
it or does he have some uh influence
either publicly and or behind the scenes
over what is or is not included in the
final product that is then sent to his
desk
in in June yes
thank you yes all right next question is
there any other questions
thank you very much I'm next going to
call on Kayla Montgomery please
good afternoon members of the House
Judiciary Committee my name is Kayla
Montgomery I am the vice president of
public affairs for Planned Parenthood of
Northern New England and Planned
Parenthood New Hampshire action fund and
we support this bill before you house
bill 271. so three points for you today
about why New Hampshire's abortion ban
should be repealed in its entirety
first
the current law has an exception to
abortion after 24 weeks in the case of a
fatal fetal diagnosis and that critical
exception was added to this body just
last year
now some lawmakers have questioned why
someone would need an abortion later in
pregnancy if not for a fatal fetal
diagnosis
and to be perfectly clear no one no one
wakes up at eight or nine months
pregnant and just decides they no longer
want to be pregnant that doesn't happen
but the fact is that every pregnancy is
different and that our bodies don't
always follow black and white laws
and that is why blanket abortion bans
don't work
carving out exceptions also creates a
legal gray area and we know this
because with rogon we are hearing of
more sexual assault victims including
children
who are denied abortion care at all
stages of pregnancy
and prior to row falling these
absolutely horrific examples like the 10
year old in Ohio last year would have
remained under the radar because these
survivors would been able to get care in
their home state
and these stories they're heartbreaking
and they're cruel but they're an awful
reality
and we should not have to hear firsthand
from these patients to understand that
this happens
we should instead have compassion
and respect and allow doctors to help
their patients make these incredibly
complicated decisions
and second the current abortion
restrictions impact our health care
landscape at a time when chaos and
confusion around the full range of
reproductive health and rights Reign
because of the overturning of Roe v Wade
the current law criminalizes our
providers who are exercising their best
medical judgment
I think we can all agree that New
Hampshire is home to world-class doctors
and hospitals who are highly trained and
experienced in their fields so should
our state be sending its citizens in
these complex medical situations out of
state to get the care that New Hampshire
doctors are trained to deliver
and finally the state of New Hampshire
has a long bipartisan history of
supporting privacy around reproductive
Health it was a New Hampshire
republican-led legislature that repealed
Three pre-roll Laws 25 years ago and it
was a New Hampshire republican-led
legislature that was the first in the
nation to urge the FDA to approve
medication abortion back in 1991 citing
Quote The issue is freedom of choice and
medical treatment unquote
the state of New Hampshire has a proud
history of trusting doctors and women
and families in these complexities
decisions to do what's best for them the
state government should not be reaching
into these decisions people must have
the freedom and privacy to make their
decisions about their pregnancy and
consultation with their doctors so we
urge a vote of ought to pass on 271 and
trust women and doctors to make these
private decisions without government
interference questions for this Witness
representative Perez hey thank you I
have three very quick questions prior to
Roe versus Wade up to what gestation
does Planned paren up Planned Parenthood
perform abortions after Roe versus Wade
up to what gestation does Planned
Parenthood now perform abortions and do
you know of any
abortions being denied to any of the
Planned Parenthood
clients since this abortion
thank you for the question so
um
abortion after 24 weeks is out of the
scope of Planned Parenthood practice to
be perfectly clear that is care that
happens in a hospital setting that's
care in New Hampshire that would happen
at places like Dartmouth or the Elliot
it does not happen at Planned Parenthood
so you know as a representative Planned
Parenthood it is not within our scope of
work Planned Parenthood in New Hampshire
we have four sites in New Hampshire to
perform abortion two do not Manchester
performs both medication abortion and in
in-house Center abortion up to 15.6
weeks
uh in Manchester it's 15 weeks six days
and in Keen it's medication abortion
only which is up to 11 weeks now that's
at Planned Parenthood in New Hampshire
Planned Parenthood of Northern New
England is the affiliate and that is
Maine Vermont and New Hampshire in
Vermont and Maine the house centers go a
little bit later gestation but in
Manchester that's where it is that was
the case before rofel and that is also
the case now that didn't change with row
falling and I'm sorry I forgot your
third question representative Stapleton
I think you had a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
in the case of
rape victims
including children abused
why would
we wait
until the third trimester to
resolve or answer that issue there by
creating a greater risk
for the women involved
yeah thank you for that question and
there's no easy answer here because this
is complicated anyone who is a victim of
sexual assault is dealing with a
tremendous amount of barriers
barriers including maybe not knowing
that they're pregnant not sure how to
get the care they need not sure where to
get the care not be able to afford it
there's many many different reasons
that is true for any victim or any
Survivor of sexual assault but when you
add the fact that there's potentially
minors in this situation and we know we
know that there are potentially that
there are minors who are in a situation
these barriers become overwhelming how
can we expect a child to navigate the
Health Care system so unfortunately the
reality is that sometimes people can't
get the care that they want when they
know it sometimes it takes them longer
because of these barriers and that's
true that was true before real following
and that's especially true now when half
of our country is experiencing these
abortion Bans
thank you representative Manish
thank you Mr chair
um Miss Montgomery we heard conflicting
testimony about the exceptions in the uh
fetal Life protection act and I was
wondering if you would clarify your
understanding of what the exceptions are
thank you certainly so RSA 324 Colin I'm
sorry 329 Colin 44 is the RSA you can
look that up
um so the exceptions as it is now as the
law is currently today there's an
exception for maternal life and there's
a very narrow exception for physical
health as well and then of course
there's the Fatal fetal diagnosis which
was added last year
and those are the exceptions and that's
it so am I correct that that as you just
said there is an exception for for uh
for the one the health of the mother
even if it's not even if it's not a
threat to the life of the mother it has
to be a significant threat to the health
but there is a health exception in the
current law there is a life exception
and there is a physical a very narrow
physical health exception which lists
some things but the I think it's
important to remember when it comes to
exceptions is that there's a lot of
legal gray areas because council at One
hospital might view it differently than
council at another hospital and these
are of course moments you know when
you're dealing when you're dealing with
these moments this is minutes count and
so the that's why there's a tremendous
amount of gray area and that's by just
removing that barrier altogether would
be a better approach other questions for
this Witness
yes representative greeson thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking our
questions you said that at the
Manchester Clinic where they perform
actual physical abortions uh you go out
to 15 weeks and six days correct how do
you determine that it's 15 weeks and six
days versus 16 full weeks how do you
actually know the gestation of the baby
certainly so there's lots of different
ways and there's a you know this we
offer patient-centered care so every
situation is going to be very different
medication abortion which I said is
offer up to 11 weeks here in uh here at
our health centers in health centers in
New Hampshire if someone comes in and
they know exactly the date of their last
period they are low risk maybe they know
that they're eight weeks then they can
have their medication abortion if
someone's not sure the date of their
last period That's generally the most
um the biggest factor in not having the
dates for your pregnancy then you could
do an ultrasound to figure that out but
every situation is going to be different
every pregnancy is going to be different
and we're going to work with each
patient to decide what's best for their
care
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you I'm next
going to call on Bob Dunn I'm sorry I'm
going to call on representative sellers
I got out of order and Bob Dunn will be
next and I'm going to ask everyone
please it's now 12 30.
um we're supposed to start the hearing
on the third bill in half an hour no one
has had lunch yet so I'm going to ask
you to please keep your remarks uh to
three minutes and I'm going to enforce
that okay thank you thank you Mr chair
and committee members uh I will only
take less than a minute I hope
um I want to just State a couple things
uh I actually agree with representative
Smith I don't think anything should be
stuffed into a budget and even though
there's a process for reviewing and
triple checking it it you know years and
years and A's and let's move forward and
let the governor actually sign it or not
sign it all right however now on the
next thing is uh honorable Sherman
he mentioned something about
um there are no abortions actually after
24 weeks or at that point on
I'm saying we don't track the bushes we
don't even know how many we do in the
state
so how does he know and how do we know
that
does any of you have any members on how
many abortions we do
I've seen guesstimates of 2200 a year
and I probably think they're taking that
by because of the other states that
allow abortions and number of people in
our state they're just guesstimating
that we do 2200 a year so therefore I do
want to make sure because I didn't say
it on the last one I oppose this bill
all right I think right now it's in
place and it's working and we should
move forward and I also oppose the loss
Bill thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none uh Bob Dunn and the next
person up will be uh Danielle
Mr Dunn uh thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee
um I'm going to keep this very short
I've got written testimony I'll defer to
what I said earlier except uh and I'm
Bob Dunn uh the public policy director
for the Roman Catholic Diocese
Manchester representing uh Bishop Peter
labashi and the diocese and I'm going to
quote from Roe v Wade
um this is what Rose said and I think
sometimes this is often forgotten in row
the court recognized and this is a quote
the state's important and legitimate
interest in potential life and the court
determined that again quote if the state
is interested in protecting fetal life
after viability it may go so far as to
prescribe abortion during that period
except when it is necessary to preserve
the life or health of the mother
um and so the law that's in place today
is consistent with Roe the law was
remember enacted before Dobbs was ever
decided
so it was consistent I think with the
Constitutional situation that was uh in
place two years ago
um and so uh the law that is in place
today was consistent with what Roe
allowed and uh we think it would be
inadvisable to go back to a situation
where there was absolutely no limit
abortion for any reason up to birth
thank you thank you question for Mr Dunn
seeing none thank you uh Miss Pimentel
and then the next one up will be Allison
Bedell and I'm just I direct this to
their other members of the committee
given the uh the time if some of you
want to go have lunch go right ahead I'm
going to stay and what maybe what I'll
do is after somebody after the sort of
first
group of people who may decide to have
lunch do that when you get back I may uh
ask uh someone to take over from me
while for a few minutes while I go have
lunch but please feel free to do that
and we'll hear next from Ms Pimentel
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Danielle Pimentel
it's a pleasure to speak with you again
this morning as I stated earlier I serve
as policy council at Americans United
for life which is a national law and
policy nonprofit organization with a
specialization an abortion end of life
issues and bioethics law and I will try
to be brief um given the time
constraints I urge the committee today
to oppose hb271 because it removes
necessary protections for the health and
safety of pregnant women and unborn
children and is inconsistent with New
Hampshire's legitimate interest in
protecting human life
if HB 271 is passed abortion on demand
up until birth will be allowed in New
Hampshire which will subject women to
higher risks of Health complications as
well as maternal deaths only six states
explicitly endorse abortion on demand
and New Hampshire should not become one
of those states it is well known that
abortions carry a higher medical risk
when done later in pregnancy and 10
percent of women experience immediate
complications from abortion that can be
life-threatening after eight weeks
gestation the risk of death increases by
38 with each additional week
because hb271 would allow abortions on
demand up until birth more women will
experience life-threatening
complications from later term abortions
which will likely also increase the
number of maternal deaths the woman of
New Hampshire deserved better than to be
subjected to later term abortion
procedures that threaten their health
and safety in that way
New Hampshire also has a legitimate
interest in preventing fetal pain as
noted by the Supreme Court in the Dobbs
decision
um if the fetal Life protection act is
repealed and abortions are allowed up
until birth that will leave unborn
children who can experience pain from
abortion unprotected current Medical
Science has firmly established the
existence of pain and pre-born infants
on or before or at least by 20 weeks
gestation
so given the substantial evidence that
that pre-born babies experience pain by
at least 20 weeks gestation if not
earlier it Is Well with the New
Hampshire's legitimate interest to
oppose a spell in order to minimize
fetal pain as much as possible
um lastly I'll be brief and my last
point
hb27 would also get rid of the
ultrasound requirement HP pardon me the
Life protection act requires that an
ultrasound be performed
um if a woman is a 24 weeks gestation
and these are important protections
because they enable health care provided
to accurately date the gestation of the
baby which protects the woman by
ensuring the appropriate abortion
procedure is performed
my last point is there are numerous
states have enacted strong pro-life
bills law is part of me after Roe v Wade
was overturned there's at least three
other states that maintain enforceable
limit on abortion at 24 weeks 18 states
have protected life at conception and
three states to protect life after a
heartbeat has been detected so by
rejecting
hb271 New Hampshire will be joining
numerous states to continue having laws
that affirm life
thank you questions for this weapons
seeing none of Allison thank you uh
bodell and the next witness will be
Michelle silly foisy
oh that's fine that's fine all right yes
please
hi my name is Allison bodell and I'm a
resident of hooks at New Hampshire
and I'm here in support of little babies
in the womb
um I oppose the uh repeal of the fetal
protection act
I think if you knew more about
fetuses and abortions you would you
would want to repeal it too let me
explain what happens when abortion is
done
I have to warn you that and I think I
gave you all a copy of this so I'll kind
of keep it kind of brief but um I have
to warn you that it is very graphic to
perform an abortion the mother is given
anesthesia the doctor then uses an
instance called a forceps which are
actually just big tweezers and they they
enter the womb and um they start pulling
out pieces of the of the baby the fetus
First It's usually the feet because
that's the position that the fetus is in
at the time at the time the vision
the babies are in that position at the
time so they pull one leg and then they
pull the other and then they pull the
arms and finally when they get to the
head because it's not really a um a
birth that kind of a thing the canal is
very small so they have to squish the
head and break the head
and the Brain comes
sizzling out it's like I said it's very
graphic
um
so that's basically it and I think she
had talked about
um having pain and I was wondering if
you thought about if the fetus does feel
pain well has anyone ever heard of Dr
Ben Carlson
he is a pediatric neurosurgeon and he
specializes in in people and babies for
example works on co-joined twins also
known as Siamese twins
he's discovered that fetuses do Winston
Payne when he would attempt to do their
surgeries all of his tiny patients after
that would receive anesthesia for all
their surgeries just like their mother
so in closing my hope is that you
realize that fetuses are tiny living
babies not just masses of cells
and that we should repeal this this act
does that have any questions thank you
questions for this Witness
thank you very much
Michelle foisy and next will be
Mara Casey
great thank you
good afternoon Mr chair and house
Judiciary Committee
my name is Michelle silly foisy I live
in Temple and I am here today in support
of HB 271 repealing the fetal Life
protection act
before telling my daughter Kayla's
abortion story at 22 weeks due to a
fatal fetal anomaly to the New Hampshire
house Judiciary Committee last February
I had never told my ice our story in
public
over the last year I have had the honor
of meeting people from all over the
state while advocating for Reproductive
Rights
through my own storytelling I have in
turn heard many stories of abortion
stories of relief for their life and
future ahead after having an abortion
stories of loss of dearly wanted
pregnancies and stories of self-love
after enduring a horrifying sexual
assault
on this journey I have learned that
Granite Staters overwhelmingly believe
in and support legal and safe accessible
abortions for all
but New Hampshire's abortion ban puts
politicians between patients and
providers
18 years ago I sat with my husband in
the paranatologist's office we were
devastated by the news we had just
received
we learned that our second child who we
desperately wanted had no chance of
surviving outside of my body due to her
fatal anomalies
though my heart was crushed I felt the
most incredible compassion and empathy
from our medical provider
listening to him explain our options
with the patience and understanding he
exemplified with us on that day is
something I will never forget
the relationship we developed in a very
short amount of time was a bond I cannot
describe and a trust that cannot be felt
without living the experience itself
without my provider's expertise I firmly
believe my life would not be as it is
today as a mother of six living children
a medical provider that has the burden
to share the horrible news that a wanted
pregnancy will not have the outcome once
dreamed of deserves compassion as well
all medical professionals enter the
world of Medicine with the desire to
help others and as their own states to
do no harm
New Hampshire's abortion ban
criminalizes doctors for doing their job
and working with their patients to get
the care they need just as my doctor did
on that fateful day
as a person who has had an abortion
later in pregnancy I understand the
complexity of reproductive Health Care
families in New Hampshire can face
harrowing circumstances ma'am can I
we're you're at the three-minute Mark so
can I ask you to finish up please
and may have difficult they may have to
make difficult choices letting Kayla go
from the body that was not able to
sustain her life outside of mine was our
way of setting her soul free
for me and my family choosing abortion
was a true Act of Love last year the New
Hampshire legislator took an important
step to mitigate some of the harm caused
by the state's abortion ban adding an
exception for fatal fetal diagnoses
however it's kind of going over the
limit now ma'am I really need to have
you finish up okay okay I apologize
studies show that survivors of rape
incest and sexual assault can experience
delayed decision-making due to trauma HB
271 removes barriers to care for
patients who need not to disclose their
personal circumstances with an arbitrary
time limit
Staters knows no no I'm I'm sorry ma'am
you really are way up your time thank
you are the questions to this Witness
saying none thank you next I'm going to
call on Maura Casey and the next witness
after that will be Peter Hogan
Miss uh Casey yes
hi my name is Maura Casey I live in
Manchester New Hampshire and I'm here in
support of house bill 271. can you hear
me okay yes okay
I never thought that I would be affected
by the politics around abortion Ron and
I wanted a baby very badly and we're
thrilled when I finally got pregnant
last year
unfortunately after the first trimester
our joy and excitement turned to shock
and grief
neither of us had heard of Trisomy 18
before but now I know that that it is a
rare severe and life-threatening genetic
condition
even though we hoped it wasn't true both
a blood test and an ultrasound confirmed
the diagnosis we had incredibly hard
decision to make
if I stayed pregnant the most likely
outcome was a stillbirth which I
honestly was terrified of
if my pregnancy was brought to term the
baby could die from hard and or
breathing problems during the birth
if by some miracle the baby was born
alive it would be a short and painful
life probably lasting only a few days
we would never want to put a baby
through that I also didn't want to put
myself through the trauma of a
stillbirth
on the other hand I was worried about
having an abortion I was mostly scared
the baby would feel pain I was already
attached to this baby and wanted to do
right by it
I learned that the baby wouldn't feel
anything and made sure that the remains
would be handled respectfully
I learned that the baby wouldn't feel
pain by medical providers not the
internet
although I had so many confusing
emotions going on I'm completely
confident that the decision to end the
pregnancy was the Humane one
after the surgery it took time to
process and grieve unfortunately our
ability to go through that process was
derailed when we got the bill for
sixteen thousand two hundred ninety
three dollars which later increased to
twenty two thousand seven hundred and
forty four dollars
prior to getting that bill I hadn't even
considered that it might not be covered
by insurance
I tried to appeal based on the severity
of the baby's diagnosis but was again
denied
I hope that sharing this story helps
people understand that people have
abortions for many reasons abortions can
be incredibly sad scary and painful
women need to feel safe when they're
making these difficult and personal
choices
please consider that abortion isn't
cruel it can be a way to decrease
suffering of fetuses babies and
potential parents
please consider passing HB 271 thank you
questions for this one yes
representative Perez excuse me and how
many weeks did you have your uh
termination of your pregnancy it was 14
14 weeks and how would this a bill that
you would like to see go away have
prevented that from happening I think
that
insurance and
intertwined so I think that my health
insurance likely was affected my private
health insurance was likely affected by
the politics around I'm sorry I think
that politics and health insurance are
intertwined in some ways and I think
that um
my health insurance made the decisions
not to cover my
treatment because of politics political
reasons I don't know more than that I'm
not a politician so I'm sorry I'm not
going to take any more questions thank
you
a follow-up I just how would this bill
have stopped you from having that
abortion
all right um other questions all right
thank you uh Peter Hogan please
and next will be Omer uh Ahern
my name is Peter Hogan I'm a student
high school student in Sullivan County
House Bill 271 seeks to repeal the fetal
Life protection act which restricts
abortion after 24 weeks this act is
repealed it will allow a woman to have
an abortion at any stage of her
pregnancy
at 24 weeks a human person is able to
survive outside the womb that our heart
has already been beating for 18 to 19
weeks by week seven of the baby's
development the brain begins to take
shape by week 10 of their life their
eyelids nostrils and mouth have already
begun to form
by week 15 the baby will be able to hear
these are just a handful of things that
a person in the womb can do
the thought of repealing the fetal Life
protection act act should be Unthinkable
the restrictions that are now in place
are not enough to protect a person in
the womb so to repeal them would only
infringe upon the right to life of an
unborn person even more
and 24 of the 50 states of our country
abortion is highly restricted and out of
those 24 States
half of them have outlawed abortion
completely there are only 10 states in
which abortion is completely
unrestricted or protected by the law
New Hampshire needs to defend the right
of unborn humans and the only way it can
start is by upholding the fetal like
protection act thank you thank you
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you sir uh Omer uh
Hearn and next is Laura
Ella Laura
thank you Mr chairman uh
I asked the committee to oppose
house bill 271--f-n
I reiterate my remarks from earlier this
morning
um I agree with the remarks of
Representative Sellers and this young
man right here again I urge the
committee to oppose House Bill
271- FN thank you and I yield the
remainder of my time thank you questions
to this Witness
saying none thank you sir
um Laura L Azam and next will be Phyllis
Woods
is
Laura
is Miss Miss at Miss El Aslam here
do not see her so I will call on Phyllis
Woods next
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
um I'm Phyllis woods from Dover
um I can recall being on that side of
the committee uh as a former member of
Judiciary and Judge Lynn testifying on
this side so this is bringing back a lot
of kind of memories for me
I also one of the memories that I'm
having is what uh confusion some of the
members might be having with the
testimony that you're hearing first
we're hearing that late term abortions
from six months on never happen but yet
we don't want to make them illegal
it may be the case that we are not doing
late-term abortions here now but if this
law that protects late-term abortions is
repealed I submit that we may have an
influx of people coming from other
states wanting to have late-term
abortions right now we have
unrestricted abortions up to six months
as you know this the repeal of this ban
would make unrestricted abortions right
up through the ninth month totally legal
which is out of the mainstream of what
the people in this state I believe want
43 States currently have restrictions on
abortions at six months or even earlier
so we would be quite the exception we
would be joining perhaps seven other
countries in the whole world including
North North Korea and China who have
absolutely no restrictions on abortion
as I look to the committee when you were
all here
um I could certain that you would
probably be quite evenly divided on this
issue but I would see suggest that
you will have common ground between you
and I think in three areas you will find
a lot of common ground number one
I believe that you and I and all the
members of the committee agree that
choice is important Pro being being
free to make our own decisions and our
own choices an American tradition
so we believe in choice
but I also believe that none of you
believe in unrestricted choice
you have to think about this our
responsibility as Citizens and voters
and your responsibility as lawmakers
is to have laws in place that restrict
choices that harm our ourselves our
neighbors and our culture we don't have
unrestricted Choice none of us would say
it's your free choice that
incest is a free choice or rape is a
free choice or murder or any other
things that we activities that we what
can I you're getting pushing up against
your time I wonder if I can ask you to
sort of sum up please okay
for okay first we have Choice the other
thing that I think we all have in common
as the is that we appreciate the
sanctity of life we do want uh and to
Value life if any of us saw somebody at
the side of the road uh that had been
hit by a car you would rush to help them
if you were on a suicide line you would
try to talk somebody out of committing
suicide if you saw somebody wanting to
jump off the bridge you would try to
protect that life the last thing that I
think we have in common is that we all
care about women
uh this law is not going to be something
if we have a late-term abortion that's
going to be in the best interest of
women no one wants to have a woman and
this is my final point no one wants to
have a woman give birth or to deliver a
dead baby that is not only not in the
best interest of the unborn child but
it's certainly not in the best interest
of women so I implore you please vote no
on House Bill 271 so that we have some
protections not only for The Unborn but
for the women and thank you for your
time thank you very much
is what questions for this Witness
thank you very much next I'm going to
call on
Marianne Cooper and after that will be
Sheila Marshall uh
Miss Cooper
thank you committee members um
I
my friend Phyllis Woods
worked so hard and I appreciate your
work that you do in on this Committee in
all of this I do rise in a position for
270 to 271 I would work very hard
um
during the
um decision making on um the fetal Life
protection act I I wrote to the governor
when I knew he was not really fired up
about it and I I wrote to the
representatives that worked so hard I I
I think we all know that if there are
defects in the fetal Life protection act
as it is today that will be worked on
you know but please
um do not
um vote in experience legislate on 271
FM and thank you for being here thank
you questions for this Witness
that's enough seeing none thank you very
much
um I just want to say I'm Sheila
Marshall yes the high school
that High School young man and that
gentleman there have expressed
everything that I would have said I am
against this bill so thank you very much
thank you any questions for this week
oh all right thank you so next I'm going
to call on Roy Dennehy and after Mr
Dennehy will be best
here I believe I've got that right Mr
netting
thank you for your time I'll just make a
quick uh Roy Dennehy I live in Windham
and I'm life director for the Knights of
Columbus
and I represent
um approximately 7 000 brother Knight
here in New Hampshire and I oppose
um House Bill 271 FN
and I
I will end by saying that this is a huge
human rights issue here in the human
rights of the unborn child and I've
heard a lot of terms here today but the
term of of the fetus is brought up many
times the fetus is a child it's a human
being and we need to keep this bill
intact
in order to protect The Unborn thank you
so much thank you president any
questions for Mr dennigan
seeing none thank you uh Beth scarer I I
hope I'm not it's mispronouncing that
scare scare I'm Sorry Miss scare and
next will be Karen Reed you're scared go
ahead hi thank you for taking my
testimony
um my name is Beth scare and I'm a
mother from Nashua I'm here to speak in
defense of New Hampshire's fetal Life
protection act which protects Healthy
Babies just a few weeks from being born
from being killed in an abortion
um and I'll in my testimony which is on
your desks I included a picture
of an abortion at 23 weeks
a week before the fetal Life protection
act kicks in
so you can see the gruesome you can see
the gruesome procedure here and as an
another person testified I included the
steps of an abortion a late-term
abortion which I won't repeat
and as you can see this is a gruesome
procedure who here on the committee or
who among any of those testifying in
support of repealing the fetal Life
protection act could stand to watch such
a bloody procedure
medical professionals reform these
abortions have to harden their hearts to
the inhumanity of what they are doing
many workers who've left the field
confessed that they became suicidal
after participating in these procedures
and despite
what some of the other people said it
cannot be used to save a pregnant mother
in the case of an urgent medical
condition because these abortions take
multiple days
to open up the cervix wide enough to
extract the fetus
and because of the size of the baby
these procedures are dangerous to the
mother's health and I'm grateful to Dr
Sherman for pointing that out in his
testimony
and and also
um he was very wrong when he said it
didn't allow for the help of the mother
it allows currently for serious risk of
substantial and irreversible impairment
of a major bodily function
so
a late-term abortion is just a very bit
serious risk for the mother and there's
we don't
we need to protect the mom and the baby
by keeping the fetal Life protection act
in place
and the reason that Planned Parenthood
and the other abortion businesses are so
determined to repeal it is because it
draws attention to the inhumanity of
abortion it's the same re it's the same
reason that Planned Parenthood fought
tooth and nail against the passage of
New Hampshire's fetal homicide law
because both the fetal homicide law and
the fetal Life protection act
demonstrates that the baby's human and
deserving of protection please vote in
expedient to legislate on HB 271 to
protect innocent babies from a gruesome
death and their mothers from physical
harm and the abortion workers from the
serious mental health repercussions of
participating in these inhumane
procedures thanks questions for this way
seeing none thank you very much
next is Karen Reed
and after that uh Ian Hewitt please
thank you Mr chairman and members of
this committee I'll keep this short uh
my name is Karen Reed I'm a
representative for Hillsborough District
27 Deering in Francis town but I am here
speaking on my own behalf today
um I oppose bill um House Bill 271
um because
in I as a nurse for 30 years
um 30 years ago I took an oath to do no
harm
that rule has not only guided my
professional practice but how I live my
life as well
I said I stand before you not to change
your mind or convince you that I am
right or to
um but but more to give you something to
think about tonight when you state when
you're alone with your own thoughts on
the way home
or when you really have to do us do some
soul searching
I've been present when life entered the
world with all its energetic Sparkle and
excitement and I've had the honor and
privilege as well to to be there um as
life left in its quiet release or in its
abrupt and tragic end
it is easy to take a life that you
cannot see and have no feelings for but
taking a life is a slippery slope
when when Society kills its children
what is the next logical step
the old and in in firm all you have to
do is look at our neighbors to the north
Canada
who now practices made medical
assistance in dying they're looking to
expand that to anyone who who seeks this
service young old or just down on their
luck
take a moment to Google Ezekiel Ram
Emmanuel Ram's brother Ezekiel was the
health advisor for President Obama and
he was a bioethicist who believed that
in the name of social justice that
anyone under 14 were over 50 wasn't
deserving of care that Health Care
rationing
um was something that was an option
take if you have a moment watch the
movie The Giver or read the book the
movie had Kurt Russell and Katie Holmes
it was a story of a world where only the
perfect
um got to live babies who were not
perfect or disposed of and everybody
looked lived in their similar perfect
commonness
um
look at so under that you know Insight
when you go home and look at your family
album your aunts your uncles your mother
your father your grandparents who is
deserving to live who
who would have been not made it if
abortion or
um Healthcare rationing does become a
reality
so I guess the my point being today is
to allow one
segment of the population to be aborted
it's opening up to you know to a society
that doesn't value life in general and
we run the potential of becoming a
country in a state that does not value
life and becomes more of a culture that
um you know accepts death as a normal
outcome
thank you very much thank you questions
to this Witness
no questions being none thank you
um next I'm going to call on Ian Hewitt
and after that will be dick
La Luna
um I hope I pronounced that correct
balloon sorry all right Mr you
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representatives for uh giving up your
lunch time to hear both sides of this
issue
Ian Hewitt appearing for Cornerstone in
opposition to House Bill
271. we appreciate that this bill is
honest and consistent in what it
represents but it will surprise no one
that Cornerstone opposes forthrightly
legalizing abortion weeks or hours
before birth for any or no reason I
wanted to make myself available to
answer any legal questions about our law
in New Hampshire which by the way had
full hearings in both houses of the
legislature as a standalone Bill and
received majority votes in both houses
as a standalone item before being signed
by the governor but I did want to First
bring two points to your attention I've
heard a number of things today that were
demonstrably false but I don't expect
I'll be able to answer all of them
unless you all have a lot of questions
first of all Massachusetts until
December of 2020 had a felony six-month
abortion prohibition which had no
exceptions for fatal fetal anomalies and
being a six-month abortion prohibition
like most late term abortion laws that
have ever existed in the country did not
have an exception for rape most
criticisms you'll hear of our law can be
resolved with that fact alone if our law
is Extreme for some undefined reason was
massachusetts's law extreme before 2021
if our law is going to cause Physicians
to flee from New Hampshire did that
happen in Massachusetts in 2020 of
course last year the legislature added a
fatal fetal anomalies exception to our
law which Massachusetts did not have
before December of 2020 and so our law
is now more moderate than a law that
existed in the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts less than three years ago
secondly as far as the views of the
people of New Hampshire on this issue
poll after poll at this point has shown
60 to 65 percent of people in New
Hampshire support some limits on
abortion including a majority of
unregistered and independent voters and
depending on the poll between a quarter
and a third of democratic voters in fact
polls show that the more information is
given to people being pulled on what our
law says the more supportive people are
of the law a March 2022 poll found that
when our law is accurately described as
quote a Prohibition at six months of
pregnancy with exceptions for the
mother's life and physical health it
does not have even majority opposition
among Democratic voters and 24 percent
of New Hampshire Democrats support are
strongly supported typically what you'll
hear people on the other side of this do
is they'll say that a majority of people
in New Hampshire think abortion should
be legal in quote unquote all or most
cases
but consistently when you look at those
polls whether it's Pew or American
values Atlas you will see that what
people have done is they have combined
the plurality that supports moderate
restrictions and nothing further with
the minority that supports unlimited
abortion up to birth papering over this
really unquantifiable moral Gulf sphere
you're kind of uh you're you're at your
time so if you want to ask you to sum up
if you would please well if you're
giving me an additional sentence Mr
chair I'll just say that when you hear
that statistic all or most bear in mind
that most people in that category are
more aligned with this law than with
those trying to repeal it I would be
happy to take any legal questions about
the law or abortion law generally if I
may Mr chair all right thank you uh
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you Mr Hewitt um next
I'm going to call on uh dick laloon and
then next after that we'll be
representative for tenza
good afternoon my name is uh dick
LeBlanc from Gary from Derry New
Hampshire first of all I want to point
out to everybody here with I'm here for
self I'm not here to point send you some
moms that might want they have an
abortion not report woman
that one not to have an abortion we're
not here to judge
but I am here my parents by the way had
13 kids you know and my aunt had 13 kids
so I guess you know where I stand on the
issue
I oppose hb2271
this seeks the elimination of the
recently passed fetal protection act
recently passed
by our respiring presidential hopeful
Governor it was signed by him a bill
that allowed abortion up to 24 weeks and
yet hit where we have some training not
only to eliminate and recall the 24 week
feed of protection act but to allow
abortion all the way up the bird
there were over 1 million abortions in
our country last year you know when
you're here tell me how these abortions
have anything to do with women's health
or being pregnant these days is
unhealthy and inconvenient to one's
lifestyle and why even when abortions
are reliable
up to 24 weeks then it is necessary to
try to repeal the 24
weeks the bottom line
is it because the bottom line
like organizations such as planned
parenthood profit much by every abortion
and they'll make much to political
entities that result in favorable
legislation that help Planned Parenthood
in other such organisms organizations to
Blossom financially
no I am not a radical Christian
conservative as you can see
I think I look normal don't I uh
no response
and yes I will always pray for my
opponents who have a change of heart
always help and support parents in need
they were organizations by the way like
real options in Manchester and Mantua uh
burnt right Gianna's House they helping
advise
pregnant woman
hopefully to advise them in the
direction of birth of their child
ah almost done as for me I will always
speak for the babies yet to be born
hopefully a voice for the voiceless a
voice for reason and love for The Unborn
babies I have one final question for you
to ponder if you believe in God that is
if you do what side do you think he's on
thank you and God bless you all
thank you thank you
two two minutes and 58 seconds that's
pretty good pretty good questions for
this Witness
thank you all right next I'm going to
call on representative Potenza please
and the next witness after that will be
Kathy Holmes representative Potenza
thank you chair
um my name is uh representative Kelly
Potenza I am in Stratford District 19
Rochester's Awards one through four and
six
I had a couple different things prepared
but I'm just going to actually speak
from my own personal experience in uh
speaking with
thousands of people actually in
Rochester during my campaign
I knocked on every door it didn't matter
whether they had an R by their name or a
d by their name and I told people the
truth
and I believe that this law that's
currently in place so that's why I
strongly oppose of course this repeal
um
is
is very minimal we're just like
Massachusetts uh it's still extremely
liberal one month two months three
months four months five month six month
for any reason whatsoever it's only in
the seventh eighth and my month and I
told people the truth
especially
um I'm a pro-life person and I told them
that I was pro-life but I spoke with
pro-choice people and I know I won their
vote because I told them the truth about
what the law was on the books
and there's been a lot of things here
that have that have gone on during the
campaign and it's just it was a lot of
heated rhetoric
and nobody ever told people the truth
about what the law was and some of the
people that I talked to that were
adamantly
pro-choice were like wow six months
and I turned I I turned their minds I
turned their hearts
and I think if we just
focus on that I don't understand why we
are
wanting to repeal something that is
truly common sense
also I guess throughout this this
hearing it has been repeated multiple
times that this um that this
Health exception is narrow
that's not the truth
right now the health exception that we
have is exactly the same as the parental
Health notification law that has been on
the books for 10 years
I repeat it has been on the books for 10
years
so it is not narrow in the regards with
the health exception it's exactly the
same as what we have now
that's pretty much my testimony I know
you guys have been hearing a lot so if
you have any questions thank you very
much questions for this Witness
you see none thank you
um Kathy Holmes and then uh Jason
Hennessy uh next
thank you I hope to keep this under two
minutes
uh what is the driving force that's
pushing later and later abortions
it's money it's always money
the left has successfully muzzled
project veracas which exposed the
industry of selling baby organs
the organs they get the most money for
are the late term ones in the video
Planned Parenthood lady was advising
crushed the head so that you don't
damage the organs they'll be more
valuable
but
the powers of the government which are
really people
uh they have
caved they've stifled the truth in the
video and even confiscated stuff from
his house now my question is how can the
left be against slavery but in favor of
selling baby parts
and if some of you could share my
thoughts with the absent ones when you
are debating then I'll appreciate that
thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you
um Jason Hennessy please
thank you Mr chair
uh my name is Jason Hennessey I'm the
president for New Hampshire right to
life which is the largest dedicated
pro-life organization in New Hampshire
and I there's been a lot of amazing
testimony uh just for the record we're
against HB 271 in case anybody who's
confused about that
um
I I just wanted to relate this to a
story that you probably heard in the
news that is probably disjoint in your
minds and that is the story of this uh
this this baby that was born in a in a
tent outside in December in Manchester
and uh what happened is that this baby
was born outside in the freezing
temperatures
um and and there's a a lot of heart
swell
um concern about this baby the First
Responders got involved they searched
for this baby uh after after some some
time some hours they found they found
him they brought him to the hospital and
thank God he was fine as far as I know
but I want to ask you the question if we
pass HP 271 and repeal the flpa
all that all that heartfelt protection
or desire to protect this baby that we
have in society
wouldn't have applied to him to just one
week before
so I want to ask you the question what's
the difference between this baby just
hours literally hours after he's born
and and one week before
so uh
you know we had so in this case there
were charges brought against people who
hindered the First Responders looking
for that child
and you know the the late term abortions
that are covered by the flpa which are
six months and Beyond
you know that baby is closer to to being
born than they were to being conceived
so repealing this would would legalize
abortion
through birth every Le every level of
human civilization that uh is applicable
here today
disagrees with repealing this if you
look at the statistics the the New
Hampshire Institute of politics poll
from August of last year said over 70
percent of New Hampshire agrees with
abortion restrictions at some point this
is the most moderate latest point you
could have it
if you look at the United States 43
States according to a pro-choice
research group gutmocker have have
protections at this place or earlier
so on so the vast majority of the states
and if you look at the world my last I
checked there were only seven countries
that don't pre that don't protect the
the pre-born children at this stage or
earlier amongst those are known are
those known for tragic human or other
human rights violations like China and
North Korea
so the uh one thing I wanted to address
the statistics that are there's not a
lot of Statistics but there are a couple
states that do keep statistics on the
reasons for late-term abortions
the the stats that we do have show that
the majority of them are actually
elective they wouldn't fall into rape
incest
um or health of the mother or fetal
anomaly kind of classification so if New
Hampshire is like the rest of the
country that's probably the case here as
well
the flpa protects not just a baby's life
it also protects the mother's life as
you heard uh late-term abortions are
very very risky and you can so you're
you're kind of getting over your time I
appreciate if you sum up please okay
thank you Mr chair I will say I will sum
up quickly
uh so nobody no mother in New Hampshire
is required to raise the child New
Hampshire has a safe haven law
uh and you're welcome to look into that
if if protection of life is the primary
purpose of government this fits with the
ethics of the vast majority of citizens
in the state in this country in this
world
I hope you will please follow your
conscience and vote uh and expedience
legislate on HP 271 thank you thank you
questions for this witness yes
representative Staples
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
was an interesting term you was the
choice of
the baby to be born
if we repeal this protection
do we not obliterate that initiative if
not choice at least
initiative in nature for the child to be
born
and
does that comport with
personhood
of being a person in the 14th Amendment
of the U.S Constitution
thank you representative uh I I am not a
lawyer but as a as an armchair reader
and and uh lover of the US Constitution
I I do believe that you can't take away
somebody's life without due process and
so
uh apart especially a viable child would
be recognized by the vast majority of
Americans as as a person in in deserving
of Rights
thank you
any other questions for this Witness
seeing none all right thank you very
much sir thank you Mr chair I have no
other pink cards and so let me ask is
there anyone else who desires to testify
on HB 271.
thank you
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 271
and I'm going to ask my vice chair
representative Wallace if he will take
over and introduce the hearing on the
next bill House Bill 88 I'm going to
take a short break thank you
okay we'll now openly
Committee hearing on House Bill 88 and
we call Representative Alexis Simpson
thank you Mr chair
good afternoon everyone my name is
representative Alexis Simpson I'm from
Rockingham District 33 representing the
people of Exeter Stratham New Market and
new fields I'm honored to introduce hb88
the access to abortion Care Act
since we introduced this bill last year
the Roe versus Wade Supreme Court
decision is no longer the law of the
land
since Roe v Wade was overturned I have
heard from my constituents and people
across the state that they are scared
they aren't sure if they are protected
here in New Hampshire
and if they will have access to the care
they need and even more so they're
scared of what the future looks like for
their children and grandchildren
it may seem that these fears are
overstated but most of my constituents
watch the national news
they've watched as state after State
across the country has banned abortion
early in pregnancy before people even
know they're pregnant and in some cases
banned abortion completely
in a time when people are uncertain
about so many things the cost of housing
electricity and child care to name a few
losing control over your body and the
ability to make decisions about the
security of your family's future is
scary
as a mother myself I understand those
fears
there's no decision more critical than
if when and how to start and grow a
family
I want to be really clear about what
this bill does and does not do
this bill does not change any current
abortion laws it does not change the
24-week ban at all it does not change
the parental notification law instead it
puts into state law that the state
cannot further restrict or interfere in
an individual's ability to access
abortion
currently there's a legal void regarding
the affirmative right to an abortion in
New Hampshire
there's nothing that grants Granite
Staters abortion rights there are only
restrictions and the restrictions are
clear
New Hampshire is one of three states
where abortion is legal but not
protected and New Hampshire is the only
state in New England without this
affirmative right
our neighboring states all have this
type of statutory language on their
books it may be worded slightly
differently but Maine's law for example
is almost identical to this bill's text
let me quote it
it is the public policy of the state
that the state not restrict a woman's
exercise of her private decision to
terminate a pregnancy
end quote
and then their specific ban on abortion
is listed there
similar to Maine's language in HB 88 the
access to abortion Care Act we have
included the current abortion laws
though we've used the rsas as reference
New Hampshire does not have explicit
State protections for abortion the
access to abortion Care Act adds Clarity
on where we the legislature stand and
what our intent is for abortion laws in
New Hampshire
indeed perhaps this bill wasn't needed
when there was a federal legal framework
for abortion rights but all that has
changed with the overturning of Roe
we have an obligation to our
constituents the overwhelming majority
of whom believe that decisions about
reproduction and abortion care belong to
pregnant people and the people who
provide them care
Granite Staters are looking to us
they're elected officials right now for
clarity and security
access to abortion care up to 24 weeks
is legal in New Hampshire and we should
reassure our constituents by securing
this in statute passing the access to
abortion Care Act will show the people
that we understand what is at stake and
that we trust them and their doctors
thank you
any questions representative Simpson
representative mcbeath
thank you thank you for taking my
question um representative Simpson
um so I just want to clarify so this
bill will do nothing it will not repeal
the
um 24-week ban that Governor sununu
signed into law two years ago is that
correct
thank you for the question
representative you are correct this does
not change the 24-week abortion ban in
statute
thank you
representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking our questions
uh in the uh in the bill lines 13 and 14
say an individual injured as a result of
a violation of this chapter shall have a
private right of action in Superior
Court against the state for injunctive
Relief arising from the violation would
this not then prohibit a doctor from
refusing to perform an abortion against
their conscience
thank you for the question
representative
I believe that under the enforcement
section of the bill you're pointing to
It lines 13 and 14. that this is
actually
um just against the state and actor of
the state not a private actor
which a doctor would be unless they were
employed by the state I would presume
representative Tripp
uh thank you for taking my question uh
during your presentation you made uh the
statement that uh uh in New Hampshire
it's abortion is legal but not protected
could you explain what you mean by that
yes thank you for the question
representative so right now abortion is
legal up to 24 weeks the 24-week ban
starts right then but there is no place
in the statute where it is
um a protected right
thank you
any further questions for representative
Simpson
thank you
uh we we now call Senator Perkins
Hawkeye
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee I am Senator Rebecca Perkins
quoka here to represent district 21
which is the city of Portsmouth and the
surrounding towns in support of HB 88.
in 2021 I was a first-term Senator and
one of two young moms in the chamber
as many of you may remember the same
term new abortion restrictions were
passed into law through our budget
I was just around 24 weeks pregnant when
we first debated this bill
I was experiencing firsthand how
frightening frightening it is to think
you won't be allowed a full range of
medical care that was available to you
when you started a journey
no future parent should ever again have
to worry that their rights will be taken
away
last year this same bill the access to
abortion Care Act was introduced to
guarantee the right to abortion before
24 weeks in New Hampshire
months later the Supreme Court leaked
the eventual dabs decision that
overturned Roe leaving folks across the
country vulnerable
it didn't take long for many to lose
their rights today around 20 million
people have lost access to abortion in
their home state including one in three
American women of reproductive age
in New Hampshire there is nothing giving
the affirmative right to an abortion
prior to 24 weeks in this chamber
nothing to prevent what is happening
across the country to reach our state
too
the overturning of Roe versus Wade means
that the entire legal framework for
Reproductive Rights no longer exists
New Hampshire is one of three states
where abortion is legal but not
protected as we just heard about with
new court cases starting to come out
including one that could affect a form
of abortion in every state including New
Hampshire
we need to fill the void on our books
for a state that Prides itself on local
control we must enact a New Hampshire
solution before one is imposed upon us
last session we tried to do just that we
garnered bipartisan support in this
chamber but ultimately fell one vote
short in the Senate
some of my colleagues said we needed to
wait for the Supreme Court to act before
we took action
for many a world without Roe seemed
impossible
for many more still the idea that
abortion could ever be illegal in New
Hampshire seemed impossible
I for one at this point am not willing
to wait and see any longer we must act
now to ensure the women of New Hampshire
are protected
this bill is not radical
it does not even change state law or
amend parental notification instead it
makes good on something that 71 of
Granite State or support access to
reproductive Health Care
it's also about respect
it's about respect for the women who
bear the important responsibility of
carrying our society's children and for
their right to personal physical
autonomy
we are women mothers and pregnant people
and when we are pregnant our ability to
be complex highly intelligent decision
makers doesn't change
I urge you to support a not to pass
recommendation on HP 88 and I'm happy to
take any questions thank you chair
any questions
see none thank you thank you very much
uh we now call Senator Whitley
and you've asked for 10 minutes from
maybe shave it down a bit
oh 10 minutes I don't need 10 minutes
pardon me
uh thank you Mr chair good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
my name is Becky Whitley and I'm honored
to represent Senate District 15 which
includes the communities of Beau Concord
Penacook and Hopkinton thank you very
much for welcoming me to your chamber
and I'm here to testify in support of HB
88. so I'm gonna talk a little bit about
the legal background about how we
arrived at the need for this bill so as
many folks know 50 years ago Roe v Wade
was decided by the U.S Supreme Court and
made abortion a constitutional right in
all 50 states the Supreme Court later
affirmed that decision in the Casey case
these rulings gave people the right to
access abortion legally in every state
although of course that didn't mean that
everyone had that the same amount of
access last year just last year the
Supreme Court overturned 50 years of
legal precedent when it decided the
Dobbs V Jackson Women's Health
Organization case the overturning of Roe
v Wade in the Dobbs case means that the
entire constitutional framework for
Reproductive Rights no longer exists it
was white clean no there's no longer a
federally constitutionally protected
right to access abortion in our country
that means that the legal landscape
across the country and in New Hampshire
without Roe v Wade is recklessly unclear
in the Dobbs case the Supreme Court left
the issue of Reproductive Rights
squarely with State legislatures and
with State politicians like me and you
well here we are it's our turn to act
and it's our turn to listen to the vast
majority of Grant Staters who support
the rights that we had under Roe v Wade
our constituents are watching us and
they're waiting for us to act
many states like Missouri have tried and
are continuing to try to restrict
patients from accessing abortion in
other states
the Texas abortion ban includes a bounty
hunter provision allowing essentially
any individual anywhere to seek a civil
lawsuit against anyone who obeyed who
AIDS and abats an abortion which is a
provision that has not been struck down
by the U.S Supreme Court
local municipalities across the country
are also attempting to pass local
ordinances including to restrict
medication abortion as seen in Minnesota
this bill before us hb88 would give New
Hampshire a legal lend to stand on not
if but when another state tries to reach
in
two years ago the New Hampshire
legislature passed a law Banning
abortion at 24 weeks with very very
limited exceptions as part of that law
which is now RSA 329.49 that law states
nothing in the subdivision shall be
construed as creating or recognizing a
right to abortion
that means that in New Hampshire we do
not have a law protecting access to
abortion before 20 weeks but the passage
of HB 88 would put this right explicitly
into state law just to be crystal clear
the bill before you does not amend the
24-week ban it does not amend parental
notification it simply addresses the
legal void in our state laws and
provides Clarity for nearly half of our
population
New Hampshire is one of three states
where abortion is technically legal but
not protected This legal gray area is
confusing and disconcerting to Granite
Staters as they look around the country
as millions and millions of women lose
access to their reproductive freedom
Granite theaters need these protections
and we need them now there is an urgency
and often a panic when I talk to my
constituents and my contemporaries what
is going to happen in New Hampshire do
New Hampshire politicians value freedom
will they step up to protect my right to
determine my own future
this bill would make it crystal clear to
Granite Staters and to a future New
Hampshire Supreme Court what the intent
of this legislature is we have a void on
the books an unresolved status there is
nothing in New Hampshire law that any
judge can point to which says the intent
of the new of New Hampshire law and the
legislature is that abortion is legal up
to 24 weeks the only Clarity in New
Hampshire law is the Restriction to
abortion
do we want to be a state that starts
with the presumption of the unknown
because that is where we are right now
as we speak 25 million people have lost
access to abortion in their home state
including one in three American women of
reproductive age this is staggering and
something I never thought I would see in
my lifetime
I'm scared and the women in my life are
scared
that we won't have the freedom to
determine our own Futures and the course
of Our Lives that we will net that that
the rights to bodily autonomy will be
taken away from us that we will be
forced to carry pregnancies against our
will it sounds dystopian because it is
thank you very much and I respectfully
ask for the committee's support of hb88
and I'm happy to take any questions
representative
thank you for taking my question uh the
previous speaker made the same statement
that you did that
uh in New Hampshire
the abortion is illegal but an honor
protected right
uh could you please explain to me how
House Bill 88 will make it a protected
right yeah thank you very much for that
question this is the confusing area
right the reason why we say it's legal
is because there are no current
restrictions the only restrictions on
abortion are at that 24-week period but
there is nothing in state law and in
fact existing law says it very clearly
there's nothing about the right to
access abortion up to 24 weeks it's our
law is silent
no follow-up
uh
I know that uh representative Gleason
active asked this question earlier but I
must not have been listening on lines uh
13 and 14. there's a statement that uh
an individual suffering an injury could
blah blah blah could you please explain
what kind of Entry is covered in this
yep so thank you for that question so
the bill is very simple pair uh lines 8
through 11 give the right so this is
very typical statutory construction that
part of the bill gives this right right
and the right is freedom from
governmental intrusion up to this
24-week point that's the right
government you can't interfere
and then the second portion you have a
right your right means nothing unless
it's enforced so it's not a penalty it's
an enforcement mechanism my right was
violated this gives me the legal
authority to um to enforce that right so
and it's very I just want to be very
clear and reiterate the fact that this
is only related to governmental action
this is not related to private action
this is governmental action which again
is typical statutory construction the
right is freedom from governmental
intrusion and this is how you exercise
that right
thank you very much thank you
representative Perez
thank you
not legal I'm not legal so I apologize
so again I'm going to do the legal so
you're saying right now
the law says
you
can have an abort it doesn't say you can
have an abortion up to 24 weeks it only
says when you can't have an abortion is
that correct
that's correct and then specifically in
in statute now as of two years ago the
law also States specifically and this is
a quote from RSA 329.49 nothing in this
subdivision shall be construed as
creating or recognizing a right to
abortion so it's very clear that we that
there is no right to be free from
governmental intrusion
when a woman seeks an abortion up to
that 24-week period have we had any
problems with it
access to abortion I mean I can't speak
to that and I'm surely the providers
will be able to seek that but certainly
around the country we have seen States
rushing in to create those restrictions
and I understand that but um have we had
have you heard of any women who have had
their right to have an abortion up to 21
stopped from having that happen I think
I'll have to defer that question to our
providers in the room but thank you for
that okay thanks
representative Beth
thank you um Sharon thank you for taking
my question Senator the just because
it's been um this the whole thing about
going to the superior court for
injunction so what somebody would do I I
don't know if you could explain what
what that is so if somebody's prevented
from could you explain the injunction
part what that does or yeah well it's
been a while since I've been in a
courtroom but right so um the
enforcement mechanism and you'll see
that online uh 13 and 14 is that if
someone believes that their right was
violated that the government intruded on
their rights as described in eight
through eleven they have the ability
they have the authority under the
statute to go and Superior your court
and file an action so that's what it is
and then the second part is this is very
typical language too if you have an
enforcement mechanism if you have a
right of action then you also have this
ability to
um get injunctive relief so that means
injunctive release means government stop
you're not allowed to intrude
thank you thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you uh we
now call Representative Nutter
up next we'll be representative Phillips
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
again members of the committee
I'm I'm stand in opposition to this bill
I made a promise to advocate for
innocent human life
and if we don't speak with them there is
no one to speak for them and that is all
I'm going to say on this Bill thank you
We Now call Representative Mary Hawkins
Phillips
next will be Danielle Pimentel
all right
hello uh representative Mary hacken
Phillips from Grafton County District 12
which is the towns of Hanover and lime
so I'm here as a co-sponsor of hb88 I'm
here to urge support for this bill and
I'm only here to speak about two issues
today although I feel very strongly
about a breath of them
the first issue
um is purely a professional many of my
constituents are these states best
leading OB gyns practitioners and
Healthcare professionals
uh I'm here to report that they're quite
anxious about the current state of our
law
they feel threatened in fact by the
24-week abortion ban the criminalization
that goes along with their
um practitioning and the requirement in
law to disregard the national standards
of care
in particular against their oath to do
no harm
denying abortion care is a very very
real harm that we're talking about
the the tool of abortion access that has
helped make it possible for many of
these leading abortion care providers
is actually being denied to their
patients and they find that very
difficult to digest
um
you know the ability to have that tool
in your pocket as a young professional
in trading for these medical professions
is what enables them to become women
leading their field and you know it's a
real kick in the seat to not be able to
protect your own patients in the same
way
I implore this committee to please
relieve these Professionals of their
fears
of being prosecuted
please pave a clear pathway for these
professionals to practice the best
peer-reviewed medical guidelines by
codifying this law this right to
abortion care up to that 24-week
deadline
during our current Workforce Workforce
crisis let's incentivize the best OB GYN
professionals and health care providers
to work in New Hampshire give them the
best allow them to give them the best
care to their patients as well
they can't be here today obviously
they're attending to our Granite
theater's needs so I'm here to relay
that message
as a member of House Finance I've been
briefed several times by the New
Hampshire Department of Business and
economic Affairs and specifically I'd
like to speak to commissioner Taylor
caswell's statement that of the five
strategic goals of the Bea number one is
to retain and recruit a modern Workforce
this bill would support Bea's Michigan
mission mission excuse me by supporting
New Hampshire's best OB gyns and
Healthcare professionals and practicing
the nation's best medicine
the second issue I'm here to speak about
is the financial and economic issue
in house finance I'm also briefed by
Brian Gottlieb the director of economic
New Hampshire's economic and labor
market information Bureau and the 23
outlook for New Hampshire's labor and
market economy
according to Brian
um the state's biggest challenge to
growth is the labor force shortage and
he estimates that we're about 8 500
workers short for pre-pandemic levels so
that 8 500 worked for shortage the
biggest group that he can point to for
the a drop who's not back yet to the
workforce are women between the ages of
25 and 34. among those women
that category of women these are the
most likely ages for women to be
reproducing
so we're talking about a huge piece of
the workforce shortage that you can
incentivize to return to the workplace
by giving them this tool
this abortion access will allow them and
Empower them to control their own family
planning explicitly explicitly through
this abortion access to choose how many
miles they'll feed how many seats at
their table they'll need to pull up how
many spots in child care they'll need to
secure
let's be frank
giving full determination of your
family's makeup is the financial
consideration this is a decision you
have to make every day
and if we want to reach full economic
growth as a state then we're going to
need to incentivize giving these this
specific group of women back into the
workforce
so as you know there's a lot of moral
ethical religious legal Arguments for
why this bill is needed but I want you
to remember that there are Financial and
Professional real implications to
supporting this bill especially if we
want to reach that full Workforce
potential here in our state
thank you
happy to answer any questions yeah
thank you questions for this witness yes
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um do you find that these
um uh professionals that you're working
with alongside are they looking for
other positions outside of the State of
New Hampshire
thank you for the question uh
representative I know that there are
folks here from um Healthcare
providers in our state who can speak to
that with more
um
direct factual examples but I can tell
you anecdotally
um having close personal relationships
with many of professional women
providers in our state that this is a
major issue on the Forefront of their
mind and it has not ebbed since the
moment that Roe fell this is something
that they are continually worried about
for not only themselves as working
Professionals of maternal age but a
maternal reproductive age but also as
mothers as wives as grandmothers
um so you know please don't discount
um these real real
tax paying and I would say highly tax
paying citizens in our state and their
needs
thank you other questions for this
women's
yes representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
if
the right to an abortion is not inherent
within currently inherent within the New
Hampshire Constitution
doesn't it really require a
constitutional amendment
we ruled on in the ballot initiative by
the people of New Hampshire rather than
just the legislature
and my best answer to that is that this
is not a constitutional request this is
a statutory request and as you know
there are plenty of federal laws that
are reduced to statute that support
fundamental rights across our country
that are not included in you know the
Bill of Rights for instance so
um you know
just off the top of my head I think
about workers rights you know OSHA
concerns I think about just
anti-discriminatory Clauses for
accommodations none of that is included
in our constitution but there are
federal rights that are protected under
federal law so in in statute
thank you
other question for this Witness
saying none thank you very much
um I guess next we have uh Danielle
emmentel and then next after that will
be representative sellers
foreign
Mr chairman the members of the committee
my name is Danielle Pimentel and I serve
as policy Council on Americans United
for life um thank you again for allowing
me to testify
um this is my third time hopefully third
time's the charm this legislation has
Grave implications similar to the
amendment that we heard earlier today
proposed um grave implications on future
health and safety protections for women
as well as conscious protections for
health care providers which is why I
urge you to oppose this bill
hb88 will prevent New Hampshire from
enacting abortion regulations that
purportedly interfere with an
individual's decision to have an
abortion as a result this bill severely
limits New Hampshire's ability to enact
health and safety protections for women
that are being alleged to interfere with
someone's right to have an abortion
for example as I stated earlier in my
earlier testimony New Hampshire does not
have an informed consent process for
women undergoing abortions an informed
consent safeguards provide women with
material information to guide them in
their abortion decisions which is vital
given that many women may be considering
abortion because they are being forced
either by a partner or family member or
sex trafficker so informed consent
safeguards provide women with material
information that let them know their
other resources available to them that
they are supported and give them other
options such as giving birth or giving
up their child up for for adoption
Etc however hb88 would prevent likely
prevents the state from passing these
kinds of safeguards further hb88 races
serious concerns for conscience rights
as representative greeson mentioned
earlier because the bill has no language
that would want uh that would probably
ensure the protection of Health Care
Providers conscience rights so health
care providers that have moral or
ethical objections to abortions
instead the uh hb88 would result in
positions being forced to perform
abortions regardless of these objections
and also prevent States from an act or
the state from enacting legislation that
would protect Health Care Providers
conscience rights in the abortion
context
instead of increasing abortion
protection as this bill reports to do
the focus should be on strengthening
informed consent laws and health and
safety protections for women especially
given that women are increasingly
rejecting abortion and choosing life the
current abortion rate is nearly half of
what it was in the 1980s after Roe B
Wade was decided and even prior to the
court deciding Roe v Wade women have
been steadily gaining access and
esteemed in the workforce and have been
continued to choose life and carry their
pregnancies to term and so for these
reasons I urge the committee strong
leaders to commit to oppose hb88 thank
you any questions I'm happy to answer
thank you questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you
representative Sellers and then next
will be uh the Reverend Heidi Heath
uh thank you Mr chair and thanks again
uh committee for hearing what I have to
say
um I'm just looking up here some I have
two things with this bill and I just
want to bring it up to you I'm probably
actually more but two things that's
coming to my eye
uh one is
to me this is again we come down to the
lawyers or the attorneys I'm saying the
attorneys are going to have a blast with
this they finally found somebody that
has Deep Pockets it's called the state
of New Hampshire
one misstep and they're going to get
millions of dollars from us just one so
I I you know for that one reason that's
one reason I'm opposed to this bill but
the other one is you know you look at
line ten and nine and ten
excuse me
and it says uh it basically shall not
restrict or interfere with an
individual's exercise to their private
decision to terminate a pregnancy
again the word interfere does that mean
if we create a bill or that becomes a
law eight ten years from now without
repealing this law we're indirectly
interfering
with that person to have a pregnancy
so that this is this is just an accident
waiting to happen if this actually
passes
the other part of this
and I guess it's the third part is
terminate
well that's why I was looking up my
phone again because I'm not an English
major but it does say terminate says
bring to an end bring to an end bring to
an end is another word bring to an end
to what they're talking about a
pregnancy that means you must be talking
about something that's living
all right it's it's not a thing it's not
a yeah it's not a fetus it's a leader
it's a living being a human being it's
also I want to say
um an infant now you think an infant is
just after birth it is not
you look up the word infant and Latin it
means infant i-n-f-a-n
which means speechless
a one that can't speak
that is a pre-born that's not born yet
all right so someone whoever's writing
this bill here I I it's to me I'm sorry
and I don't mean any disrespect but
plain English it's a joke this is just a
joke
but thank you questions for this week
saying none thank you sir thank you
Reverend Heidi Heath and after her will
be Liz Canada
honorable members of the committee thank
you for hearing my testimony this
afternoon
I am the Reverend Heidi Carrington Heath
and I come before you today in strong
support of the access to abortion Care
Act
I'm coming to speak with you today in
two capacities
I am an ordained Christian minister and
I have served in multiple Ministry roles
now for over a decade including as a
labor and delivery NICU and postpartum
chaplain
today I am also here representing a
coalition of interfaith clergy from
across New Hampshire
we are bringing to you a letter asking
for a vote of ought to pass on this bill
we represent more than half a dozen
religious traditions and hundreds of
Faith communities across the granite
state
access to abortion care is an essential
part of all of our religious beliefs and
all of our practices as is true for the
majority of the world's religious
traditions
this bill would enshrine into law
critical protections for women and
birthing people across the Granite State
Health Care is an essential human right
abortion is health care no more and no
less it is a fundamental Bedrock of
making sure that citizens of any state
can make appropriate Health Care
decisions in conjunction with their
medical providers their clergy their
therapists and other trusted supports
free from shame
interference
government pressure or more
as a practicing Christian I am pro-faith
I am pro-family and I support abortion
access I do so not in spite of my faith
but because of it
my faith compels me to stand with those
who seek safe and legal access to this
care
abortion is Health Care
abortion can be life-saving
what could be more faithful than that I
honor the sometimes complex and
compassionate choices that pregnant
people seek to make
moreover I am the Deep supporter of the
principles of religious freedom upon
which our country was founded each of us
is guaranteed the right to make our own
choices according to our own religious
beliefs and not to be required to
conduct our health care by the
principles of someone else's ethics
my Christian faith encourages me to look
out for those who may be left behind by
those in power
so I come before you today in support of
the access to abortion Care Act for
these reasons and many more I urge you
to vote ought to pass on HB 88 and abide
by the values of freedom and choice that
New Hampshire has claimed as our own for
centuries people of faith and people
across the granite state are counting on
your leadership thank you for hearing my
testimony today thank you questions for
this Witness
yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony are you aware of any
other medical procedures to which anyone
has a statutory or constitutional right
to access
I would offer that there are many
medical procedures to which folks have a
constitutional right and statutory
requirement is not the word I use both
statutory right to access but I'm not a
lawyer and I'm not a medical
professional so I can't speak to the
details of the law
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Staples
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question you mentioned that
you represent a number of interfaith
organizations
um
is the Catholic church or any of its
parishes aligned with that particular
organization signed on to the letter
that I mentioned
sir and we will provide you with a
written copy of that letter
electronically so you have access to all
of our information
um
my hearing is not good and I'm having
trouble with the reverberation did you
say that there were or were not some
Catholic churches that were aligned with
what you've just spoken about the letter
that I that I'm about today which I
assume is what you're asking
thank you sure
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
um Liz Canada and next will be uh Court
Courtney uh read I think
yes Miss Canada good afternoon hello
again
um my name is Liz Canada I'm the
advocacy manager at Planned Parenthood
of Northern New England and Planned
Parenthood New Hampshire action fund and
we're here in strong support of house
bill 88. as you've already heard New
Hampshire does not have anything in
state law protecting or recognizing a
right to abortion we are the only state
in New England without anything in state
law I heard mention earlier of
Massachusetts for example they have
statutory protections for abortion in
Massachusetts
Vermont has statutory protections as
well and they recently passed the
Constitutional Amendment so now they
have both statutory and constitutional
Protections in Vermont
across the country there are only three
states where abortion is legal but not
protected and New Hampshire is one of
them
foreign
this bill before you would put into
state law the recognition
this bill does not amend the 24-week
abortion ban it does not amend parental
notification it simply addresses the
void in our state laws which is
particularly critical now that Roe v
Wade has been overturned and there is no
longer a federally constitutionally
protected right to abortion passage of
this law would provide legal clarity
as you've already heard since Roe v Wade
was overturned over 25 million people
across the country have lost access to
abortion in their home state including
one in three women of reproductive age
abortion bans have created a domino
effect in our country patients have had
to travel out of their own state but
only if they can find child care if they
can take time off of work and if they
can afford it and then they have to
travel farther as bans take effect they
have to travel later in their
pregnancies
and they travel to States like here in
Northern New England because they see
this area of the country as safe for
them
so this bill in front of you is an
opportunity to show granted Staters that
abortion will remain safe and legal
until 24 weeks in our home state
this bill again doesn't change any of
the current laws they remain intact this
only changes the fact that we do not
have a statute recognizing the right to
an abortion
we know that the majority of people in
New Hampshire support the right to
access abortion free of government
interference we also know that no one in
New Hampshire wants the government of
another state to interfere with what
happens here in New Hampshire
other states are attempting to pass laws
that would reach beyond their own
borders and into New Hampshire
again we're only one of three states
that has an abortion ban but no
protections on the books you can change
that House Bill 88 is a win-win
it provides critical assurances that our
state will not alter course now that Roe
v Wade is gone
but instead will enshrine into state law
that we value and support an
individual's personal and private
decision making in accessing the health
care that they need and we urge you to
vote off to pass on House Bill 88.
questions for this Witness
representative Perez
thank you I have a question for you I do
again I'm not legal so I apologize by
doing this
if the state decided
let me back up a little it's my
understanding that when
um abortion was made legal it was
initially the first trimester I believe
correct me if I'm wrong and then I
believe it was in the 1990s that it was
changed to a quote of viable fetus
um which at that time was approximately
24 weeks and that's where the 24 weeks
has come from again correct me if I'm
wrong
if we do this with this bill
does that mean if
things change dramatically and say a
viable fetus is at
15 weeks and the people
okay because I believe in the people
wanted to change the present
statute they would not be able to change
it
thank you for that question so two
pieces that I want to address and what
you said so 24 weeks is not the same of
as the viability standard that we have
seen so it's a fixed Mark in the
calendar 24 weeks is that hard firm line
now the question about can a future
legislature what I think is what you're
asking can a future legislature amend it
that's true for any Bill any bill can be
changed in the future as you know A
legislature dictates what we know in
every state in the country even where
abortion is outright banned it is
unpopular to have abortion bans in those
States and so a future legislature would
have to come to terms with how the
people of the Granite State of New
Hampshire would want them to change any
abortion ban so
that that is the that is the uh response
for sure
yes
so
again not legal you're kind of black and
white would this prohibit in any way
the state changing the present law or
any part of the present law at any time
it's a yes or no please
the legislature can do can pass laws and
amend laws as they wish we do know that
states like Missouri are trying to pass
laws that would reach into other states
like New Hampshire and try to affect
patients here and providers here and so
this type of legal Clarity would be
really helpful in that type of
circumstance
representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question in the same vein of the
prior question
but with a little variance
the bill does provide exception
under RSA 329 colon 43 to 329 colon 50.
an RSA 132 32-36.
if the law were to change
by addition of additional rsas in a
restrictive sense
does that not represent a problem for
this bill in a conflict of law
and therefore this really should be a
constitutional issue rather than a
statutory one
thank you for the question so to that
last point the good news is you have a
constitutional amendment to vote on
cacr-2 which we also support the
Constitutional Amendment would go to the
voters in November of 2024 this would
take effect immediately so that would be
you know a major value for granite
saters to know that that has been in uh
in effect affected immediately but both
things are really important to have in
place like we see in Vermont both
statutory protections and constitutional
like other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you thank you um
Courtney Courtney Reed I'm sorry
Courtney Reed and then next uh will be
uh representative uh Megan Murray
thank you chairman sorry I don't have
the best handwriting okay no problem
neither do I yeah thank you I'll try to
keep my my testimony uh short as we've
already heard some pretty robust
statements from supporters of hb88 my
name is Courtney Reed and I'm here with
the ACLU of New Hampshire and I just
want to reiterate that last last month
we should have been celebrating what
would have been the 50th anniversary of
Roe v Wade and unfortunately we're in a
cloud of legal uncertainty about what
Reproductive Rights are protected
especially in the state of New Hampshire
where we don't have a constitutional
protection for the right of abortion and
we don't have anything in statute that
protects protects reproductive freedoms
either
and just to kind of put this in a
context of the national scale we've seen
66 clinics across 15 states stop
offering reproductive care 12 states
have banned abortion outright since Rose
overturned and as many as one in three
women of reproductive age have lost
access to abortion in their home state
and we've seen a lot of these attacks on
reproductive Liberties take place
through incrementalism in Texas for
example a 24-week abortion ban was
issued in 2005. since then in 2013 the
state issued a 20-week ban with few
exceptions in 2017 the state placed
burdensome and targeted restrictions on
reproductive Health Centers and in 2019
the state issued more restrictive
policies in 2021 the state finally
issued a six-week near total ban on
abortion
so where the granite state is now is
where Texas was in 2005. we currently
have a 24-week abortion ban with limited
restrictions that was passed two years
ago and there will always be politicians
eager to chip away at abortion access
like we've seen in Texas
yet by passing a legislation like HB 88
we would act in favor of what we already
know where Granite Staters who have been
pulled show overwhelming support for
abortion protections and every ballot
initiative even in deeply red States
this past November strongly went in
support toward protecting abortion
rights so Granite Staters right now are
concerned and worried about their
continued access to abortion which
according to the American Medical
Association and other medical
communities is an essential part of
reproductive Health Care
so it's time to make explicit that
abortion is protected and by this uh
while we would be affirming that there
could be no more uh incremental attacks
on abortion as it stands through Statute
in this this legislation is an
affirmative protection of abortion that
doesn't change uh anything under state
law
uh where we are now so
um I'd like to urge the committee to
pass hb88 thank you
questions for this Witness
yes representative breesa thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking our
questions since you represent the ACLU
perhaps you will have a little bit more
information are you aware of any medical
procedures to which anyone has a
statutory or constitutional right to
access
and thank you for your question
um I would also like to leave uh the
answer to that to Medical experts
um that might be more familiar with it
but I I can say I'm fairly certain that
there are not any medical procedures
that have restricted access to them in
the ways that abortion does
any other question
one question that I have is you you say
that this would offer
some protection
from from politicians basically change
but is it if this is just a statute
isn't it this only offers protection
until until unless and until the statute
is changed and a future legislature
would have the ability to change it at
will would it not
yeah that's correct representative uh
thank you for your question uh I I just
want to speak a little bit more to that
in that um uh by by passing this bill we
would be honoring what
um an overwhelming number of um Granite
Staters have supported through polling
um which is a protected
um access to abortion and other
reproductive Health Care the ACLU has
also testified in support of the
Constitutional Amendment which
um
protects that right to a greater extent
um but like we've seen in States like
Massachusetts
there are a multitude of ways to make
sure that Reproductive Rights are
protected and through statute is just
one of them thank you thank you other
questions
yes representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
on your very nice handout here with a
lot of facts and figures
on the back page you have one particular
item protecting abortion access is part
of the battle for racial
equality can you explain
how that is uh even though we know that
the black population is uh a large
proportion a larger proportion of
abortions elective abortions than in
other racial segments
yeah thank you for your question
um
one thing that comes to mind with that
is that there's been some research that
demonstrates
um disparities in maternal mortality
rates should abortion be restricted
Nationwide for example I believe 21
or 24 will be the increase in maternal
mortality rates in general but when we
look at the increase of maternal
mortality rates among black women after
abortion access is Stripped Away that
balances up to 33 percent in general
there are racial disparities in maternal
mortality and health risks when it comes
to carrying out a pregnancy
and there's also a lot of research that
shows
it's more difficult to escape poverty
which is something that's racialized and
um I'd like to to give you some more
information that can speak to to that
bullet um if you'd like to communicate
um further about that
thank you other questions to this
Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you next I'm going to call
Representative Megan Murray and the next
witness after that will be uh Josie
Pinto
colleagues for the record my name is
Megan Murray
I come before you in support of House
Bill 88 as a co-sponsor woman and mother
who represents the towns of Amherst and
Milford
for the first time in my lifetime last
year a federally and constitutionally
enshrined right was taken from me and
many others Across the Nation
so many worked for decades to make sure
that Equitable access to Safe Care
existed as women work to gain equal
rights on so many fronts including
access to abortion care
this is not a partisan issue so many
Granite Staters support the position of
protecting access to abortion care and
have doggedly work towards that for many
generations
you know what could you just get a
little closer to the microphone thank
you thanks regulatively the fall of row
via the Jackson V dabs case has set up a
patchwork of state-by-state policy
positions that vary widely leaving
equity and access to abortion care in
the balance it is now up to us
the state of New Hampshire to make the
make the promise we must that access to
abortion care is a right
the bill would provide legal strengths
to the right to an abortion it changes
none of the statues already set forth in
law
and HB 88 is at a minimum the least we
can do to provide Assurance to those
seeking abortion care here in New
Hampshire my constituents want high
quality OB GYN doctors and services
leave an abortion care unprotected here
means that providers may leave and
practice elsewhere
it could leave a void in reproductive
health care options if we do not send a
clear message that abortion care is
protected in law and stated in the
statute hb88 ensures that access to
abortion care is so vitally important
and remains a private decision that
families with their medical providers
make together
the reasons for an abortion and an
individual's medical and personal
circumstances are many and unique
no two circumstances are the same
we as a community must ensure that we
are not creating environments where
practitioners are hesitant to provide
critical care and that from an equity
standpoint we are allowing the most
vulnerable populations to access their
care safely affordably and privately
with the protection of the law firmly
alongside of them they are taught to
pass on hb88 thank you questions for
this week
yes I guess I just have one question I
want to I mean could you
it's a little unclear to me candidly the
purpose of this bill so I guess what I'm
wondering is could you
let's assume that
we the the fetal Life protection act as
it exists right now remains in effect
because as I understand that this bill
doesn't purport to change to change that
so could you give
us an example
of of what you're in other words if the
fetal Life protection act remains in
effect and is not to be changed by this
can you give us an example of what would
what would change If This Were enacted
or not enacted what what are you what's
the risk that you're worried about
if you have this bill or don't have this
bill uh thank you representative for the
question my concern is that we do not
have anything currently in state statute
like hb88 that sends the message that
acts access to reproductive care is a
state right clearly and defined as
defined in the statute
okay all right other questions for this
Wednesday
thank you very much thank you um Josie
pinto and then next will be Michelle
silly foisy
all right hello again legislators
um my name is Josie Pinto I'm here as a
lobbyist and the executive director of
the reproductive Freedom fund of New
Hampshire and I'm here to express my
strong support for HB 88 relative to
access to abortion care
as our organization deals with the
Fallout of half of our country Banning
abortion there has never been a more
important time for us to proactively
protect the right to abortion here in
New Hampshire and prevent our rights
from being chipped away at over time
despite personal opinions on the topic
abortion is an incredibly safe medical
procedure
the residents of our state deserve to
know that despite what the Supreme Court
has decided or what other states decide
in these coming months and years they
will be guaranteed access to abortion up
until the 24-week ban that has already
been put in place
to be clear as we've discussed HB 88
wouldn't change anything about the
existing law that is currently on the
books but it would solidify it giving
Granite Staters a clear answer to where
our laws stand and easing our fears that
we will not see a 24-week ban turn into
a 20-week ban then a 15-week ban and so
on
if we as Granite seders truly believe in
bodily autonomy medical privacy and the
rights of all Granite Staters to pursue
Liberty we must codify the rights of all
into law so that we can then begin the
true work of ensuring equal access and
true reproductive and maternal Justice
I urge you all to vote in favor with the
majority of granite Staters saying that
they want the right to abortion to be
affirmed and protected here in New
Hampshire I urge you all to support this
Bill thank you
questions for this Witness
ing none thank you very much
Michelle silly foisy and next will be
Omer
thank you
good afternoon Mr chair and house
committee my name is Michelle silly
foisey and I live in Temple as I said
earlier today I am here today in support
of HB 88 the access to abortion act Care
Act Care Act
a year ago I told my daughter Kayla's
story our abortion story for the first
time in public In This Very Room in
support of HB 1609 to add a fatal fetal
diagnosis exception to our state's
abortion ban I spoke of being a mother
of seven children including my daughter
Kayla who I lost 18 years ago due to a
fatal fetal anomaly our abortion was at
22 weeks
December 10 2005 Kayla was delivered
stillborn after our termination the day
before
as we held her in our arms for several
hours we said goodbye to the little girl
that we continue to love with all of our
hearts
Kayla was found to have a deletion in
her 15th chromosome that was not
detected until after our abortion
our amniocentesis results returned a
month after our termination when I would
have been 26 weeks pregnant this
timeline is the reason that I began to
tell our story in support of the Fatal
fetal anomaly Amendment added to the
abortion ban instituted last year
it is clear that in these incredible
complex situations decisions should be
left to a pregnant person and their
doctor
I am here today to urge you to protect
the right to an abortion before 21 24
weeks in state law
since Roe v Wade was overturned last
summer our country's reproductive Health
Care landscape has been in disarray one
in three American women have lost the
right to abortion in their home state
while abortion remains safe and legal in
New Hampshire before 24 weeks we are the
only state in New England without a
proactive protection for our abortion
rights Granite Staters are now
susceptible to out-of-state attacks and
on their health care
in New Hampshire we don't let other
states dictate our rights
I did not make the decision to have an
abortion with ease nor uninformed though
we had only hours to make our decision
those hours were filled with gathering
information and asking many questions in
the days that followed I continued to
ask questions along the way and together
with my Physicians we made the best
decision for our family not once did I
look to my state legislators for advice
opinions or medical knowledge I trusted
in my Physicians expertise and the
information that we had
New Hampshire residents are capable of
making thoughtful decisions about their
own health care and consultation with
their loved ones faith and medical
providers as they see fit New
Hampshire's elected officials should not
turn their backs on our state's
tradition of trusting the people of New
Hampshire to make these decisions in the
face of national uncertainty you have
the ability to take proactive action to
ensure abortion remains safe and legal
in New Hampshire before 24 weeks
I urge you to support hb88 thank you for
your time thank you questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much uh next
uh Omer Hearn and then next will be Bob
Dunn thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee
I urge the committee to oppose house
bill 88.
quite simply I believe House Bill 88
will put chilling effects on what little
the state of New Hampshire can do to
protect human life
it must not become law in New Hampshire
because we're we want to protect human
life
and also New Hampshire it's part of a
republic that is based upon judeo
principles judeo-christian principles
and one of those principles in the Bible
is beware of false prophets oppose House
Bill 88 thank you thank you uh questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you sir thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh Bob Dunn and next
will be Sandra
then encore
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee once again I'm Bob Dunn the
director of public policy for the Roman
Catholic Diocese of Manchester and on
behalf of Bishop Peter labashi I'm here
today to respectfully oppose
hb88 I won't repeat everything I said
this morning and I've provided written
testimony here today uh that explains
why we oppose the policy and I think
also today both in your questions and in
the answers it's become abundantly clear
of what the sort of procedural issue
with this is that this is
what I would respectfully say is an HB
that wants to be a cacr
um and so with that I would urge you to
vote this down thank you
questions for this week
I I take it Mr dry I think am I
corrected what are you what you sort of
mean by what you just said is that if we
pass this bill it's good only until
somebody decides to some Legends until
some legislature in the future decides
to change the law exactly it's it's
trying to sort of enshrine policy into
perpetuity but it can't do that because
the legislature is always free to do it
so if the legislature decided to do
something in the future which is what
the folks who sponsored this are trying
to prevent from happening it would have
no impact because the legislature would
simply repeal this and replace it with
the new legislation
thank you other questions for the switch
seeing none thank you sir Sandra de
Encore and next will be uh
at Glo gloa
hi good afternoon good afternoon Mr
chairman and committee members thank you
for the opportunity to provide both
written and oral testimony I just ask
you to get a little closer yeah yeah
thank you you're welcome thank you for
the opportunity to provide both written
and oral testimony today in support of
house bill 88. I'm Sandra did Oncor I'm
the executive director of the Joan G
Love Ring Health Center in Greenland the
lovering health center is an independent
non-profit Health Center that's been
serving New Hampshire citizens for over
42 years we provide abortion care in
addition to accessible contraception
care sexually transmitted infection
testing treatment and prevention and
preventative health screenings all of
which are Central to our mission
the lovering health center is only one
is one of only two independent
non-profit reproductive and Sexual
Health Centers providing abortion care
in New Hampshire the second is equality
health center right here in Concord
after Roe v Wade was decided 50 years
ago New Hampshire citizens were afforded
affirmative legal protection that
allowed Advocates medical providers and
Health Care Centers like ours to develop
a safe effective accessible
patient-centered and evidence-based
system of abortion care that has
compassionately and professionally
served your constituents for over 45
years as they make important personal
medical decisions
I wanted to focus my testimony today on
two considerations the first is that RSA
329 sections 43-50 explicitly do not
protect the right to abortion as you've
already heard RSA 329 section 49 makes
that clear in its very specific one
sentence text nothing in this
subdivision shall be construed as
creating or recognizing a right to
abortion
I believe it's inaccurate and misleading
for any person lawmaker or politician to
say or imply that abortion before 24
weeks gestation is protected in New
Hampshire it is not with the lack of
federal protections as of June 2022 the
time to provide protection is now
it is not inappropriate in our opinion
to do this now as a House Bill while
considering the possibility of a
constitutional amendment in the future
the second consideration is about the
precedent that sets that is set by RSA
329 sections 43-50 if lawmakers have
determined that access to this medical
procedure an access to an abortion is
important enough to legislate with
restrictions then it must be important
enough to recognize with legislative
protection
I've heard lawmakers and other folks in
this state insist that there is no
intention to restrict abortion further
in New Hampshire intentions and
reassurances are not the legal
protection that your constituents need
and deserve
the access to abortion Care Act upholds
New Hampshire values by putting into law
that the state cannot further interfere
in the right to access abortion House
Bill 88 also provides an enforcement
remedy if that freedom is violated this
levels the legislative landscape by
making it clear that New Hampshire
protects abortion access up to 24 weeks
the June 2022 U.S Supreme Court Dobbs
decision makes it critical that New
Hampshire actively protects the right of
to abortion for all citizens millions of
Americans are already impacted by
increased restrictions or bans since
this decision and there are bills
proposed annually in New Hampshire that
seek to further restrict abortion access
and bills that seek additional
interference in this private medical
decision being made by your constituents
and their health care providers we ask
you to vote ought to pass on House Bill
88. thank you thank you questions to
this Witness
today none thank you
at gloa and then next would be the
Reverend Allison uh
Pat gloa
this
this ah okay here we go thank you
my apologies for the delay no no problem
my papers want to go Walkabout today
so I had to retrieve them I hope that I
have a stack of copies of this testimony
to leave with
um yourselves I just have to find it
they want to hide on me
my name is Dr Patricia gloa
I'm a board certified family physician
I've been in practice in New Hampshire
since 1980.
and I've been affiliated with
Dartmouth-Hitchcock Medical Center in
Lebanon since 1995. I started out
practice in the North country in the
Woodsville area
I have practiced full-scope Family
Medicine including 30 years of
delivering babies
which was one of the high points of my
life
I have also been an abortion provider
for about 40 years which has also been a
high point in my life feeling as I do
that I'm saving women's lives by doing
so
I have worked with women in all aspects
of their experience of pregnancy
I also work in the areas of sexual
violence child sexual abuse and domestic
violence
I'm here to speak in support of HB 88
relative to Reproductive Rights this
bill is very important to protect the
rights of New Hampshire's women
any pregnancy is a major life event with
lifelong consequences for the person
involved
pregnant people understand that carrying
a child will also carry obligations for
many many years to come
it's not just about getting to the point
of birth it's about all of the mothering
that's involved afterwards
in addition they understand that the
circumstances of pregnancy may result in
them being unable to mother a child in a
safe and loving manner
the person may have serious health
concerns
they may have a very unstable economic
and or social situation
they may be involved in substance abuse
or misuse which could jeopardize a
child's health during and after a
pregnancy
they may not have a supportive partner
indeed they may be in an abusive
relationship
which jeopardizes the child as well as
the woman
they may have been raped or subjected to
incest
they may be a student or a member of the
military working to improve their life
circumstances such that they could
securely and happily support a child in
the future
they may already have the number of
children who they feel that they can
support emotionally physically and
financially
they may have children with special
Health needs that make it impossible for
them to take on the responsibility of
another child
they may have be unhoused
or even incarcerated
they may have experienced a failure of
their contraceptive method
there are as many circumstances as there
are pregnancies
pregnant people need to be trusted to
make the best decision for their lives
and the lives of their families without
interference or mandates from
legislation
people want to be good mothers
at the right time and in the right
circumstances
I thank you for your time and
consideration of this critical measure
designed to safeguard the rights
appropriate to our citizens
thank you questions for this Witness
saying none thank you mayor
um Reverend Allison Tom and next will be
Jake Berry
thank you so much for hearing my
testimony
my name is Reverend Allison palm and I
am a Unitarian Universalist Minister
serving the Unitarian Universalist
Church of Nashua as well as a resident
of Nashua I'm here to speak in support
of HB 88 the access to abortion Care Act
as a Unitarian Universalist Minister I
firmly believe in the inherent worth and
dignity of every person and that each
individual has a right to make decisions
about their own body and their own life
this belief extends to the issue of
abortion access
people who seek abortions as you've
already heard today are often faced with
difficult and complex situations
including Financial hardships health
concerns or unwanted pregnancies
resulting from sexual assault or a
coercion
no matter what the situation all
pregnant people deserve access to Safe
Medical Care without fear of shame or
reprisal my faith tells me that
everybody is sacred including and
especially those bodies that can carry
pregnancies and every person has a right
to Holy agency over their bodies
we are in a crisis moment when it comes
to abortion access in this country since
Roe versus Wade was overturned in June
abortion access has been chaotic and
confusing in this post-row world Granite
Staters deserve a law on the books that
affirms their right to access abortion
care and prohibits the state from
further interfering with that right
my faith compels me to support bodily
autonomy and freedom of conscience and
access to safe and legal abortion is
essential to upholding those values
as a faith leader who cares deeply about
the well-being of the people of New
Hampshire I urge you to support House
Bill 88 the access to abortion Care Act
and protect these sacred rights here in
our state thank you questions to this
Witness
saying none thank you uh Jake Barry and
next will be
F Emma
says Susanna
okay
good afternoon Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is Jake
Berry I'm the vice president of policy
at new Futures as many of you know new
Futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
Health policy and advocacy organization
I don't want to repeat too much of
what's been said here this afternoon but
I do want to emphasize new future strong
support for this bill HB 88 as well as
HP 224 which you'll hear later today
simply put reproductive care including
abortion is a critical component of
overall health care access to abortion
directly impacts the current health and
future well-being of our women Children
and Families we believe it needs to be
protected in statute
uh data shows that women who give birth
are after being unable to access
abortion report more life-threatening
complications like eclampsia and
postpartum Hemorrhage they report more
chronic conditions like headaches or
migraines joint pain and gestational
hypertension
women who are denied an abortion are
less likely to have the money they need
to cover basic living expenses like food
housing and transportation then children
who are born as a result of inability to
access abortion are more likely to live
below the federal public poverty level
uh poverty and other adverse childhood
experiences are known to negatively
impact brain development and can follow
children throughout their lifetimes
in some in summary abortion is a needed
part of Health Care no doctor or medical
professional should be fined or
penalized for providing these procedures
in women and families across our state
should be able to rest assured that we
are not looking to further restrict
access to abortion in the years to come
for these reasons we ask that you
support HP 88 and as well as HP 224 and
both them both ought to pass and with
that I'm happy to take questions thank
you questions from this Witness
actually none thank you thank you uh
Emma I hope
Emma I'm sorry Emily jejano and then
next will be uh
uh Ovid uh
Young
yes
good afternoon Sherman Lynn and
honorable committee members
my name is Emily zagrano and I ask you
to support hb88
I am a pediatric emergency medicine
physician my adult life has been
dedicated to saving children's lives but
I could not save my own daughters
I had two abortions
my stories of my love and my heartbreak
but the value is in my body and my
choices
this was my first pregnancy and very
much wanted by my husband and I we were
shocked and thrilled when our first scan
at 12 weeks showed two babies
however the ultrasound also showed I had
a uterine anomaly a potentially
life-threatening condition
the Twins were in two different areas of
my uterus
more studies suggested I was safe and we
would have our baby girls we chose names
I marked the date on my calendar when
they would be 29 weeks and very likely
to survive
at 16 weeks and four days pregnant I
woke up with pain that became sharp
severe it hurt to breathe
I was ultimately sent to a Boston
hospital my husband and I sat in a dark
room where monitors show the ultrasound
images turned on during happy scans
turned turned off during the sad ones
they were off for ours
the news was worse than we could imagine
the left side was a previously
unrecognized rudimentary horn and the
uterine wall had ruptured in two places
this fetus had no chance
my room was literally broken
on the right side the baby had a
congenital heart defect which would
require surgery and functioning lungs to
survive if she could make it to
viability in my broken womb
these findings changed everything
to save my life I needed surgery and one
of my daughters inside needed to be
removed
in surgery they saved the unicornate
uterus and the fetus on the right was
still there
but it was clear that allowing the
pregnancy to continue would put me at a
huge risk
for two weeks I sat on the couch tried
to heal from surgery and loved my baby
as hard as I could I grieved
we went to Boston for the appointment
the next day or the day before the DNC
the abortion we were there for medical
care
we were there to save my life
we were there because this was the most
appropriate decision for our family
we were there because we needed to be
there
my abortion saved my life my abortions
allowed me to have more children
my abortions allowed me to continue my
work to save your children's lives
I appreciate that the legislature acted
last year to add a fatal fetal diagnosis
exception to the New Hampshire abortion
ban
however we also need to protect access
to safe and legal abortion in New
Hampshire state law
as a doctor and as a patient I
understand just how different every
pregnancy is
Uranus theaters and their medical
providers need all options available to
them
please pass HB 88 and protect access to
safe and legal abortion
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you man
um I
opened uh young please
did you say Dr Young uh Dr Young yes yes
Judge Lynn it's a real honor to speak
before you and your thank you for being
here committee
uh I I want to say thank you for the
work that you do
it's it's hard work trying to make our
state better
my name is Dr OG Young
I'm a retired obstution gynecologist
uh who trained practiced and taught
Dartmouth medical students
for over 40 years in Concord
I'm the past president of the New
Hampshire Medical Society and I remain a
member of The General Counsel
representing
the Obstetricians and gynecologists in
our state
I'm here testifying
for the New Hampshire Medical Society
the majority of my colleagues
my past patients and the majority of New
Hampshire women
to support house bill 88.
politics obviously crept
into our judicial
branch of our democracy in June
when the Dobbs Jackson decision
overturned
Roe v Wade taking away the right of
privacy
in deciding about a woman's health her
fertility and her future
the result is that now one in three
reproductive age women
do not have access to abortion in their
home States
the inevitable result is that affluent
women will continue to have
safe abortions
crossing state lines if necessary
but marginalized and less affluent women
will not have access to preventive
services and they will resort to unsafe
abortion
I'm old enough
who have seen the consequences
of unsafe
illegal abortion
performed by unskilled
providers in non-sterile
conditions
my first admission onto the gynecologic
Service as an intern
almost 50 years ago was a young woman
with a septic abortion
we gave her fluids IV antibiotics
through the operating room
removed a foul smelling uterus filled
with pus
and two days later watched her
helplessly
die
leaving three motherless
children
at home
if my feelings about legalized abortion
were ambivalent at that time
they've never been ambivalent after
historic reality
is that abortions
are gonna happen
they're going to take place
we cannot go back to the times where
desperate women
of limited means seeking unsafe
pregnancy terminations is happening
everything that we can do for women
to give them control over their bodies
and fertility
enhances their health and makes our
world a better place
we must protect the privacy of a woman
and her care provider when it comes to
pregnancy
this decision is deeply personal and
very difficult
one that should remain the prerogative
of a woman
and her care provider not to be usurped
by lawmakers
I encourage you to join all of the other
New England states Vermont Maine
Massachusetts Connecticut Rhode Island
by
codifying abortion protecting a woman's
right to terminate a pregnancy
we must make it clearer here in New
Hampshire
that we are a state that values privacy
that values freedom
that values individual decision making
by passing house bill
88.
thank you thank you questions for this
awareness
yes uh representative Manos
excuse me thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question doctor we
heard testimony earlier today that the
provisions in current law that
penalized doctors and punished doctors
are discouraging Physicians from
learning and becoming proficient in
abortion and reproductive Health Care in
New Hampshire
and I was wondering if the medical
society the New Hampshire Medical
Society had a position on that or
whether what you've what you've observed
in your long years of practice
well first of all emphasize that I can't
speak for all members of the society
there are some positions who are not in
favor of abortion
but as a society
and remember Roe v Wade was passed on
this principle
all Physicians respect the privacy
the private relationship between
a patient and a physician
and so the society is
supporting
this particular bill
now you mentioned that we have fewer and
fewer
residents trained in termination and
pregnancy and you're absolutely right
it's uh
it's a problem
and we're trying to address that problem
we don't ever make anyone perform an
abortion who doesn't want to perform an
abortion or even train to perform an
abortion
um but we're trying to address that
particular
issue
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Turk
thanks chairman thank you thank you Dr
Young
um given that all the other New England
states have protections like this in
place and given your history
running and participating in a medical
OB GYN practice as well as as your your
role on the medical society
uh what are your thoughts in terms of uh
whether or not not having this provision
uh in law puts New Hampshire at a
difficult uh I'll call it competitive
Advantage for attracting
um the necessary Workforce yeah
well as I understand it abortion is
legal in New Hampshire right now but we
don't have a law
that says it's legal
I'm sorry as I understand it abortion is
legal in New Hampshire but we don't have
a law
it codifies that
it uh would be like making a law making
walking legal we don't need a law to do
that but our feeling is with abortion
it's a very controversial issue and we
do need a law
to declare that it's legal for women to
know that it's legal for Physicians to
know that it's legal
that's
that's really why I think we have this
protection act
other questions for this Witness
yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you doctor
for your testimony you had mentioned a
concern that we might go back to I think
you referred them as dirty abortions I
may be wrong with attorneys but the idea
being back alley abortions unsafe coat
hangers illegal non-sterile yeah exactly
um are you aware that in the Years
immediately preceding Roe versus Wade
that the same number of women died
during abortion procedures by licensed
medical professionals as unlicensed
medical professionals
well I can tell you that the World
Health Organization reports that there
are 22 million unsafe abortions per year
in the world
that's probably underreported and I can
tell you that there are hundreds of
thousands of injuries because of these
unsafe abortions and tens of thousands
deaths
because of unsafe abortion
um
you've ever performed abortion you you
know it's not a simple procedure and uh
having a sterile environment it's
extremely important
um
I I can't imagine
that there wouldn't be a much higher
rate of complication and mortality if we
just have back alley procedures
other questions for this Witness
representative Perez
thank you I have a question since
um this is your expertise
what do Obstetricians now consider
perhaps a viable
fetus at what age is a B I know it
depends there's a lot of things I was in
the medical field
but I know in 19 in the in the 1990s
when the law was changed it was 24 weeks
and that's where all the 24 weeks have
come from but that was a long time ago
what is considered perhaps a viable
fetus in today's medical world
it's a moving Target when I was a
resident we saved a few 28 weekers
now we're actually saving a few 24 to 25
weekers
before
24 weeks we're certainly not saving a
baby
all right other other questions for this
Witness
saying none thank you very much
next I'm going to call on Patricia
Mullen and next will be Anya Morehouse
great thank you
foreign
my name is Patty Mullen I'm a resident
of Santa Pino Hampshire
and I am here to support house spell 88
[Music]
um
I'm going to ad-lib a little bit I guess
the for me personally as a woman
who is obviously past the age of having
to deal with pregnancy
I think about my daughter and other
women
and as I see this nation chipping away
day by day by day
the rights of women
I am more and more aware of how
important it is
that we do everything we can to enshrine
whatever rights we have left
so although my story isn't exactly
in relationship to this house spell
the reason why I'm here is because of my
own feeling
of the necessity to make sure that women
in this state feel safe
and that they know that there is a
statute
that will take legislation to chip away
at it rather than to continue to chip
so this is my story
my mother had four daughters my sister
Deirdre 18 months later I arrived
considered an Irish twin
seven years later came the twin girls
my father was an alcoholic abuser and a
traveling salesman
three months after the Twins were born
my mom discovered my father had two
other wives
the next few years found us on welfare
living in the projects and once the five
of us were homeless
mom remarried when I was 11. she married
a New York City fireman with a shield
not a badge
in New York it's his shield
and I expressed that so that you
understand how little I was protected
because this New York City fireman had a
shield
I do not say his name
I call him the evil one
the evil one bought a nice home and
moved the five of us in
the four girls spent the rest of our
childhoods being raped beaten
emotionally mentally spiritually and
intellectually tortured
we would call the police
he had a shield
my sister died from suicide this past
July my Irish twin
she was a brilliant woman
graduated from Fordham as an adult with
her MSW and a 4.0 average after raising
three brilliant children
started having memory issues at 62.
it turned out Deirdre had multiple
traumatic brain injuries the dementia
was rapid
she hated losing her mind
the evil one used to grab us by our hair
and bang our heads against the walls of
the floor
if we were on the floor he would kick us
with his steel-toed firemen boots
I have had a baseline MRI to check my
brain
Deirdre died from the beatings
my sister Deirdre tried to protect the
three of us
she saved my life when I was 16.
my period was two weeks late
I was terrified
I was always terrified
I told Pietra and she took me for a
urine test
by now I was three weeks late
in New York abortions were legal prior
to Roe v Wade
I found out I was pregnant at eight
weeks
her first words to me were
Jesus Christ Patty if he finds out you
were pregnant he's going to beat you to
death
I knew this was literally the truth
we scheduled an abortion it would be two
weeks
those two weeks were the longest weeks
of my life
by the time I had my abortion I was 10
weeks pregnant
everyone in this world has their own
personal reason to choose abortion
my reason was abject fear of being
beaten to death
the freedom to choose saved me
one of my therapists once told me in 30
years of practice my childhood was the
worst she ever heard
I am here today speaking to you
only because I had an abortion
if you think I am overly dramatic for
any reason
just think of my sister
who died from multiple brain injuries
this summer
I have a daughter now a beautiful
educated kind and generous young woman
I cannot fathom why she should be denied
access to the reproductive health care
that literally saved my life
I knew what was best for me at 16.
no one was protecting me
the choice I made was the first time in
16 years
that I was actually able to protect
myself
access to abortion must be available to
women
each of our lives and circumstances are
different but no matter our reason each
of us must have access to abortion
personally behind closed doors free from
government intrusion and interference no
one else knows our stories none of you
knew me
or what was best for my life
Reproductive Rights saved my life
abortion saved my life and if this spill
is not passed we run the risk of
continuing to Chisel and chisel and
chisel
and maybe someday some woman will get
beat to death
thank you for hearing my testimony thank
you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you
um Anya Morehouse and next will be Jason
Edison
good afternoon my name is Anya Morehouse
and I'm a student in Sullivan County
the proposed House Bill 88 States
because it is vital to the equality and
Liberty of all individuals the state
shall not restrict or interfere with an
individual's exercise of their private
decision to terminate a pregnancy
except as in provided in RSA
32943-329.50 and RSA 13236
I would like to focus on the blatant
hypocrisy and disparagement toward women
implied in the phrase vital to the
equality and Liberty of all individuals
the very wording used here implies that
abortion is necessary for women to be
free and equal to men nothing could be
more belittling
there is an assumption behind this way
of thinking that equality lies in what
we do rather than Who We Are
women are equal to men and that they are
endowed with intrinsic dignity and worth
pre-born babies are equal to already
born men and women in that they are
endowed with intrinsic dignity and worth
women cannot be viewed as equal on the
condition that they have the option to
kill their pre-born child
pre-born children cannot be viewed as
equal on the condition that they are
wanted or convenient
if House Bill 88 is passed New Hampshire
will not only promote the violence and
barbarity that is abortion but promote a
misogynistic and discriminatory agenda
that tells women the only way they can
succeed is through ending the life of
their child
rather than make this a reality in our
state I urge you to focus your efforts
on creating an environment here where
women facing unplanned pregnancies are
supported and given the means necessary
to lead successful and fulfilling lives
without abortion
reject this bill and promote bills that
truly uphold the Dignity of all the
equality of all and the liberty of all
thank you thank you questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you uh Jason Hennessey
and next will be Devin Quinn
hello my name is Jason Hennessey and I'm
here again as the president of New
Hampshire right to life uh we're here we
oppose this bill HB 88 uh two for two
main reasons the first one is that in
our analysis this is essentially a
meaningless virtue signal uh so I'm
humbled to be surrounded by accomplished
lawyers here I I only took undergrad
Civics but in my undergrad civics class
we were told that A legislature cannot
find a future legislature other than
through the Constitution
and so if you pass HB 88 any future
legislature can just repeal it
alternatively you'll if the legislature
decides to keep it what it will mean is
that all the pro-life bills will then be
more difficult we'll be more longer
because they'll all contain a clause
that amends the exceptions to add itself
into there so in terms of protections
for abortion rights this doesn't do that
as far as we can tell
uh from the second
from the second point
uh well it's I guess just to just to
um
bring that back a little bit more I I
actually didn't hear any examples from
anybody of cases that they would think
that this would
get you anything
um whether it's lawsuits against the
government or something like that I
didn't hear any uh strong examples
second one is that is the subject matter
itself of abortion it throughout most of
History
abortion has been seen as being
something bad
um you know it's in the Hippocratic Oath
it's in almost every major religion
throughout history and so at this point
in stage what we'd be saying is we want
to enshrine something that most of
history and most religions say is evil
the killing of an unborn child
so is that the thing that we want to
leave is that the Legacy that we want to
leave to the people who come later
uh so you know as I mentioned before in
the testimony 70 over 70 percent of New
Hampshire agrees with abortion
restrictions at some point this
legislation does not reflect that
consensus here
one thing one thing I wanted to one of
the things I wanted to address is that I
if there's any confusion of Rights of
where where abortion rights are
um where when abortion's legal when it's
not legal I would suggest a web search
um while I was sitting over there I just
did I just did a search of abortion laws
New Hampshire and some of the top uh
hits like Planned Parenthood and
Wikipedia's website
say things like abortion remains safe
and legal in New Hampshire
or abortion in New Hampshire is legal up
to the 24th week so if there's any
confusion
Google's your front and that is the rest
of my testimony thank you Mr chair
thank you very much questions for this
Witness
representative Morgan
it's very quickly I mean I'm not a
lawyer either but I'm
I mean your point about I've the point
about not finding a future legislature
but doesn't this also apply to acts by
um state government that aren't
specifically authorized by a
by one of those two by an RSA and uh
I don't know whether or not you think
that's implausible but I think it's am I
wrong at thinking that it's plausible
that the state might do something to
restrict rights um even if they even uh
even it's not specifically uh authorized
by either of those two rsas that might
go
Beyond
[Music]
so is your experience in the state never
go like beyond what appears to be
specifically authorized by the law or
they always like stay colored like stay
totally within the lines of the law
uh thank you representative uh I'm not
completely sure I understand your
question it was it is it along the lines
of could an agency through rulemaking or
something uh restrict rights or
something like that
I think so but I think
is it possible is it do you think it's
so you're saying it's unlikely the state
would ever take any action restrict the
laws unless we specifically passed an
artist saying authoring two of them or
is it conceivable to State might uh you
know
do things that aren't specifically uh
authorized by the rsas
uh so I I I I'm not a lawyer
representative so I'd have to defer on
that all right other questions for this
Witness
yes representative Perez
thank you now I'm completely confused so
when this bill was presented to us I
specifically asked if this bill would
prohibit us at a later time
from changing
the RSA and I was told
blatantly no it would not
but then I have heard testimony after
testimony saying
or at least what I'm hearing is that if
at any time we wanted to lower the
um limit of 24
we wouldn't be able to do this so now
I'm confused and I want to hear the
other side of the story
I do not want anything that'll I'm
asking if doing this is going to legally
or uh protectedly going to limit
the legislature from changing the
present bill without having to
completely eliminate it and start all
over again
thank you representative my
understanding is that you can't find a
future legislature without a cacr
ific that you can't prohibit a future
legislature from amending any law
without without a constitutional
amendment
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you Mr chair
next I'm going to call on Devin Quinn
please
foreign
all right thank you
got noon chair members of the committee
my name is Devin I'm the uh Devin Quinn
I'm the director of policy for the New
Hampshire women's Foundation where we
invest in equality and opportunity for
the women and girls of New Hampshire
through research education advocacy and
Grant making and the women's Foundation
uh very much supports HB 88 because
access to a full range of reproductive
health care including abortion is
crucial for Women's Health Economic
Security and long-term impacts on women
and their families
deciding whether and when to have a
child is the most consequential decision
relative to women's lifetime economic
well-being
women who have access to abortion have
higher rates of high school and college
graduation they can invest in school and
job training increasing their long-term
earning potential
and the intergenerational impacts of
um to previously born children or
subsequently born children
um lower their rate of poverty increase
their High School graduation rate and
college attendance rate
and they and access to care to abortion
care is critical to disrupt the cycle of
poverty between Generations
so I also sent around I sent around my
testimony but also a colorful sheet that
we put out this past summer
uh that goes around uh that covers the
background on New Hampshire's
legislative actions on abortion it goes
over information on care in the state
and comparative policies of New England
I hope it's useful to you
um for any um abortion related
legislation you see this session
um but I also presented this uh hand out
to Providers over the summer right after
the Dobbs decision
um and they found it very helpful
because they were sharing stories with
me that they right after the job
decision they had a lot of questions
from their patients
um they shared that they had patients
asking if they would have to remove
their iuds and they said of course not
um I would use our long-acting
reversible contraception but there was a
lot of patient confusion particularly
last summer and they also had questions
of course about their access about
patients access to abortion and so I was
hearing a lot from providers that they
were doing a lot of education on what
their rights their patients rights were
in New Hampshire and I think that
providers and patients and everyone in
New Hampshire would appreciate and
deserve to know that New Hampshire will
protect the right to safe and legal
abortion amid a rapidly changing
landscape in the country
um I know there has been there have been
questions for an example
um when our situation that would occur
when this affirmative right that we're
seeking to establish an hb88 would be
theoretically enforced and of course
these are theoretical ideas but
uh one example that we had discussed
previously might have been if a State
Trooper sees someone driving into a
clinic an abortion provider it sees that
they have floor um Texas plates or
Florida plates or any other plates and
they are confused because other states
have different laws
and they prevented that person from
entering the clinic
um that might be an example this is
theoretical but what we're saying is
that it is so important to be clear
about our own laws because other because
there really is no federal framework
anymore
um it's up to the states to decide and
we should be very clear with New
Hampshire about where we stand on
abortion access and rights
thank you very much questions for this
Witness
seeing them thank you there's one more
uh person who signed up uh on hb88
that's representative Potenza
representative Potenza
thank you chair
representative Potenza Stratford
District 19 Rochester's Awards one
through four and six
listening to the testimony I'd just like
to clarify a couple of things
the laws of the land are founded upon
the Constitution of the United States in
New Hampshire our constitution came
first so our New Hampshire laws come
first and the federal comes second
in regard to overturning Roe versus Wade
just because so there was so much
testimony on that
this is following the Constitution and
giving rights back to where they should
have always been where those rights
originated from the Constitution does
not prohibit the citizens of each state
from regulating or prohibiting abortion
Roe and Casey seized that Authority
we now overrule those decisions and
return the authority to the people and
their elected representatives
abortion is not Health Care abortion is
an elective procedure abortion is a
choice
if a woman decides to take the life of
her one to six month old baby that is
her choice and that choice is legal in
New Hampshire because that is our New
Hampshire law and what our constituents
have accepted
what are their represented body have
passed
listening to the heart-wrenching
testimony here I want to be clear
terminating a presidency based upon rape
or incest or any other horrific reason
would never be against the law in New
Hampshire I know that
terminating a pregnancy if a woman's
life is in danger the life of the baby
baby or a fetal fatal homily is
considered health care that's the
difference
based upon the most recent information
gathered from the Center for
Reproductive Rights there are only 10
states 10.
that have state laws that protect
abortion
if we want anything codified into law do
it the right way that's through a cacr
on a side note I was actually a patient
of a doctor that testified here today
when we lived in Concord
he used to wear a button
that said I love women
he was a fantastic OB GYN
I loved him
but I'd like to correct one thing that
he stated when he was in his testimony
he said he represent represents women in
New Hampshire
we need to be clear that he only
represents a portion of women in New
Hampshire thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on HB 88
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on hb88
and open the hearing on House Bill 224
and I will call on Senator Sue Prentice
please
oh okay I'm sorry yep I'm sorry we have
uh representative wolf sorry I didn't
did you fill out a card
did I apologize Mr chairman don't worry
about there's a blank one right there
for you got one right here thank you
[Music]
um
two two four
ah great thank you very much thank you
um
thank you Mr chairman I didn't know I
could screw it up before I even started
oh don't worry
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
members of the Judiciary Committee
House Bill 224
this bill does nothing to make abortion
any easier in the state of New Hampshire
it may clarify the law only
the 24-week time frame still stands
House Bill 2224 repeals only the
criminal penalties that were inserted in
the fetal protection act as part of the
budget pass in 2021.
these penalties include a possible
felony conviction with a jail time of up
to seven years as well as a fine of a
hundred thousand dollars
these are charges which no other medical
procedure inflicts on a doctor
a doctor acting in good faith and
following the Hippocratic Oath would
constantly be second guessing his or
herself
could this uncertainty cause a doctor to
not act immediately as would be prudent
saving the life of a pregnant woman
should be able to be done without any
other thoughts clouding one's mind
and I want to point out a recent case in
Texas that highlights the uncertainty
that makes treating a pregnancy that has
gone awry in the potentially fatal
consequences that can follow
in Texas a young woman's water broke
and she and the doctors knew that the
baby would not survive
yet as the baby still had a heartbeat
they were unwilling to perform an
abortion
three days later the woman had chills
her temperature Rose to 103. finally the
doctors agreed and felt safe that they
could legally perform an abortion
12 hours after the pregnancy was
terminated the woman came down with
sepsis
intense medical intervention barely
saved the mother
and I ask you
would you want this to happen to you oh
would you want your doctor to do what he
or she is trained to do and to protect
the mother's life
very simply for these reasons I urge
this committee to recommend that HB 224
receive a vote of ought to pass
thank you very much questions for this
Witness
yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative
how does current law Define a violation
of the law that could be prosecuted and
how does one prove that a violation has
occurred when there's no way of proving
the age of the baby and how many
prosecutions have actually occurred
since this law became the law
I think those were three questions it
sounds like three questions but we'll
allow it roll out go ahead
um
I'm not sure about prosecutions I
haven't gone into that all I know is
what I've been told by doctors in the
field I know follow me is going to be
Matthew Hood from Dartmouth and Dr Cass
who said of OB GYN up there who can tell
you about some of those things I know
that
at one time we wanted to have some
statistics
and
we could never get anybody to agree on
that so I can't tell you the answer to
your question
other questions for this Witness
I guess I I do have a question
Representatives I as I think you and I
had discussed in the hall yesterday I'm
the elevator rides have been too short
the the uh
the statute for the criminal penalty
says that liability for for being guilty
of a crime is if you act knowingly and
so I'm
you know I I guess I have
some difficulty understanding if why
with that
with that caveat in there that limits in
other words if if the if there's some
question that the doctor has not act
acted knowingly
um that then there's there's not a basis
for prosecution but it's the in other
words if the
what if if a doctor does act in other
words a doctor knows there's no question
that the that this fetus is over 24
weeks old and there's no there's no
justification you know in the terms of
life or health of the mother or that
kind of thing fetal abnormalities
um and the doctor performs the abortion
anyway I I'm I guess I am troubled with
the idea that the doctor should not be
subject to criminal penalties in that
circumstance
I think the issue that you raised Mr
chairman is that it raises a cloud
and there's a cloud out there that may
occur and as I stated in the Texas case
it may delay
proper Medical Care
if it can be proven that it's knowingly
in violation
I don't have a problem with that
but let's have the medical procedure
proceed without knowing
that situation
does that make any sense to you well I
mean I I guess I I guess what I would
say is I understand that this that
obviously this could this there could be
circumstances where this could become
a question did the doctor really know
what were the sir I I completely
understand that
but this I guess the thing I have
trying to distinguish this from the
example that I gave you when we did when
we talked it is it's perfectly legal for
doctors to prescribe narcotics for you
know for for for appropriate use but
it's not legal for doctors to do that if
they're actually acting as drug dealers
and there have been you know many many
cases in which doctors have been
prosecuted for that and it is often the
situation in those kind of cases uh but
I know because I've had some of them
myself some of them myself many many
years ago that that there will be a
question the doctor will say well you
know there'll be an issue was the doctor
really acting within the scope of his
practice or was he being a drug dealer
and those can be complicated
um
but I'm not sure how they are
all that much complicated from the
circumstances you're talking about here
you've raised an interesting question
which I don't have an answer for except
to say that I think a doctor acting in
good faith wouldn't
not want to have that sword hanging over
his head
thank you other other questions for yes
uh representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
may I assume from the tenor of this bill
that you or co-sponsors are not opposed
to the six-month restriction but only
the penalty
yes or I don't know whether that's a yes
or no but uh I'm willing to live with a
six-month restriction I think it's a
reasonable restriction I know some of my
people including my wife disagree with
me but I think we've found a compromise
yes please
then may I ask
how do you enforce
the the intent of the fetal Life
protection act by withdrawing penalties
and making an open choice to observe or
not
you have a law on the books that says
you can't
do something there are other ways to
enforce the penalty whether it be a loss
of medical license or something like
that but I think they
jail term for a doctor the fine of a
hundred thousand dollars
for a person that is acting in their
best interest in the best interest of
the mother
is enough of a penalty enough of a
threat
thank you thank you other questions for
this Witness
see none thank you representative thank
you thank you uh Senator uh suprentice
Senator thank you for coming
foreign
thank you chair Lynn good to see you
this afternoon and members of house
Judiciary I know it's been a long day so
I will um my comments will be brief and
hopefully to the point I'm going to
frame my uh my testimony in or focus it
around really access the gaps in
maternal care that already exist in New
Hampshire other than that are growing in
New Hampshire and want a law like this
on the books could continue to do to
harm that situation so for the record my
name is Sue Prentice I'm a state senator
from District Five I represent 15
communities large part of Grafton County
part of Sullivan County and one town in
Merrimack County
and I am here today speaking in support
of House Bill 224 and I I appreciate
that representative wolf has filed this
legislation so as you know and he has
already said but it's worth repeating
that this bill
would this bill would remove the
criminal penalties that are now in place
for performing an abortion after 24
weeks
and those those penalties are it's a
felony it's a hundred thousand dollar
fine and a prison sentence and as
representative wolf said this is the
only medical care practice or medical
part of the medical profession that
actually is subject to these kinds of
provisions and penalties so when we were
debating this in 2021
I heard from a number of healthcare
professionals and I actually took a
quote out of a letter that we received
that were signed by 200 New Hampshire
health care providers that I want to
share with you New Hampshire already
struggles to retain Medical Care
Professionals and we are deeply
concerned that these criminal penalties
will undermine the state's effort to
recruit and to retain clinicians
so you know New Hampshire already has a
shrinking population of obstetrical care
providers and I had the honor of serving
the state of New Hampshire as the chief
of Emergency Medical Services at your
department of safety for close to 10
years and during that period of time we
started to see this shrinking population
of obstetrical care providers which was
predominantly at that time in the North
Country so I teamed up with
I teamed up with nurse midwives and
Obstetricians and other Emergency
Medical Service professionals and we
went into these areas and what we did is
we picked the areas that had there was
there was no maternity care unit present
but that doesn't mean that there aren't
pregnant women in those communities and
an obstetrical emergency could actually
take place so we went up there and we
trained them to manage the situation
that was before them without the
adequate type of backup that they really
need because again this population has
shrunk at that time I thought it was
only a rural problem but what I can tell
you now is that this is not just a rural
problem that this is impacting Suburban
areas in New Hampshire as well we have
26 acute care hospitals in the state in
the last 20 years 10 of them have closed
their birthing units the 10th is
actually in Derry New Hampshire good
afternoon representative good to see you
and we have an 11th that is planning to
close its doors over in the Seacoast so
that's a pretty significant number in
shift of obstetrical Care Professionals
and services that are available and
again my concern is our pipeline in
terms of the workforce and bringing more
obstetrical care providers to take care
of our moms and our babies and their
families in New Hampshire
so and I just a few other points I
learned from a an obstetrician a
horoscope obstetrician at Dartmouth
health during this first the first time
we were debating this in in 2021 that
they had a high risk practice in Bedford
New Hampshire again a more like not
considered a rural area of this state
and that it took them close to two years
to recruit a high risk obstetrician a
neonatologist who would be taking care
of Moms
um and you know you know while they were
pregnant and that women from where I
live which is in Lebanon Lebanon and
Hanover and other parts of the Upper
Valley were rotating and covering that
practice so that these women could still
receive
could still receive care so I know that
that particular situation has been
remedied but it doesn't mean it isn't
going to continue in the future
I know that New Hampshire trains at a
minimum for OB GYN residents per year
and certainly we'd like the folks that
we train to stay here and take care of
our New Hampshire patients so the big
question is will they think twice about
this now will they seek positions
elsewhere because of these criminal
penalties that are going to come in
between them and doing their job
so that's certainly a conversation that
is happening and I can't tell you that
is it impacted this recruitment already
but this is not even what are we two
years old this happened in my first term
in the Senate
my greatest fear could become a reality
and that's that we won't as I've said be
able to fill these important roles and
provide access to obstetrical care in
New Hampshire why would why would you
want to work in a state that would
prosecute you for caring for a woman in
that most and her family in that most
critical time
criminalizing health care providers for
providing Compassionate Care that's in
line with their medical expertise their
medical expertise and the best interests
of their patients is why I could
consider to be cruel and to be
regressive and could have chilling
effects in the long term up here in New
Hampshire and we critically need to have
a solid framework in infrastructure for
obstetrical care providers that's what's
at Jeopardy here so I urge you to
support HP 224 and to do the right
things do the right thing for our health
care providers and for the families the
women that they take care of I again I
support ought to pass I'm happy to
answer any questions that I can and if
not I know that representative wolf has
answered some and we do have some other
we do have some other professionals and
experts here that might be better suited
thank you representative Lynn
thank you questions for this Witness
uh representative
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
Senator Apprentice for for um your
testimony
um as as a as a former uh head of uh
States EMT
um in situations late term pregnancy if
it were to arise I know there's been
testimony that this from a practical
standpoint doesn't happen at least on a
on a routine basis
um how much time would be available to a
provider in certain circumstances uh to
make that decision about what needs to
be done
in in the later stages of of pregnancy
if
um situations arise and and how clear
would it always be
thank you for your question
that's that's hard to answer I mean it
could be moments to minutes to more but
what we are putting in between them and
their decision making
um is a is a risk manager or you know
the again the thought of what they might
have to do what what criminal penalties
they might suffer for doing their job so
I can't answer direct exactly but thank
you for the question
yes other questions for this Witness
yes representative Perez
thank you
I have a concern in the fact that this
not only repeals Criminal
penalties but it also repeals any civil
uh penalties
for example if
um if a doctor
performed an abortion on a minor
um and the mother didn't give permission
or if something happened
during the abortion that the mother
would not the person having the abortion
would not have the opportunity to
provide any civil suit so taking away
criminal and civil penalties I think is
in makes this kind of a red flag for me
can you tell me why the Civil is in
there and if that civil
um
are my fears
are my fears right that it could take
away the right for civil suit
I'm actually going to defer that
question to Matthew Hood a former state
senator the the government relations
director for Dartmouth Health okay
thanks Matthew all right other questions
for this one thank you
yes representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for the detailed uh rationale and
itemization of your argument
I have a question
if the intent of the fetal Life
protection act
is to protect that viable life
at a certain point going forward from
the 24 weeks
and that right
um
of life
is violated by taking that life
should there not be a penalty
to prevent or caution
people from stepping over the line and
taking that life which the law intends
to protect
um good to see you representative
Stapleton and thank you for the question
so here's what I know less than
according to the Centers for Disease
Control less than one percent of
pregnancies are terminated after 24
weeks these are
mothers and families that have named
their children that have painted their
nurseries and are preparing for to bring
this life into the world but they are
met with a circumstance an unforeseen
you know critical devastating
circumstances put them in that position
so
I just want to frame it in it's not that
this is not taken lightly and it's not a
matter of uh you know I'm gonna proceed
forward because I can I'm going to
proceed forward because there's a
situation that my medical care provider
and I are talking about and need to make
a decision on because my life the
child's the child's life are in Jeopardy
and I think it's important to keep in
mind in the whole conversation what if
you know this is a very small percentage
which tells you how seriously not just
providers but the women and the families
take these situations
thank you representative
thank you other questions for this
Witness
see none thank you very much uh next I'm
going to call on uh Dr Tom Sherman
former senator
had had you had to leave okay all right
I was going to submit all right great
all right the next I'm going to go on to
uh Daniel uh Danielle Pimentel and the
next uh witness after that will be
Allison bodell
this trim himself
good afternoon once again Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Danielle Pimentel and I'm with Americans
United for life and today
um in my last testimony that I'm
presenting to the committee today I urge
the committee to oppose this bill
um because it will allow abortion
providers to escape legal culpability
for their illegal abortions that result
in the life-threatening complications to
women
repealing the civil and criminal
penalties prevent New Hampshire women
from Seeking Justice under the fetal
Life protection act if they've been
harmed during an abortion
New Hampshire has a legitimate interest
in protecting maternal health and safety
as noted by the Supreme Court in Dobbs
yet hb224 directly contradicts with the
state's interests to safeguard pregnant
women because it removes Common Sense
protections for their health and life
for example the bill removes criminal
and civil liability for abortions and
violation of the fetal Life protection
act that result in harm or death of
pregnant women and as I said in earlier
testimony we know abortions carry a
higher risk of of or higher medical risk
when done later in pregnancies and that
many women suffer complications
so if a health care provider performs an
abortion after 24 weeks gestation or
fails to perform an ultrasound in
violation of the fetal Life protection
act that provider is subjecting a
pregnant woman to numerous
life-threatening Health complications
and potentially death
however if hb224 is passed women cannot
maintain a lawsuit under the fetal Life
protection act against abortion
providers who performed an illegal
abortion and again potentially caused
them harm physical harm or resulted in
their death
um the bill also eliminates
um women's protections against
psychological injuries from abortion
under the fetal Life protection act a
woman can seek monetary damages for both
their physical and psychological
injuries and this is an important remedy
given that pregnancy loss whether that
it's natural or induced through it by an
abortion is associated with an increased
risk of mental health problems and
scholarship shows that the emotional
reaction or grief from losing a
pregnancy or experiencing a pregnancy
lawsuit to an abortion can be prolonged
afflict mental health and impact
intimate or parental relationships
so abortion causes grave harm to women's
mental health however hb224 incentivizes
abortionists to completely disregard the
impact that an abortion may have on a
woman's mental health being what mental
part of me well-being by eliminating
civil liability for psychological
injuries arising from again illegal
abortions under the fetal Life
protection act or from failing to
provide an ultrasound in accordance with
the law
the criminal and civil penalties under
the fetal Life protection act are some
of the last remaining regulations in
place to protect the life health and
safety of women who choose to have an
abortion in New Hampshire and the fetal
Life protection act does not penalize
doctors from Compassionate Care as you
may have heard earlier it penalized them
for performing illegal abortions after
24 weeks that result in life-threatening
complications to women if this bill is
passed New Hampshire may become a safe
haven for abortion doctors to take
advantage of that and for these reasons
I urge the committee to oppose hb224
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much
um Allison Bedell and next will be uh
Courtney Reed
Captain good afternoon nice to see you
all back up to lunch right
um I I'm
um asking you to please don't repeal the
um criminal penalties act
um one thing that I didn't mention this
morning is uh in my morning's
presentation is that a baby's heart
begins to beat at five weeks by 18 days
that is five weeks before the mother's
after the mother's first menstrual
period the mother doesn't even know
she's pregnant
now correct me if I'm wrong if one
person uses an instrument to stop the
Beating Heart of another what do we call
that
anybody
I think we'd call that murder
so now I ask you how different is this
from abortion especially in late germ
abortions so I ask you please don't
repeal the criminal and civil penalties
from the federal fetal protection act
thank you very much questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you
um uh Courtney Reed
and next will be uh uh Julia stoot
thank you again chairman and members of
the committee I just wanted to provide a
brief statement of support on behalf of
the American civil liberties Union for
HB 224 which we've heard would repeal
the criminal penalties from New
Hampshire's current abortion ban
I want to start off by making clear that
abortion is health care and not a
criminal activity and that
criminalization of abortion result
results in poor health outcomes abortion
is an extremely safe component of
comprehensive reproductive health care
and medical societies like the American
College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists has expressed that
abortion is an essential component of
women's health care
but moreover physician Advocates and
medical ethics experts have noted that
uh laws similar to the existing criminal
penalties in New Hampshire often require
Health Care Professionals to
de-prioritize the pregnant individual or
act in ways that might be medical
medically harmful because instances
where criminalization of abortion is
only lifted for medical emergencies or
risk of death these narrow definitions
that are in current statute have been
described as vague for Reproductive
Health Care Providers to interpret which
is often left Physicians feeling
cornered into limiting care or requiring
a continued deterioration of a mother's
health before an abortion is deemed as
medically necessary
moreover imposing criminal penalties
creates an unnecessary barrier to
abortion access according to the Journal
of Family Medicine laws that directly
criminalize abortion providers
discourages both capable providers and
future clinicians from pursuing the
practice of abortion care which we've
heard in statements earlier today
in fact in 2021 when the abortion care
abortion ban was introduced we heard
Physicians and medical doctors expressed
that these criminal penalties evoke fear
that they might not be able to offer the
best care to their patients and it's
already difficult to recruit Physicians
and other practitioners in rural States
like New Hampshire and in fact a recent
study of pre-med students found that how
States respond to rows overturn will
significantly impact where they choose
to attend medical school
after the pandemic New Hampshire's
primary care and health professional
shortage has been deemed as
catastrophically staffed and legislators
should affect policy that attracts
Health Care Providers to the Granite
State not Inspire fear through
criminalizing Health Care Services like
abortion
moreover the current law singles out
qualified providers capable of
Performing abortions later in pregnancy
the criminalization of abortion
providers represents one of many
politically motivated tactics to further
restrict access to abortion and these
current penalties embolden individuals
that seek to intimidate abortion
providers further
our law is a slippery slope and is an
invitation for further harassment
against these medical professionals and
should be removed and lastly I'll leave
it with uh polling data that's expressed
in 2021 that 66 of granite Staters have
shown support for keeping abortion legal
in all or most cases so I encourage the
committee to pass HB 224 and get rid of
this ambiguity that obstructs quality
Care thank you questions but excuse me
questions further questions
oh yes representative Tripp
thank you for taking my question uh are
you aware that New Hampshire is a
Dylan's real estate
I'm sorry could you repeat that I said
are you aware that New Hampshire is a
Dylan's rule state
uh no thank you oh you're not a lawyer
I'm not a practicing attorney now all
right well anyhow uh in a Dylan's real
estate uh typically what is not
permitted is prohibited
which would mean that since uh
uh you need to help I'm on the wrong
Bill I'm sorry
yes representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
we back out the penalty
in this law
what kind of precedent does that set
losing the penalty deterrent
to other laws
that protect some of the many people
that your organization defends and
supports
sorry I think I only got half of that
question would you mind repeating it
the question focuses on the precedent
that we set by backing out penalty civil
and criminal but especially Criminal
from laws that we have widespread in our
body of law
that are enforced and protected by and a
deterrent by by virtue of the penalties
that are listed
and thank you for your question uh the
ACLU has taken a stance of supporting
this law as the the medical community
has noted that it's
um its vagueness has often led to tough
decisions that obstruct
um their ability to best provide quality
of care
um and since I'm not a practicing
attorney I'd love to correspond with you
further and get the advice from our
legal counsel that we do have
thank you thank you other questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you Julia
stoot and uh after her uh Omer her
good afternoon my name is Julia Stout
I'm a resident and student from Sullivan
County
House Bill 224 which would repeal the
Seminole criminal and civil penalties
from the fetal Life protection act as a
senseless bill which I strongly oppose
section 329 46 of the fetal Life
protection act which would be repealed
by this bill says that any health care
provider who knowingly performs an
abortion after 24 weeks would be guilty
of a class B felony
what is the point of a law that is not
upheld and the criminal penalty not
enforced by our judicial system
these so-called Health Care Providers
which should more honestly be referred
to as abortionists are not providing
necessary and life-saving treatments to
pregnant women rather they are taking
innocent lives and putting pregnant
women at risk of serious health
complications
these abortionists many of whom are
working in facilities with a specific
purpose of Performing abortions should
be held to the same standards of the law
and its penalties as any other criminal
would
not only do these abortionists totally
violate a human being's dignity and
unalienable right to life by performing
an abortion but by doing So after 24
weeks gestation they are also in
violation of the fetal Life protection
act
these abortionists should be prosecuted
to the full extent of the law and in
order for that to happen House Bill 224
must be voted down
thank you questions for this Witness
thank you
oh yes uh representative testerman
probably
get back
should
ers
I'm sorry I I didn't hear the first half
of the question
Michael
it's issue right here
foreign
okay
you you stated some relatively strong
reasons for for getting rid of the bill
uh particularly in its current form see
a lot of those are based on the fact
that many of the of the penalties or the
injuries done were done in in the
background or wherever uh but they were
done by the the
well
very good doctors but they seem to be
all the general kinds of things do you
have the facts on those you know some
written facts of of how many of each of
those and what you're basing your
argument on
um I'm not sure if I'm understanding it
correctly but I don't have any data
statistics with me today to present to
you all
um I do know that any abortion that
takes place after 24 weeks or that is in
violation of the fetal Life protection
act which would go against
um
the life of the mother or uh fetal
abnormalities I believe
any abortion that takes place against
those protections is wrong but do you
have any exact cases of it do you uh
yeah I I hear that the wording and so on
the generalities but I I'm not sure if
those are those are facts taken from
cases that you read about or if they're
just generalities
I'm not sure which specific part you're
referring to I know that
um
I know that
any uh any abortion that is like I said
performed against after the 24 weeks
gestation would be
and against the um
life of the mother I know that would be
yeah against the criminals do you have a
case about an abortion that took place
yes I don't I'm sorry okay
other questions for this Witness
foreign
I'm sorry thank you
can I just say is not abortion Care
Health Care
I do not believe that
the intentional killing of a pre-born
child uh is Healthcare no
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you uh Omar Ahern
please and next is Phyllis Woods
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee
um
I guess one other thing I didn't mention
in my uh first remarks to you folks uh
I I
didn't think it was important at the
time but based upon what I'm hearing
this afternoon
I'm also a Grafton county commissioner
and so I work with a lot of Delegation
members up there in Grafton County so I
thank you for all of your services
members of the your county delegations
and
as a county commissioner
I am one of three responsible for
the operations and the management not
day-to-day management but the operations
and the management of a hundred and
fifty bed
Department of Corrections Facility
so and every month as a county
commissioner I receive a superior court
report
the superior court report basically
tells the commissioners
how many inmates we have in our
Correctional Facility
where they're from and why they are
incarcerated
or why they are waiting uh for their
trial to be completed
so having said that and I'm just
speaking now in general terms of why we
in our society
as as individuals
we can't we do we have a responsibility
to act
you know with common sense
so
and and
all men are they be treated equally
under our Law And Men include men and
women
but there but these laws and penalties
on the book but there are laws and
penalties on the books now
that we're not there
20 years ago 30 years ago
unfortunately
because some people in our society
do not know how to act with common sense
and try to do what is right
so there are penalties that must be
retained
uh in order to remind people
uh
who may not believe that what they are
doing is wrong
so we kind of need to retain these
subjects uh under the penalties of Law
and criminal and civil I believe are
part of that
accordingly I oppose and I ask all of
you to oppose
House Bill 224 FN thank you very much
and again thank you all for your service
thank you questions for this Witness
uh representative Oregon did you have a
question
is this one um
as um since you uh probably with the
Grafton County Jail that's probably
where if anybody was has been prosecuted
under this law that's probably someplace
they might end up so the invest your
knowledge is anybody
been prosecuted or even arrested for
violation of of the fetal Life
protection act since it took effect in
January 1st 2022
uh not to my recollection I do not
recall seeing any of those uh there are
you know a lot of pretty
sick things that you know minors abuse
pornography uh things like that but I
have not seen anything in Grafton County
I don't know what's going on in the
other nine counties though
representative
all right
other questions to this Witness
seeing none thank you very much again
thank you very much
uh Phyllis Woods
I know Miss Woods was here uh earlier
she had to all right
okay all right so miss Woods has left
um uh Marianne Cooper
Ms Cooper
she may have left also all right
um
Sheila
b oh boy
uh Mark I think it's Marshall but I
could be wrong from Somersworth
I'm on a roll here looks like yeah all
right uh Roy Dennehy
and Beth's scarer will be next
so then he yes thank you I'm Roy Dennehy
from Windham New Hampshire
and I oppose
um House Bill 224 FN as I previously
have also opposed the previous
[Music]
um
re repeal bill for the feed and light
protection act
and as I mentioned earlier today I
I'm the life director for the New
Hampshire
Knights of Columbus and I represent over
7 000 nights here in their families
and uh who believe in the sanctity of
human life from the moment of conception
to Natural death
um uh fellow pro-life supporters
in the in in the New Hampshire executive
council state senate House of
Representatives uh have been accused of
having extreme quote extreme ideology
and partisan ideology for supporting and
protecting the current field of Life
protection law
this law in fact protects the pre-born
baby from being brutally killed from 24
weeks after conception to its uh actual
delivery date at nine months
[Music]
um
this current law in effect allows a
pregnant woman to allow her to her
Freeborn baby to be killed at any time
up to 24 weeks after the baby is
conceived
this abortion for these abortion
providers such as planned parenthood and
others
um hide behind the slogans of women's
health reproductive freedom and sexual
education
uh they are the they are extremists and
partisan ideologues they are
[Music]
um
very strong on supporting and promoting
and funding the killing of Freeborn
babies right up to the moment of death
and here in conquer the Democrat
leadership uh has proposed this bill
today
in order to guts or totally eliminate
many penalties to the current field of
Life protection law and replace it with
a totally unrestrictive abortion law
that would allow the killing of babies
in the womb from the moment of
conception right up to the moment of
birth
so who are the extremists here to feed
the Life protection act protects the
human rights of each pre-born baby so
it's a major human rights issue and why
the Knights of Columbus are in total
opposition to this Bill thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you um that's scarer
and the next witness after that will be
uh Ian you
hi I'm Beth skier I'm a mom from Nashua
and I'm here for a second time today to
speak in defense of New Hampshire's
fetal Life protection act which protects
Healthy Babies just a few weeks from
being born from being killed in an
abortion
and again I've included a picture of an
abortion at 23 weeks with my testimony
which is just a week before the fetal
Life protection act kicks in
and
I'm speaking again because I fear some
members of this committee and of our
legislature believe that voting for
repealing the legal and civil penalties
for performing a gruesome late-term
abortion
would give them cover against being
accused of supporting abortion up until
the moment of birth
Governor sununu has made it clear that
he believes that if he signs this bill
into law that he can use this as a fig
leaf in order to not be branded as an
abortioned extremist good luck with that
in the presidential primary
no one's fooled by that
if they're no legal penalties then
everyone knows there is no protection at
all for babies from being killed in a
late term abortion it's common sense
there would be nothing to protect
prevent doctors from performing the
procedure and I'm even more suspicious
now that I've heard that they're
representative Wills proposed this
saying that we could put in other other
penalties but they didn't he didn't
include them in the bill the bill was
fatally flawed right off the bat remove
all the penalties but nothing in its
place
moms and babies and abortion workers
would continue to suffer from this
gruesome multi-day procedure which
cannot be used to save the life of a
mother or save the health of a mother in
an emergency medical situation because
it takes multiple days to complete
and it's traumatic for the abortion
workers as I detailed in my testimony
this morning
I'll end with a quote from Frederica
Matthews Green the problem is that it's
a baby winds up in dead like deadlock
with it's a woman's right
the two statements do not refute each
other so no resolution is possible
what's more they continue a pernicious
fallacy that deadly conflict between
women and children is a normal State of
Affairs
in no seen country are women and their
own children assumed to be mortal
enemies
any culture that does so is slowly
committing suicide
when we accept as normal The Ripping of
a child from her mother's womb we
violate something disturbingly close to
the heart of the human story in the land
where women kill their unborn children
every lesser love grows for you
please vote itia in expedient to
legislate on hv224 to protect innocent
babies from a gruesome death and their
mothers from physical harm and the
abortion workers from the serious mental
health repercussions of participating in
these inhumane procedures
thank you questions to this Witness
seeing none thank you
um uh Ian Hewitt and next after that
will be uh Bethany
Severin severine I believe or severe
scene
Stuart
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee again I'm Ian Hewitt general
counsel at Cornerstone in opposition to
house bill 224. I will not repeat myself
unless there are any questions which
overlap with anything I spoke about
before which I would welcome I will just
raise two points one is that because our
law in New Hampshire already allows the
killing of viable children before six
months and because there's an exception
after six months for fatal fetal
anomalies the only children whose deaths
would be authorized by this bill are
children older than six months who are
viable that is children who could have
been induced and delivered on the day
that they were aborted instead of being
killed and would have lived children a
lot like the children whose five corpses
were discovered in Washington D.C last
year where five star upscale abortion
clinic like the DuPont Clinic advertise
explicitly on their website that they
will perform abortions after 26 weeks
when there are no fetal anomalies
the second point that I'll raise is that
I have seen a number of statutes that
have no penalties and are purely
symbolic that refer to what the general
court will do or what an agency will do
but I have never seen in New Hampshire a
statute that falsely purports to
prescribe what citizens will do and I
think I haven't seen that because a
statute like the one that this bill
would create would be alien to the idea
of the rule of law we have always said
that we and our supporters prefer a bill
like House Bill 271 to a bill like this
one for reasons of clarity of
transparency and ultimately for reasons
of life because of the deceptive effect
that a bill like this would have
relatedly I think there might be a
drafting error in this bill it does not
remove the class B felony penalties from
RSA
329-36 so under the bill in front of you
a provider if he removed a child child
six months or older in pieces he would
face not so much as a parking ticket but
if he opted to move remove it more
quickly as intact as possible than under
section 36 he would be a Class B felon
in which I think in which case I think
some abortion providers might be in for
a surprise thank you and I'd be happy to
answer any legal questions about our law
or abortion law generally yes
representative Smith
thank you good afternoon I wonder if you
could help the committee by providing us
with written documentation of the ad
that you
described about New Hampshire
um
offices that offer
abortions
I believe you're referring to the part
of my testimony where I talked about
corpses of full-term children being
recovered in Washington DC and then I
referred to the fact that abortion
clinics there where there are no limits
on abortion explicitly say that even if
there are no fetal anomalies on their
own websites they will perform abortions
after 26 weeks I described Washington DC
as an as an example of what we might
look like if we explicitly allowed a
legal abortion thank you for clarifying
so none of that refers at all to what
happens in our state none of that refers
to thank you very much that has happened
in our state where no statistics are
collected on what abortions are
performed all right thank you any other
questions oops uh representative correct
yes thank you
if we eliminate civil penalties from
this statue will that eliminate section
47 which states simult civil remedies
the woman comma the father of the fetus
if married to the mother at the time she
receives an abortion in violation of
this subdivision comma and or if the
mother has not attained the age of 18 at
the time of the abortion comma the
maternal grandparents of the fetus May
in civil action obtain appropriate
relief relief unless the pregnancy
resulted from the plaintiff's criminal
conduct or if brought by the maternal
grandparents and maternal grandparents
consent to the abortion
such relief shall include monetary
damages for all physical
psychological and physical causes by the
violation of this substitution
would this
new house bill eliminate that
possibility if it because it's con
because it has the word civil penalties
well not only does it say that it
removes civil and criminal penalties but
if you look at the text of the bill it
removes that section you're referring to
47 so it removes the class B felony
penalties in 46 the Civil penalties in
47 it does not remove the class B felony
penalties in 36 which is the section I
referred to a moment ago okay so there
would be no ability for a civil penalty
for them the mother the Father the
whatever the grandparents okay thank you
it would entirely nullify our current
law and allow abortion at any time for
any or no reason okay
thank you
other questions to this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you Bethany
Iverson Chevrolet
I'm sorry and the next witness after
that will be whoa Richard
[Music]
La line La line I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly anyway you'll be next
after Miss uh Simmons
good afternoon members of the community
Judiciary Committee my name is Bethany
Severson and I am here with my twins
Micah Syverson and Landon cyverson you
guys want to wave
foreign
they've been here all day
um well we did take a break for lunch
get them out of here but um Micah and
Landon are the pride and joy of mine and
my husband's life yet their lives were
nearly destroyed by their birth mom at
some time after 20 weeks I don't know
exactly what um what week she went in
um when she walked into Planned
Parenthood with the intent to end their
lives once at her appointment by the
grace of God she decided that she could
not murder these little guys and our
family is so blessed because of that she
stood there in that in that Planned
Parenthood
um room recognizing that these lives
were inside of her these lies that at
Beyond 20 weeks already had fully
developed bones
um eyes eyelids a heart that was pumping
blood kidneys and other organs that were
pumping urine through their bodies teeth
buds beginning to develop and stuff like
that
um they also knew that they that these
that they had gender that they were boys
that they were identical boys and these
are our boys now
um
our boys who lit whose lives would have
otherwise been ended by the state's
abhorrent laws that at that time allowed
for the legal murder of babies human
lives inside the wombs
um
not by worse their lives were saved not
only not by moral consciousness of those
who were elected to protect those babies
but by the birth mom who intuitively
knew that those lives growing inside of
her were in fact human lives listen I've
been here and I've listened to some of
the testimony and I I have sympathy I
was gang raped at 13. I can stand behind
still at rape I went through my first
pregnancy and got preeclampsia I heard
an earlier testimony and I was extremely
sick delivering my first child my liver
and kidneys started to fail but all
along the line
these are human lives we have to
understand what abortion is it isn't
just a health care issue it is a life
inside of another human being that is
growing it is a life that has its own
perfect DNA from the time of conception
it is a life that has its own perfect
fingerprints unique fingerprints from a
very early age gestationally when we
understand what abortion truly is we
can't just then turn around and say it's
okay to just murder those lies because
whatever reason like their birth family
a married couple they were super
financially in in in
a very tight spot financially
and they understood that and they
recognized that the risk to having these
little guys would have been you know
detrimental to their marriage they made
that plan they went into Planned
Parenthood but ultimately she knew that
that was not okay
so
the the argument that
um that there are situations right when
I was raped at 13 I could have become
pregnant
and that would have been horrible at 13.
but that still would have been a human
being inside of me I've lived through so
many of these examples that are given
and I still would have chosen light for
every single one of them
so we as a state must protect these
babies from the atrocities and voting in
favor of House Bill 224 would gut a bill
that finally outlawed these barbaric
measures on a baby that can fully
survive outside of a mother's womb we
must recognize the truth I urge you to
vote in opposition of House Bill 224 and
vote for the wise and babies children
humans that all have a right to live and
have a life ready to be lived whether
that's through birth moms or an adoptive
family like ours there are choices we
argue that this is about choice but
there are choices the choice can be
adoption and we as a family are so
blessed because that mother chose life
for these two little guys
we're so blessed so um their lives
matter to us and uh to this planet to
the Future their lives matter and so do
the thousands of lies that can be saved
in New Hampshire by your vote in
opposition of House Bill 224 I don't
envy the job that you have but I would
urge you I heard another another
representative from Dover earlier say I
urge you to not vote with your stance on
abortion and I would strongly urge you
against that
I would really encourage you to vote
with
um the knowledge that these are human
lives growing inside of every single
woman and that is not to take lightly of
their situation again I could have been
in those situations and I was in some of
those situations it isn't taking those
things lightly but it is recognizing
that these are human lies so I'm happy
to take any questions and I have written
testimony for each one of you thank you
very much questions for this Witness
machine gun thank you thank you uh next
I I think it's Richard lessline I hope
it is and next after that is uh Patricia
glala
Richard
less line
should less line I'm I hope I'm not
pronouncing that incorrectly
of maybe Le plume
from
oh okay I don't I assume he must have
gone home next is Patricia glauer
um from Hanover
and after that will be Emily sosana
hello I spoke with you earlier my name
is Patricia gloa I'm a physician
um currently working through
Dartmouth-Hitchcock Medical Center in
Lebanon
I'm here to speak in support of House
Bill 224
and good afternoon to all of you and I
appreciate the opportunity to address
you
um
pregnant people and their doctors
sometimes face a terrible dilemma of
whether or not to continue a pregnancy
in the third trimester these
circumstances arise in this in the
context of lethal fetal conditions
where an abortion will save the fetus
from the suffering that would ensue if
the pregnancy is continued
the pregnant person may have serious
medical conditions
such that they may face worsening health
status and possibly even death if they
continue the pregnancy
those circumstances might include
worsening liver or kidney failure
heart failure a new diagnosis of cancer
that is more aggressive in the present
presence of pregnancy hormones and a
variety of other conditions
these situations are not easy
the painful decision to terminate a
pregnancy at these times is undertaken
with very careful considerations by both
the Physicians involved and the pregnant
person and their family
the doctors involved at these times
carry a heavy burden of responsibility
to work with the pregnant person and
carry out a difficult procedure
penalizing them for doing their
difficult job is cruel and inhumane
these doctors and their patients deserve
our support
not our opprobrium and Punishment
the repeal of the criminal and civil
penalties invoked by the fetal Life
protection act will allow our valuable
medical practitioners to continue doing
their difficult job with compassion and
skill not inhibited by the threat threat
of State prosecution
I'd like to make a side comment on this
issue of viability
there is no such thing as a
one-time definition of viability it is
an ark
yes there are some 24 weekers who are
resuscitated and survive
but you have to understand
that those are extremely sick infants
dependent on life supports and
medications and painful procedures
to make it to that point and they almost
all at that early gestational age end up
with physical disabilities of some type
or other
it might be blindness or visual
difficulties it might be intracerebral
hemorrhages such that they have
neurologic
um limitations
they may not be able to hear or speak
they may not be able to swallow food
because of
um death of portions of their gut they
may require long-term feeding tubes or
ventilators these are not
quote healthy viable fetuses
right the decision to continue that
pregnancy or to end that pregnancy is
dependent on those
Shades and gradations
of risk
and should not be penalized with
criminal penalties thank you all right
yes questions for this Witness
yes representative
yeah thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you um Dr gloa for your testimony
um I just wanted to clarify can you can
you envision or do you foresee that
there's any times when
um the provisions of the fetal Life
protection act would put you in Conflict
either with your Hippocratic oath or
with standard of care
I will
state that I am not in the position of
Performing abortions at that late
gestational age that is a highly
specialized
skill
I could imagine however that if I were
that kind of clinician
that I would be constantly worried about
every single decision to carry out that
procedure
worrying that
some aggressive prosecutor would decide
to
pillory me put me in jail deprive me of
my livelihood
and it would have a distinct chilling
effect on my ability to practice
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you Emily
cisano and I'm gonna We I see we have 15
more people listed to testify and given
the hour I'm gonna really request that
you keep your testimony to two minutes
please two minutes thank you
foreign
I should also say by the way anybody and
we we you can submit testimony
electronically to the committee if you
wish to do that please don't hesitate to
do do so thank you
hello again chairman Lynn and committee
members my name is Dr Emily zajano and I
ask you to support HP 224 repeal the
criminal and civil penalties from the
New Hampshire's current 24-week abortion
ban
the current law singles out medical
providers who have the training and
expertise to provide abortion care later
in a pregnancy there is no other
profession that the state has
criminalized this law is an invitation
for further intimidation and harassment
against these medical professionals and
has a chilling effect across the
healthcare landscape in New Hampshire
we have seen this reality play out
across the country
there is a significant shortage of
Health Care Providers already and
specifically in labor and delivery every
couple of years for the last 20 years
New Hampshire's in hospitals in New
Hampshire have been closing down their
labor and delivery units there are
obstetrical deserts in our state and as
nearly 200 providers said when the
original abortion ban was adopted
criminalizing the profession for
providing evidence-based care will
exacerbate difficulties in recruiting
and retaining critical OB GYN providers
I appreciate that last year the
legislature directed more money to
hospitals so they will continue offering
birthing Services however that will not
help New Hampshire families if there are
not enough Physicians with expertise to
provide care in those units
those proposing these criminal penalties
have likely never been in a room when a
woman has to hear her baby won't survive
or that continuing a pregnancy could put
her life in danger
or that there is nothing that can be
done to save a baby
I have been on both sides of those
discussions
it is devastating for the patient and
the medical team
the discussion and ultimate decision is
not taken lightly
the people of New Hampshire trust their
doctors to offer sound medical advice
the state legislature needs to do the
same
I urge you to support HB 224 and end the
criminalization of New Hampshire's
capable and trusted doctors thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
saying none uh over uh young I
and I know I know I've pronounced it I
know it's not open and that's policy oh
I apologize
oh I'm sorry I apologize Dr Young it's
probably it's easier to put it that way
Dr Young please
and so all right I uh
previously introduced myself so we can
forego that
uh I am I do want to say I'm here
testifying on behalf of the New
Hampshire Medical Society
and the Obstetricians in our state in
support of House Bill 224
I've long held
that there is a sacred
social contract
between Physicians
and Society
as Physicians we sacrifice a good
portion of Our Youth and Young adulthood
uh to train and learn the skills so that
we can devote the rest of our
life to caring for other human beings
Society
is supposed to for that Society is
supposed to create
uh reasonable fair environment
and I would argue
that the criminalization of physicians
in this situation
violates that social contract
given the complexities
of second trimester and early third
trimester pregnancies
this law
makes no sense
all it does is create a barrier or a
burden to the provider who's trying to
make the best decision
or his or her patient when it comes to
delivering or terminating a pregnancy
now let me just
give you uh or share with you a story to
illustrate what I'm talking about well
yeah you know we're trying to limit
everyone's testimony to two minutes
doctor so I can make it uh pretty quick
please
well I once I once had a position that's
what I present to me
she was very healthy
uh they achieved pregnancy without any
problems at 25 weeks
she presented
with severe preeclampsia a headache
swelling severe hypertension
and to save her life I performed an
emergency cesarean section the baby died
of complications of prematurity
this happened two more times by the
third pregnancy very unusual story she
delivered 26 weeks the baby survived she
survived
the baby has severe cerebral palsy but
otherwise as well
I'm telling the story to point out
how complicated the situation was and
the thought
of of thinking about criminalization in
making the decision to deliver her
seems unfaluable
I wouldn't have done anything different
than I did but who knows this might have
ended up
so the point I want to make
is that this social contract between
I'm shot as Mike often
don't don't do that
all right
so doctor I you're you're quite a bit
over your time and I appreciate your
being here but uh we we have a number of
other people we need to hear from so
thank you very much are there questions
for this
look with me in just
a verification
great I'm gonna thank these questions
for the generation of the committee
members who have other political
commitments this evening
so please
representative Macbeth thank you Mr
chair and thank you Dr Young for my
question in the scenario that you were
just describing
um when you had to do the emergency
C-section at the 26 weeks and on the
third time the baby did survive but is
that a situation where you might have
been criminally liable if the baby died
but you're not liable and won't get the
felony if it lives and that's the so
it's not only the mother's health but
it's the baby's Health that you're
worried about for these criminal charges
I'm
dependency
all right
questions
other questions for this Witness
representative
I just wanted to ask the same question
that I asked uh roughly of Dr gloa um
as as a former practicing
um OB GYN uh do you ever Envision that
there'd be the possibility of
this fetal Protection Law being in
conflict with either your your
Hippocratic oath or standard of care
turn on the microphone
foreign
all right
thank you other questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much doctor
um uh Josie Pinto
um so I'm actually here on behalf of an
OB GYN in New Hampshire is it okay if I
read her testimony or would you prefer
if I submit it uh why don't you submit
it and if you have you know if you want
to just sort of summarize very briefly
but you can submit it that's fine all
right I'll do that thank you all right
all right thank you uh Jason Hennessey
please and next after that will be Ben
Safford
Jason Hennessy
thank you again Mr chair my name is
Jason Hennessey I'm the president of New
Hampshire right to life and I'm here to
oppose HB 224
on behalf of our our many members uh we
already talked about a lot about a lot
about the reasons why we want to keep
the flpa in the previous uh hearing so I
won't dive into that uh but HP 224 is
essentially a repeal you know a law
without with no penalties carries no
weight so the question is is that the
direction we want to go
uh as as I said earlier the vast
majority of New Hampshire over 70 agrees
with abortion limits at some point and
six months is the latest
point that anybody could think of that
and if you look at our national
landscape
all right
so the question is what would be a
deterrent then from from doing this and
um there wouldn't be one also another
another thing I wanted to throw out
there is we just heard that uh most of
most late term abortions are uh not
elective but that disagrees with the few
statistics that we have where at least
in in one of the states that we have the
statistics for it's over it's it's
roughly over a little bit over half so
over 50 are elective uh and done for the
same reasons that early term abortions
are done
right anything else you want to tell us
sir uh I guess I guess one thing I would
say I just wanted to address the the
point that we would have trouble
recruiting uh recruiting Physicians here
in New Hampshire if 43 states have the
same law or even an earlier prohibition
and they also presumably have criminal
penalties I don't understand how that
would affect our our state's recruiting
ability thank you all right questions
for this weddings
saying none thank you uh
Ben uh Safford please
yep no that's fine I think that's I
think that's fine just speak speak up if
you would please and then after Mr
Safford will be Sam Safford
yep okay
honorable house Judiciary Committee
members good afternoon I am here today
to oppose HP 224
how many future doctors teachers firemen
legislators and parents have we lost
student abortion over the years their
dreams and contributions to our society
have been lost forever
in this great land of opportunity
someone like me with duchenne muscular
dystrophy has been able to live away at
college graduate with a degree in social
work serve others in my church and work
for a non-profit that helps others with
disabilities
as a person with duchenne I am living on
borrowed time right now my brother
Samuel and I have already exceeded our
life expectancy someone I know just
recently two weeks ago who was 24 years
old passed away with my condition and I
know some that have not survived their
teens and some that have made it maybe
to 31 32 but I'm pretty much over my
life's expectancy
we more than most know how fleeting and
frail life can be
my condition is you know you get it when
you're you can have it at Birth so it
can be under fatal phenol anomaly so
underneath that I could I could not be
here today my mother had elected to you
know uh take you know the Fatal
phenomenally and abort me I wouldn't be
here today
I'm thankful that I'm still here I'm
asking this committee not to return our
state to one that allows abortion on
demand up until the moment of birth if
this HB 224 goes through it guts the
fetal Life protection act from any
penalties and then just think about it
is it really needed as a law if it has
no penalty your might as well repeal it
because it won't have any any weight
the majority of Granite State or support
are modest 24-week abortion ban and do
not support unfettered abortion access
that's where we're heading if we pass
this please vote itl on HB 224 thank you
thank you questions to this Witness
saying none uh next I'm going to call on
Sam Stafford please
sorry it'll take us a minute all right
honorable house Judiciary Committee
members I am here to oppose HB 224
this bill would essentially return our
state to abortion on demand until birth
I am also here to represent represent
those in the disability Community who
cannot be here today
everyone even a person with a severe
disability deserves the right to live
and this bill would deny them that right
being differently able
doesn't make anyone less of a person who
is endowed by their creator with an
inalienable rights
the first of which is the right to life
whatever your thoughts on disability or
abortion I hope you'll agree that
killing a baby would be
would who would be viable outside the
womb after six months gestation is
prevalence please vote itl on HB 224
thank you thank you questions to this
Witness
seeing none thank you uh Lori Safford
please
I know
okay
it's amazing
so I'm here today not actually
representing myself but my friend Laura
Preston who is a high school science
teacher in Salem New Hampshire she
couldn't be here today just going to
read her testimony
as a pro-life woman who made a mistake
and had an abortion when I was 18. I am
appalled that the state of New Hampshire
is even considering going back to
allowing abortion of viable babies all
the way up to birth
when I was 18 my first year in college I
was scared ashamed
and uncourageous and I didn't want to
disappoint my widowed mother
I thought I took the easy way out having
an abortion at Planned Parenthood
but little did I know that I would be
haunted by this decision for the rest of
my life
since that time I have been on the
course to help in any way I can to save
the babies and to help women facing an
unplanned pregnancy
children are a blessing
there are many choices when having an
unplanned pregnancy including adoption
and I believe women deserve better than
abortion
we have two beautiful grandchildren we
happen to be raising because our
daughter made a couple of wrong choices
but she chose to have her babies instead
of aborting them I'm so proud of her
she was much more courageous than I
I feel like God has given me a second
chance with our grandchildren I have
been blessed beyond measure
whatever you think about the issue of
abortion
I hope we can all agree that
purposefully killing a viable child
after he or she has already developed in
the womb for six entire months is
unconscionable
please oppose hb224
thank you questions for this week
real quickly
um just because I have to really rebut
the two Physicians
um who said that they thought that
viability is still at 24 26 weeks I have
a very good friend Robin Moore who lives
in Framingham Massachusetts and her
daughter was born just months after mine
um I don't know what her issue was she
had a uterus that couldn't hold the baby
she was in bed for a couple of weeks
while she was pregnant and her daughter
Kaylee was born at 19 weeks she was
obviously in the NICU for some time
there were issues with her lungs and
they weren't sure if she would you know
be blind or not but she is a totally
typical 23 year old today and she
competes in dancing competitions if you
want to look up Kaylee Moore or Robin
Moore on Facebook you'll be able to see
her competing
so to say that 24 weeks is stretching
viability
is not true thank you very much
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you
um you know I I'm gonna next Witnesses
Dr Alana cash and I'm gonna I know that
the the representatives here from
Rockingham County have have to be at
another meeting at 6 30 tonight and so
I'm supposed to be there too but I'm
gonna hang in there as that I'm gonna
hang in here and share and I'm and the
other Representatives that need to go if
you're from Rockingham County and you
need to go please feel free to do that
we don't need a quorum for hearing
purposes and obviously I'm sure that
people who do have to go will will
listen to the testimony
um before we uh deliberate on the bill
uh so next I'm going to call on Dr Ilana
Cass uh for your testimony please
thank you very much uh chair and uh and
committee members so I'm the chair of
Obstetrics and Gynecology at Dartmouth
Hitchcock health and find myself uh
currently in the situation that many
have alluded to today
um just to remind you all I am currently
recruiting two Maternal Fetal Medicine
Specialists to Dartmouth health
I will remind the members of this
committee At Last At Last
uh sort of estimate we have seven such
Maternal Fetal Medicine providers in the
state of New Hampshire
um and two I am currently trying to
recruit as I'd indicated
and I'm urging you to consider
um the the benefits of of the uh of
hb224 this is become evident already in
my efforts to recruit Maternal Fetal
Medicine Specialists to care for the
women and families of New Hampshire
um this is already an issue in making a
hospitable and also a reasonable place
for them to practice the medicine that
they have been specially trained to do
to care for I might add pregnant
individuals with any range of medical
conditions trying to promote healthy and
safe deliveries for for our Granite
Staters but I'd like to invite you to
consider the downstream consequences of
the legislation that adds criminal
penalties for a provider in in the
sanctity of the relationship between
that provider and patient
the downstream consequences of criminal
persecution this has an impact on our
residency the only Residency program In
Obstetrics and Gynecology in the state
of New Hampshire this has an implication
for our medical students the only
medical school in the state of New
Hampshire this kind of environment makes
providers as you as you've heard from
many of my colleagues today more
apprehensive about delivering care
concerned that they will potentially
face criminal criminal consequences as
well as Financial consequences making it
difficult to impossible for them to go
on with their professional careers that
they have been trained specially to do
I'm happy to answer any of your
questions given the hour but I would
point out that this has far-reaching
implications for the healthcare
landscape of the State of New Hampshire
in which you've already heard very
important testimony about the shrinking
number of obstetrical units in our state
as indicated we have fewer and fewer
places where women can seek obstetric
care and to add criminal penalties for
providers further carries us along in a
Continuum which could grave which could
pose great Peril to the women and
families of the state
thank you questions for this Witness
yes representative
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I need your help
I'm reading and and this in part I think
is going to help I think in a
translation if you will from the legal
World which I'm a little more familiar
with to the medical world which I'm
completely unfamiliar with but you are
so I'm looking at 329 colon 46 that's a
criminal
penalties and it uses words that are
familiar to me by my training knowingly
performs or induces an abortion and
knows this is this is sort of getting
into the mental state of the doctor or
consciously disregards the substantial
risk those terms are I won't say
comforting to me in the statute but as a
lawyer they give me some Bedrock to look
to so but I'm wondering in the medical
room where all this is going on
it must be a little bit more complicated
than than that there must be scenarios
where it's not as linear as the lawyer
mind would like it to be for a criminal
code and I'm wondering if you could
describe that sort of complication
complicated kind of nature that I'm
guessing is there but I don't know yeah
so thank you for that excellent question
which I think really highlights the
point that many people have shared with
you today who are medical professionals
there is a tremendous amount of
uncertainty uncertainty in the context
of a pregnant woman who perhaps is in
the situation that the pregnancy
poses some concern or life-threatening
condition but just proximal to that as
things are sort of unfolding the
condition of that woman the condition of
that pregnancy can literally change by
the minute there can be uncertainty
about the gestational age of the
pregnancy which in and of itself we use
as an anchor but can be unpredictable
and the circumstance that I would submit
to you with with regards to some of the
uncertainty and how that plays itself
out you know we are seeing situations
currently in the United States of
America where providers in that space of
have things gotten to the point at which
and this could happen in the state of
New Hampshire can I definitively say
that the circumstances that I can see in
front of me mean that if I don't act
right now the patient will die as a
result of the pregnancy that can be very
vague territory territory and decision
making which can change by the minute
can be very ambiguous and can lead to
significant delays in care which can
make the imperil the condition of the
mother as the provider tries to decide
what the right thing is to do and to
compound that what is that provider to
do again in in Far Away places you know
where there is perhaps less access to a
immediate Maternal Fetal Medicine care
where in the middle of the night that
provider has to make a decision based on
their best evidence and best medical
judgment always with the fear that there
may be some criminal prosecution if that
individual has to second guess
themselves if the outcome is not as they
project or think it might be based on
best practice based on the best data
that they have in front of them so
there's a tremendous amount of
uncertainty and I would add that to
criminalize a provider who in
consultation with their patient is
trying to practice best prep care with
the best evidence adds a dimension that
is both dangerous to the patient
dangerous to The Physician and
ultimately can have implications for our
state as providers will invariably look
to that and decide I'm not going to
apply for that job I'm not going to
apply to that residency I am not going
to apply to that medical school
questions are the questions for this
week
thank you very much uh Peter chamberlad
der
thank you so much chairman and members
of the committee I rise in opposition to
the repeal
that has been placed before us I am
Peter Chamberlain I Pastor the granite
state Baptist Church here in Concord
I'll approach this from a I believe it
ought to be an ethical and immoral and
also a righteous Duty that there are
laws on the books
and the Very subject matter of a law is
to be enforced in fact if we were to
come back and look at the very
definitions that are given in in modern
dictionaries it is something to be
enforced by the body and without it we
cannot have law enforcement if there's
ever a law that ought to be enforced it
ought to be that which protects the
heartbeat from the beginning to the end
but as we look at laws that are on the
book
if they are to be enforced I would say
by the very repeal of this law goes
against the very nature of why we would
even have a governing body a legislation
or a governor in place
because there's no other lobbying to be
able to take away penalties for breaking
the law and so I know abortion has been
debated all day long I would think there
ought to be a correction on terminology
that's being used as person after person
stands up and calls it health care I
personally believe it's prejudiced
health care that's actually looking to
take care of the health of one human
being and not the life of another human
being and to not promoting the moral
well-being or the physical well-being of
those but then if we allow this to have
a law on the books
with no consequences no enforcement
whatsoever then what precedence it was
asked but not answered earlier what
precedence and where does this stop
does it stop with speed and tickets
can I then turn around and sue for
president for for
prejudiced enforcement of laws that it's
not being enforced one way or another
and so we look at these things doesn't
stop with stealing doesn't stop with
murder
what laws
are they're allowed to be on the books
that we do not have enforcement of those
laws by the very nature it's not a law
then and by the very nature we're not
lawmakers and there is no law
enforcement and so saying it's fine for
providing Health Care it is selective
and to be able to go and I'll just give
maybe some common sense to this
recruitment
for New Hampshire we have a speed limit
so maybe by us having a speed limit
let's follow that through maybe that's
going to hinder drivers from coming to
New Hampshire
well we see every weekend that that
doesn't and so I just believe that we
ought to enforce the laws that are on
the books there are some that have said
well maybe we could do this that's not
before the committee
you're not allowed to look at
Alternatives of what could be done until
those laws are submitted
this is a repeal but it would be a
repeal with no enforcement no
replacement of it therefore it takes a
law completely off the books and so I do
urge do not repeal this law
and have a law that has no consequences
whatsoever thank you for your time thank
you questions to this Witness
thank you see none thank you uh Jennifer
Lance clock Lance clock
hello thank you all for your time today
I know it's been a long day
um and you've heard so many testimonies
but I'm going to try to keep mine short
um I'm here to oppose hb224
um as a mother of four children I have
carried all those pregnancies to full
term and I can tell you honestly that at
24 weeks and Beyond
there is a real life inside of me and
at every point in the pregnancy but I
have felt my baby's dance when they're
happy I have heard I have
um had them give me gentle nudges when
I'm sad they're intuitive and real
um a lot of the testimonies today
um in regards to abortion though I hear
a lot of people Express concern
um
about women's rights with abortion but
the fundamental question I have
is that we should be asking is does an
onboard child have rights should they
have rights
and my question for everyone in this
room is
if your mother had chosen abortion how
many rights would you have today
thank you for your time thank you
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you my 11 year old was
wishing to speak of his own will is that
okay
very briefly very briefly keep it
briefly
my name is quintus lento and I am 11
years old and I opposed the home bill
224.
because I believe that all people have a
right and a reason to live
and to have a family
and if all these people proposing this
bill want everybody to have freedom that
infants should have rights and if
somebody can't afford babies
then
where does it say here
it stops writing there so I'm gonna just
go over here sorry thank you oh am I
done go ahead okay
to those who don't know how your babies
are boarded then you should look up the
most common abortion method but I will
say the most common second trimester
motion method is
dismembering the baby and taking it out
vote now on
on home Bill 224. thank you very much
Laura L Assam
thanks thanks to all of you for your
patience on this long day
um
the funeral Life protection act has only
been in effect since last January and in
those 13 months there's been like dozens
of bills it seems maybe only a dozen but
just so many bills that seek to gut it
and um just neuter it and this is yet
another one that will gut it and you
might as well just repeal it as several
people have said
um I am the parent of four children that
check every box for affordable according
to the stories I heard today
um and yet they disagree they are happy
healthy thriving young adults at this
point
um and I think that if any of you are
still considering this a sort of a
feminist issue a women's rights issue
then I would encourage you to think
again
um we listen to these stories today
we've come such a long way from the
Mantra of safe legal and rare and now
it's just legal doesn't need to be safe
necessarily doesn't need to be rare it
shouldn't be rare as a matter of fact to
hear some of these stories just needs to
be legal abortion for abortion's sake at
any time up until the day of the baby's
birth
um
and what's especially not feminist about
this is the term that I heard over and
over again today
they're racing woman and mother from
this equation and I find that tragic
again and again I heard
um pregnant people pregnant individual
there is dignity and Worth to Motherhood
and and femininity that just can't
replace and one of the cruxes of
femininity was we recognized that we
needed to protect the life in our womb
in fact womb was a synonym for a safe
place for for as long as I can remember
as long as the English language has been
around
but for some reason and I don't
understand that women have just
abdicated their role as Protectors of
life in their womb and so unfortunately
that means it falls to you
and I encourage you to just vote itl on
this it will essentially got and repeal
the FPL fpla and leave us with abortion
up until the moment of birth in the
company of some very bad
actors in the world that do not respect
human lives at all and it has a terrible
effect bleeding across all of society
when you don't respect human life thank
you thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none I have actually have two
cards I think are further from the same
well maybe not I'm sorry I have
Christopher duffley and Christine
duffley
that is correct thank you chairman thank
you members
um
uh I know it's been a long day so we'll
keep it brief but uh good afternoon late
afternoon now my name is Christopher
duffley I'm 21 in Manchester New
Hampshire and 21 years old
and um I am we are both here to oppose
HP to 224
um and I'll just quickly share my story
with you
um you know I really should be honest
with you I shouldn't be standing here
today
you know I was an unplanned pregnancy
and both of my biological parents were
using drugs which led to my premature
birth at 26 weeks gestation
weighing me just one pound and 12 ounces
pretty much like a small head of a
cabbage
I'm here today because we are discussing
an unborn children
that were just like me at risk in the
womb
my life my life and so many others in
this uh in this stage has value and
because I'm totally blind and live with
autism nothing has stopped me from
living a full and happy life
please remember that all life has inter
intra interested value and please
protect the lives of pre-born children
after 24 weeks and maintain the current
law as is on abortion here in New
Hampshire uh and and I will emphasize
without repeating the points that were
made by the other imposes today thank
you
thank you questions for this Witness
could
yes representative Smith yes
representative would it be
that
um machine that you're using
um yeah here I see why not so uh yeah so
um I'm using uh in in short terms I'm
using a uh it's a braille display and
this particular one is by Freedom
Scientific who makes uh blindness
products and it's a focus 40 blue and
it's a it's a bro display and I can so
with this particular thing all I can do
really is pair with my phone and be able
to uh be able to read from it and it's
uh but yeah it's it's interesting I've I
think this is the second time I've been
asked this question by a committee so
but anyway thank you very much it's yes
it was a pleasure to see how
smoothly you operated that yeah thanks
yeah that's a pretty cool device it is
nice
thank you very much I'm sorry did you
have something else you want to say uh
and Christine Daphne please
hello members thank you so much and we
have had a long day my name is Christine
duffley I'm from Manchester New
Hampshire I have five beautiful children
and the last one here Christopher he's
adopted
and I have a husband too
and I also run a non-profit for
inclusion education
I am grateful to come before you today
and to offer a few brief words opposing
HB 224.
now this past Sunday we witnessed
something
that some that people cheered and they
jeered for
it was the yellow flag signaling a
penalty
not just any penalty but one that
changed the outcome of a game that names
a champion and funnels millions of
dollars Fame and a Super Bowl ring
holding holding matters
where a big hole whether it was a big
hold or a small hold that call was made
to maintain the Integrity of the game a
line was drawn in fact I just got a
message on my phone and it says oops it
says I only have five more minutes
because my my meter is expiring and I'm
going to get a penalty
sorry so what I'm saying is penalties
matter and
today we are revisiting a very
controversial topic and all the emotion
of the final moments of the Super Bowl
but we're talking about human life
worthy of acknowledgment
and protection and why not the penalty
when a line is crossed you just met my
son Christopher one pound 12 ounces
25 26 weeks one pound 12 ounces you've
heard testimony today that lives that
small are not worthy
they're not productive
my son has influenced millions of people
all over the world I meet parents I get
emails of parents that have had
premature children that are thriving
like my son
folks life is precious
and I too believe that life begins at
conception but we have a law here in New
Hampshire that I will respect but I will
speak up and say
that we need to draw the line and have a
consequence or we're going to have the
invitations
for Physicians that will come if we have
24 weeks and other states have lesser
weeks gosh we're going to be in people
are going to come here
and we might even get positions that say
wow
we're going to make some money
everybody wants to take advantage of
something
but let not let's not happen to life I
mean I understand life is messy my
brother went to prison
and telling you
life is messy in all its forms
so today I'm just going to end I thank
you and reminding you that life is
beautiful
with all its unplanned and messy parts
let's not evaluate it any further
thank you very much questions to this
Witness
seeing none thank you uh Dina Stahl herb
stahlheber
Tina stahlheber
oh she Pals she passed okay okay all
right so that uh former representative
wolper
doesn't look like it looks like he left
all right and lastly I have Matthew
[Music]
Ood
from Dartmouth Health who said he's here
he's available to answer questions if we
haven't does anybody have any questions
for Mr who thanks Mr chair
um members of the committee I am I
didn't sign up to testify but my name
was referenced several times in
connection with uh some squid testimony
so I wanted to make myself available if
there were questions much more important
for you to hear from Dr Cass with
respect to the implications for
um recruiting Healthcare professionals
and for the ambivalence for providers in
this in the state in the space about
men's Raya you had raised that question
about knowingly earlier so I'm happy to
address any of those questions all right
questions for uh Mr
this is a former representative and
former senator
okay I'm sorry I should have recognized
that but I did not I have no apologies
are necessary just for sure but are
there questions for uh for Mr who
seeing none thank you very much sir
standing away between you and leaving
the committee is like a horrible posture
at band so thank you for your service
tonight I appreciate it thank you
all right I I think I've used I've gone
through all the pink cards is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on HB
seeing none I'm gonna close the hearing
and thank you all for attending and
thank my colleagues for hanging in there
for a long day I appreciate it very much
thank you